SO I SEE WE HAVE TWO AUTHORS
HERE. SO REMEMBER JOAN SAWYER, I
KNOW YOU'RE THE LAKERS. TRYOUT
IS A LITTLE LATER ON THIS
AFTERNOON, AND YOU'RE HOPING TO
MAKE IT SO. OKAY, WHY DON'T WE
GO AHEAD AND BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE? LET ME MAKE SOME
PRELIMINARY ANNOUNCEMENTS HERE,
WE'RE GOING TO COME TO ORDER,
PHYLUM NUMBER 25, A B 2037 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPPIN HAS BEEN
PULLED FROM THE HEARING TODAY
AND WILL RESET FOR OUR HEARING
ON JULY TWO. PHYLUM NUMBER 20
6AB 2388 BY SOME MEMBER JOE
PATTERSON HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
THE CONSENT CALENDAR DUE TO.
LATE OPPOSITION WILL BE HEARD
TODAY. OKAY, LET ME ANNOUNCE NOW
THE 15 BILLS THAT ARE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR, PHYLUM NUMBER
FOUR A, B 28, 85 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BAUER KHN. PHYLUM NUMBER
5AB 2154 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN. PHYLUM NUMBER EIGHT A, B
2337 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIXON,
WITH AMENDMENTS PHYLUM NUMBER
NINE A, B 3004 BY SOME MEMBER
MIKE FONG. PHYLUM NUMBER 11 A, B
1849 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON.
PHYLUM NUMBER 14 A, B 1575, BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN, PHYLUM
NUMBER 15 A, B 2114 BY SOME
MEMBER ERWIN, PHYLUM NUMBER 18,
AB 3282 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EXCUSE ME BY THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. PHYLUM NUMBER 19 A, B
3083 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
PHYLUM NUMBER 21 A, B 2248 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN WITH
AMENDMENTS PHYLUM NUMBER 24 A, B
2998 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCKINNON, WITH AMENDMENTS PHYLUM
NUMBER 30 A, B 2759 BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PETRIE-NORRIS WITH
AMENDMENTS PHYLUM NUMBER 31 A, B
1788 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA WITH AMENDMENTS AND
FINALLY PHYLUM NUMBER 32 A, B
2948 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS.
ALL RIGHT, SOME PRELIMINARY
INSTRUCTIONS. WE'RE GOING TO
FOLLOW THE SAME PROTOCOLS THAT
WE NORMALLY DO. SO WHAT WE'LL DO
IS WE'LL HAVE THE AUTHOR
PRESENT, AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
SUPPORT. THERE'LL BE TWO
WITNESSES. IF YOU CHOOSE TO HAVE
TWO WITNESSES, EACH OF THEM WILL
BE AFFORDED TWO MINUTES, THEN WE
WILL HAVE SUPPORT. IF YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT, YOU APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE, GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. WE'LL DO THE SAME
THING WITH OPPOSITION.
OPPOSITION WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
FOR EACH OF THE TWO WITNESSES.
IF THEY CHOOSE TO HAVE TWO
WITNESSES. AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED. THEY CAN
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AND
PROVIDE THEIR NAME, THEIR
AFFILIATION AND THEIR POSITION.
SO, WITH FURTHER, WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM, BUT WE ARE GOING TO
PROCEED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE. SO
SOME MEMBER JONES, SAWYER, IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO FIRST.
FOLLOWED BY PHYLUM NUMBER ONE AB
1905 BY SENATOR ADDIS, WHO IS
HERE? SENATOR JONES LAWYERS.
THANK YOU, MR. MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, AND I WANT TO THANK MY
FELLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FOR
ALLOWING SOMEONE TO GO FORWARD,
ESPECIALLY SINCE I HAD MY
SURGERY IN TWO DAYS. AND SO,
IT'S REALLY GOOD FOR ME TO GET
OFF MY FEET, TODAY I PROUDLY
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 3089, THE
CALIFORNIA APOLOGY ACT, FOR THE
PERPETRATION OF GROSS HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY, WITH SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION FOR AFRICAN SLAVES
AND THEIR DESCENDANTS. FIRST, I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS BILL AND CONFIRM
THAT I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS. THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. IT'S A BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THE BILL. IN 2020,
THE CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
CREATED THE FIRST IN THE NATION
STATE LEVEL TASK FORCE TO STUDY
AND DEVELOP REPARATIONS
PROPOSALS WITH A SPECIAL
CONSIDERATION FOR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. I HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF SITTING ON THAT TASK FORCE
WITH ONE OF YOUR COLLEAGUES,
SENATOR STEPHEN BRADFORD. FOR
MORE THAN TWO YEARS, THE NINE
MEMBER TASK FORCE HEARD
COUNTLESS HOURS OF TESTIMONY AND
RECEIVED THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS FROM STATE AGENCIES,
HISTORIANS, ECONOMISTS,
BUSINESSES, ATTORNEYS,
PROFESSORS, FAMILIES OF FORMER
SLAVE OWNERS, AND THE
DESCENDANTS OF SLAVES AND
SHARECROPPERS WAS BASED ON THAT
TESTIMONY AND DOCUMENTATION. THE
TASK FORCE ISSUED ITS REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE, A PAIN STAKING
RECITATION OF THE DEPLORABLE
TREATMENT OF AFRICAN SLAVES AND
THE WAYS IN WHICH CALIFORNIA AND
THE UNITED STATES BENEFITED FROM
FORCED HUMAN SLAVE LABOR, AND
HOW IT CONTINUED TO SUBJUGATE
BLACK CALIFORNIANS WELL INTO
RECENT TIMES. AS REQUIRED BY
STATUTE, THE TASK FORCE WAS
REQUIRED TO INCLUDE IN ITS
FINDINGS HOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL OFFER A FORMAL
APOLOGY ON BEHALF OF THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR THE
PERPETRATION OF GROSS HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS AND CRIMES
AGAINST HUMANITY ON AFRICAN
SLAVES AND THEIR DESCENDANTS.
THIS BILL IS THE COMPLETION OF
THAT CHARGE. AB AB 1389 IS THE
FIRST STEP IN TRUTH AND
RECONCILIATION PROCESS BY
OFFERING A FORMAL APOLOGY FOR
PAST WRONGS, CALIFORNIA WILL
JOIN NINE OTHER STATES THAT HAVE
OFFERED SOME FORM OF APOLOGY FOR
THEIR ROLE IN SLAVERY ALABAMA,
CONNECTICUT, DELAWARE, FLORIDA,
MARYLAND, NEW JERSEY, NORTH
CAROLINA, TENNESSEE, AND
VIRGINIA HAVE ALL ENACTED SOME
FORM OF APOLOGY FOR THEIR ROLE
IN THE SLAVE TRADE. EVEN THOUGH
CALIFORNIA ENTERED THE UNION AS
A FREE STATE, EVERY BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT FROM TOP DOWN HAS HAD
A HAND IN PERPETRATING THE
OPPRESSION OF BLACK
CALIFORNIANS. THIS BILL IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONFRONT THOSE
TOUGH TRUTHS IN A MEANINGFUL WAY
. IT IS LONG PAST TIME FOR THE
STATE TO ACKNOWLEDGE ITS ROLE
AND RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
ATROCITIES THAT PROMOTED AND
FACILITATED THE INSTITUTION OF
SLAVERY. WE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO AN STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS AND SHOULD
CONTINUE TO AFFIRM ITS ROLE BY
PROTECTING AND UPLIFTING THE
DESCENDANTS OF ENSLAVED PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED BY A LEGACY
OF STATE SANCTIONED POLICIES. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THIS BODY FOR ACKNOWLEDGING
THE FACT THAT IF WE CONTINUE TO
IGNORE OUR PAST, WE ARE DOOMED
TO REPEAT THOSE FAILURES. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE, EVERY CHILD, EVERY SMALL
CHILD IS TAUGHT THE IMPORTANCE
OF APOLOGIZING AS A MEANS TO
MAKE AMENDS. BUT IF WE EVER WANT
TO HEAL THE RACIAL TRAUMA IN
AMERICA, THEN IT BEGINS WITH
THIS APOLOGY. TODAY THANK YOU.
SENATOR. MEMBER. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. I DON'T I THINK I'M
YOU'RE IT I'M IT. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. WELL, I DON'T THINK YOU
NEED MORE. RIGHT. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GIVE US YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON. REBECCA GONZALEZ WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
LIZZIE KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD
AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
KRISTIN GOREE, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORPS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. JULIA LOPEZ WITH
GREENBERG TRAURIG, ON BEHALF OF
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, MARVIN DIÆN, ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
Dð COONEY, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. OPPOSITION
TO AB 3069. PLEASE THAT TO AB
3089 NEED GLASSES. ALL RIGHT,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE APPROACHES THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. ARE THERE
QUESTIONS SEEING NO QUESTIONS.
WE'RE A SUBCOMMITTEE. AND SO AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME, I'LL ASK
FOR A MOTION. AND THEN I EXPECT
THAT WE'LL HAVE A VOTE. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, SENATOR JONES.
JOAN SAWYER, SO QUICKLY CLOSE.
YOU MAY CLOSE. YES. GO AHEAD. I
ALSO WANT TO THANK MY FELLOW
CLBC MEMBERS, BECAUSE THIS IS A
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS PRIORITY. WE HAVE DOCTOR
KELLY WEBER, ASSEMBLY MEMBER,
AND WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE
GIBSON. THEY'RE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBERS.
WEBER AND GIBSON FOR BEING HERE
PRESENT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT,
WE'LL HAVE A VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. NEXT, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS. SO, AB 1905. AND BEFORE
YOU BEGIN, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS, LET ME MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT IN TERMS OF
PROCESS. SO WE HAVE HISTORICALLY
GONE IN ALPHABETICAL ORDER, AS
YOU NOTE TODAY, FROM A TO Z,
WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE THAT UP ON
JULY THE 2ND. SO WE'RE GOING TO
CHANGE IT AND WE'RE GOING TO GO
IN REVERSE ALPHABETICAL ORDER ON
JULY THE 2ND. SO I ASSUME THAT
SOME MEMBERS OF BR WILL BE QUITE
GLEEFUL. SOME MEMBER ADDIS MAYBE
NOT SO MUCH SO. ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. AB 1905. LET'S
MAKE TODAY A GOOD DAY THEN, BUT
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU, CHAIR.
AND STAFF AND ADVOCATES. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 1905, THE
RETREAT RIGHTS REFORM ACT, WHICH
IS PART OF THE CALL TO ACTION
BILL PACKAGE TO ADDRESS SEX
DISCRIMINATION AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IN HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND AS YOU MAY KNOW, I'M A
TEACHER AND KNOW FIRSTHAND THAT
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS AND THEIR
LEADERS MUST PROVIDE SAFE AND
AFFIRMING EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTS FOR ALL STUDENTS TO
LEARN, AS WELL AS FOR ALL STAFF
AND FACULTY AND FORTUNATELY,
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM IS NOT ONLY FAILED TO
PROTECT ITS CAMPUS COMMUNITIES,
BUT IS ACTUALLY REWARDED.
PERPETRATORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT, AND MORE. SO, I'M
OFFERING AB 1905, THE RETREAT
RIGHTS REFORM ACT, BECAUSE THE
TIME IS NOW TO END THIS KIND OF
MADNESS. THE TRUTH IS,
PERPETRATORS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT WHO HOLD HIGH LEVEL
POSITIONS IN CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEM HAVE LONG BEEN
REWARDED WITH THE RIGHT TO
RETREAT TO TEACHING JOBS WHERE
THEY CAN CONTINUE TO VICTIMIZE
STUDENTS, FACULTY AND STAFF, AND
OR LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION
THAT PROMOTE PRIVATE SECTOR
CAREERS. THESE REWARDS DISPLAY
DELIBERATE INDIFFERENCE ON THE
PART OF OUR HIGHER EDUCATION
CAMPUSES AND FRANKLY, ARE A SLAP
IN THE FACE TO SURVIVORS. SO AB
1905 WILL MAKE URGENTLY NEEDED
CHANGE, UNDER THIS NEW LAW,
THOSE WITH SUBSTANTIATED CLAIMS
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT WOULD BE
INELIGIBLE FOR RETREAT RIGHTS,
AS WELL AS POSITIVE LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION. THÀNH. IT IS
WELL PAST TIME, AND I THINK WE
CAN ALL AGREE ON THIS TO CREATE
JUSTICE FOR SURVIVORS, TO
RESTORE FAITH IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND TO PREVENT
FURTHER ABUSE. JOINING ME TODAY
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS KATE
ROGERS, CO-CHIEF OF POLICY FOR
GENERATION UP. EVERYONE,
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SO MY NAME IS KATE. I
AM THE CO-CHIEF OF POLICY FOR
GENERATION UP. WE'RE
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST ENTIRELY
STUDENT LED ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION, AND WE ARE PROUD
TO CO-SPONSOR TEN OUT OF THE 12
CALL TO ACTION BILLS, INCLUDING
AB 1905. SO THE CALL TO ACTION
REPORT EXPOSED THE GROSS
INADEQUACIES OF THE TITLE NINE
POLICIES ACROSS THE UC, CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEMS. YEARS
OF NEGLECT FROM OUR INSTITUTIONS
HAVE CREATED THE PROBLEMS, BUT
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN THE ONES
DEALING WITH THE CONSEQUENCES.
AND AB 1905 IS A KEY PART OF THE
SOLUTION. TO BE CLEAR, I DO NOT
BELIEVE THAT OUR UNIVERSE CITIES
ARE DIRECTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
EVERY INCIDENT OF MIXED CONDUCT
ON THEIR CAMPUSES. WHAT THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR, THOUGH, IS WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER. SO SPEAKING FROM
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS A UCLA
STUDENT, NAVIGATING THE TITLE
NINE PROCESS IS INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT AND MAKING THAT
DECISION WHETHER OR NOT TO COME
FORWARD AFTER SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
HARASSMENT IS VERY HARD AND
LIKE, ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE ARE
PSYCHOLOGICAL, ACADEMIC, AND
SOCIAL CONSEQUENCES. SO WHEN I
PERSONALLY HAD TO CONTACT MY OWN
TITLE NINE OFFICE, IT WAS
PRIMARILY TO PROTECT OTHER
STUDENTS. OF COURSE, I WAS
WORRIED THAT IT WOULD BACKFIRE
OR MAKE THINGS WORSE FOR ME.
SOMEHOW CHAU. BUT THAT WAS A
RISK I WAS WILLING TO TAKE AT
THE TIME, BECAUSE I WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT MY INSTITUTION
HAD ALL OF THE INFORMATION IT
NEEDED TO PROTECT OTHER
STUDENTS. SO YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW
DISHEARTENED I WAS WHEN THEY
CHOSE NOT TO. SO ONCE A SCHOOL
KNOWS OF A MISCONDUCT VIOLATION,
ESPECIALLY WHEN PERPETRATED BY A
FACULTY MEMBER, THERE IS NO
EXCUSE NOT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
SO AB 1905 WILL PREVENT
EMPLOYEES OF THE UC, CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT
HAVE VIOLATED HARASSMENT
POLICIES FROM ENDING UP IN
STUDENT FACING ROLES AGAIN, SO
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
PERPETRATORS ARE NO LONGER
ALLOWED TO REPEATEDLY VICTIMIZE
STUDENTS. SO ON BEHALF OF
GENERATION UP, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WITNESS.
PLEASE JUST THE ONE. ALL RIGHTY,
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION, AND YOUR
POSITION. BRENDA WOODBURY, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS AND PROUD
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LIZZIE
KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU, ALL RIGHT, LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 1905, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. QUESTIONS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS. WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM. BUT WHEN WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM, I AM ASSUMING WE
WILL GET A MOTION AND HAVE A
VOTE ON THE BILL. SO OKAY,
SENATOR WILK ASSURES ME. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. OH. I'M
SORRY. GO AHEAD AND CLOSE. WELL,
WITH THAT, I WILL JUST SAY THAT
WE DO BELIEVE AB 1905 WILL MAKE
A TRUE AND LASTING CHANGE, NOT
JUST FOR CALIFORNIA STUDENTS,
BUT FOR THE ENTIRE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY. AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WHEN THE
TIME IS RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. ONCE AGAIN, I
WILL NOTE THAT WE HAVE 100% OF
THE REPUBLICANS HERE IN
COMMITTEE, AND ABOUT 10% OF THE
DEMOCRATS. SO IF YOU'RE A MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE, WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO REPORT TO ROOM
2100 ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AB 2587, PHYLUM
NUMBER TWO, GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
SENATORS. I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR WORK
ON THIS, AND I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS TODAY. AB
2587 STRENGTHENS PROTECTIONS FOR
SURVIVORS OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT
AND GIVES SURVIVORS BETTER
ACCESS TO THE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
UNFORTUNATELY, AN ACT OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT IS COMMITTED EVERY 68
SECONDS. THE TOXIC CULTURE OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT SPANS ACROSS ALL
SECTORS OF EMPLOYMENT AND
SOCIETY. IT CAN HAPPEN TO
ANYONE, ANYWHERE, ANYTIME,
REGARDLESS OF AGE, GENDER OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION. FAR TOO
OFTEN, SEXUAL ASSAULT ALSO
INCLUDES A CULTURE OF COVER UP.
AB 2587 ALLOWS A LIMITED TIME
FOR SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
TO PURSUE OVERDUE RECOURSE FOR
THE TRAUMA THEY HAVE ENDURED,
BECAUSE IT CAN TAKE YEARS TO
FULLY REALIZE THE IMPACT OF AN
ASSAULT AND TO GAIN THE
CONFIDENCE TO COME FORWARD WITH
ALLEGATIONS. SURVIVORS NEED
SUFFICIENT TIME TO READY
THEMSELVES AND RETAIN COUNSEL TO
PURSUE THEIR RIGHTS. AB 2587
ALSO CLARIFY THAT A PERPETRATOR
OF A SEXUAL ASSAULT AND AN
ENTITY WHO COVERED IT UP ARE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE HARM
INFLICTED ON SURVIVORS BY
EXPOSING THESE PREDATORS, WE CAN
PREVENT THEM FROM REOFFENDING,
AND THAT MEANS OUR COMMUNITIES
ARE SAFER, OUR FAMILIES ARE
SAFER, OUR NEIGHBORS ARE SAFER,
AND THE PUBLIC AT LARGE IS
SAFER. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT IS, DOCTOR CAROLINE
HELDMAN, A SURVIVOR AND ADVOCATE
REPRESENTING STAND WITH US. AND
MIKE FINNEGAN, ATTORNEY AND
ADVOCATE FOR THE VICTIM POLICY
INSTITUTE. AND WE ALSO HAVE MY
STAFF WHO'S BEEN WORKING ON THIS
AS WELL, IF WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD AFTERNOON. COMMITTEE DOCTOR
CAROLINE HELDMAN WITH STAND WITH
SURVIVORS. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. STAND WITH
SURVIVORS HAS SPENT YEARS
SUPPORTING HUNDREDS OF SURVIVORS
OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND I AM ALSO
A SURVIVOR. AS A COLLEGE
STUDENT, I WAS RAPED BY A FELLOW
STUDENT IN HIS CAR MILES FROM
CAMPUS. WE BOTH WORKED AT THE
STUDENT NEWSPAPER, AND WHEN I
CONFIDED IN OUR EDITOR, MY BOSS,
SOMEONE I THOUGHT WAS A FRIEND,
SHE DISMISSED IT, CALLING IT, HE
SAID. SHE SAID EVEN AFTER MY
ATTACKER ADMITTED HIS GUILT IN
AN EMAIL, I WAS OSTRACIZED AND
FORCED OUT OF THE PAPER. I
LEARNED THE HARSH LESSON THAT
SPEAKING OUT ABOUT MY ASSAULT
ONLY LED TO MORE SUFFERING, SO I
NEVER WENT TO THE POLICE. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT COUNTLESS
SURVIVORS HAVE BEEN SILENCED BY
THE TOXIC CULTURE OF VICTIM
BLAMING AND STIGMA THEY FACE
WHEN THEY COME FORWARD. OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM NEEDS
THE CIVIL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO
PREVENT SEXUAL ASSAULT, BECAUSE
ONLY 1% OF RAPISTS WILL EVER
SPEND A SINGLE DAY BEHIND BARS.
STATISTICS SHOW US THAT 120
RAPISTS CAN BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
1225 SEPARATE ACTS OF
INTERPERSONAL VIOLENCE,
INCLUDING RAPE, BATTERY AND
CHILD PHYSICAL AND SEXUAL ABUSE.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT WHEN
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED PRIOR
LEGISLATION, BOTH THE
PERPETRATOR AND THE ENTITY
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE SEXUAL
ASSAULT ARE TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
WE MUST EMPOWER SURVIVORS TO
COME FORWARD AND SEEK JUSTICE
WITHOUT FEAR OF RETALIATION OR
SHAME. I APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THE TIME TO HEAR MY STORY TODAY,
AND FOR RECOGNIZING THE URGENT
NEED FOR CLARITY IN THIS LAW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS MIKE
FINNEGAN WITH THE VICTIM POLICY
INSTITUTE. I'M AN ATTORNEY WHO
REPRESENTS SURVIVORS AND I'M
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. BUT ALSO TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE. ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, IF YOU GIVE US YOUR
NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION, YOUR
POSITION. SAMANTHA MALONEY,
CO-FOUNDER OF THE PUNK ROCK
THERAPIST NONPROFIT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2587,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR.
MEMBERS JAMIE HUFF, ON BEHALF OF
THE CIVIL JUSTICE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA, STILL RESPECTFULLY
IN OPPOSITION. BUT PLEASE ADD TO
REPORT THAT WITH THE AMENDMENT
THAT THE COMMITTEE, IS ASKING
THE AUTHOR TO TAKE THAT WE ARE
GOING TO HAVE THE MAJORITY OF
OUR OPPOSITION COALITION REMOVE
OPPOSITION, AS STATED
PREVIOUSLY, KJAC HAS NO ISSUE
WITH THE PERPETRATOR OF AN
OFFENSE BEING INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL. THE COALITION HAS ONLY
ASKED THAT THE COVER UP
REQUIREMENTS STAY IN PLACE TO
ALLEVIATE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
OVERLY BROAD APPLICATION ON THE
BUSINESS ENTITIES. ON PRINCIPLE,
WE ARE OPPOSED TO REVIVING
CLAIMS SOLELY ON THE BASIS OF
THE HEINOUSNESS OF A DEFENDANT'S
ALLEGED CONDUCT. THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS EXISTS FOR OUR
JUDICIAL SYSTEM TO PROPERLY
DECIDE CASES ON AN ACCURATE,
RELIABLE EVIDENCE WHICH IS A
FUNDAMENTAL SAFEGUARD OF DUE
PROCESS. HOWEVER, WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE THOROUGH ANALYSIS
DONE BY YOUR COMMITTEE AND WE
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND HER
GREAT STAFF FOR THEIR COMMITMENT
TO WORK WITH US THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE ELSE. WELL, MAYBE. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU. CHAIR BERG.
ANDY BIRNBAUM, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND OUR
OPPOSITION IS, CONTINGENT UPON
POTENTIALLY REMOVING THE OR
MAKING CLEAR THAT PUBLIC
ENTITIES ARE NOT, SUBJECT TO THE
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL. IT'S
BEEN STATED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
IN MANY PAST ANALYSIS. BUT WHAT
WE'RE CONFRONTING IN THE COUNTY
OF LA IS THAT THE COURTS ARE
STILL ENTERTAINING THESE MOTIONS
AGAINST US. WE'RE FACING
LITERALLY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
CLAIMS. AND IF THE INTENT WAS
NOT TO INCLUDE PUBLIC ENTITIES,
WE BELIEVE THAT MAKING THAT
CLEAR WOULD BE ADVANTAGEOUS. SO
WITH THAT, THANK YOU ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING. YES,
SENATOR WILK YEAH, I JUST HAVE A
QUICK ONE BECAUSE I REMEMBER I
THINK IT WAS MAYBE LAST WEEK IN
THE LA TIMES. THEY HAD AN
ARTICLE ABOUT THIS, THIS VERY
ISSUE AND HOW MUCH IT'S COSTING
THE COUNTY OF LA. SO CAN YOU
ADDRESS THE COUNTY'S CONCERNS?
WELL, I'M JUST SO YOU KNOW THAT
AB 2587 IS BUILDING OFF OF A
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS DID
AB 277 OF LAST YEAR, AND THAT
BILL DID NOT INCLUDE THE PUBLIC
SECTOR IN THAT BILL. SO WE'RE
JUST BUILDING OFF OF THAT. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK,
OBVIOUSLY, WITH THE COUNTY. WE
JUST FOUND OUT THIS JUST A
LITTLE BIT AGO THIS MORNING,
THIS AFTERNOON, THAT THEY WERE
OPPOSING IT. BUT WE'LL BE MORE
THAN HAPPY TO WORK WITH THEM AND
THE OPPOSITION. OKAY GREAT.
THANK YOU. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO FURTHER QUESTIONS,
JUST A COUPLE COMMENTS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY, FOR WORKING WITH
US TO ONE NARROW THE BILL. BUT
TWO, AS I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS STILL A WORK IN PROGRESS,
THAT THERE IS SOME, STILL
CHALLENGES THAT REMAIN. I
UNDERSTAND YOUR FOCUS IS ON THE
PERPETRATOR, AND THAT'S WHAT WE
WANT TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT
THAT THAT THE PERPETRATOR DOES
NOT ESCAPE RESPONSIBILITY. SO
WITH THAT UNDERSTANDING, I
ASSUME YOU CONCUR, ABSOLUTELY.
DO I CONCUR? ALL RIGHT. YOU
KNOW, I WANT TO DO GOOD POLICY
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
MAKE SURE ANYONE THAT'S INVOLVED
OR HAS CONCERNS THAT WE ANSWER
THEIR ISSUES, SOMETIMES WE CAN'T
DO IT ALL. BUT I'LL GIVE IT MY
BEST SHOT. ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. CLOSE.
PARDON ME. YEAH, YEAH. THAT'S MY
CLOSE. I'LL GIVE IT MY BEST
SHOT. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AGAIN. THANK YOU. DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM, BUT IT'S SUCH
TIME AS WE DO. I EXPECT A MOTION
AND A VOTE. SO THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HELP. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, SEEING NO OTHER
AUTHORS HERE, I KNOW, I SEE, I
SEE, ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON
THERE. YES, HE IS AN AUTHOR.
YES. YOU BETTER HURRY. YES. OKAY
DON'T GIVE US OPENINGS WITH
LINES LIKE WEASELING IN. YEAH.
ASSEMBLYMAN RIGHT. TRUE. THERE
WE GO. WELL, THAT WAS. THANK
YOU, SENATOR NEIL. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. SO. OKAY GREAT,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR, SENATORS,
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB 2388, WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT PROHIBITS
STATE ENHANCES AN EXISTING LAW
THAT PROHIBITS STATE AGENCIES
FROM DISTRIBUTING, RENTING OR
SELLING AN INDIVIDUAL'S PERSON
INFORMATION FOR FINANCIAL GAIN,
UNLESS SPECIFICALLY AUTHORIZED
BY LAW. AND SO MODERNIZES THE
INFORMATION PRACTICES ACT OF
1977. SINCE THAT TIME,
TECHNOLOGIES HAVE KIND OF, YOU
KNOW, ENHANCED, SUCH AS CELL
PHONES AND CELL PHONE NUMBERS.
IT'S A NATURAL EXTENSION OF THE
EXISTING LAW AND INFORMATION
COLLECTED BY STATE AGENCIES,
THERE HAVE BEEN JUST OUR OFFICE
THROUGH THE COURSE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WE'VE BEEN
APPROACHED BY SOME GROUPS THAT
HAVE ASKED FOR CERTAIN MINOR
CHANGES AND WE CONTINUE TO HAVE
THOSE DISCUSSIONS ONGOING. AND
ALWAYS HAPPY TO WORK WITH ANY
OPPOSITION WE DID RECEIVE AFTER
THIS, PASSING THE ENTIRE
ASSEMBLY ON, YOU KNOW, PRETTY
MUCH UNANIMOUS SUPPORT. WE DID
RECEIVE A LATE LETTER FROM AN
ORGANIZATION OUT OF TEXAS ON
SATURDAY NIGHT, AND
UNFORTUNATELY, THAT RESULTED IN
THIS BILL BEING WITHDRAWN FROM
CONSENT, BUT ALWAYS INTERESTED
IN EVERYBODY'S, EVERYBODY'S
CONCERNS. BUT THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL IS TO ESSENTIALLY JUST
UPDATE THE EXISTING LAW AND MAKE
IT MORE CLEAR ON WHAT STATE
AGENCIES CAN AND CAN'T DO WITH
INDIVIDUALS PRIVATE INFORMATION.
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. ALRIGHTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH
SEEING NO WITNESSES APPROACHING
IN SUPPORT ANY ME? TWO WITNESSES
SEEING NO. ME TWO. OH, HERE WE
GO. Dð COONEY, ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION. STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO, AB 2388, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHING, LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONED
BY SENATOR WILK, THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY, BUT I KNOW YOUR YOUR
FRESHMAN. SO THIS IS YOUR FIRST
TERM, AND YOU MAY OR MAY NOT
KNOW THIS, BUT IT'S THE
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY OF THE
SENATE TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE
FROM THE STATE ASSEMBLY. SO SO
EVEN EVEN THOUGH I GOT NO, NO
VOTES IN THE ASSEMBLY, THAT
DOESN'T MEAN ANYTHING BECAUSE
IT'S COMING OVER HERE TO THE
ADULTS. BUT WITH THAT, HAPPY TO
MAKE A MOTION FOR YOUR BILL WHEN
THE TIMES COMMENT, THANK YOU,
SENATOR WILK, FOR SETTING THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS STRAIGHT. OKAY
WITH THAT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? OH, SENATOR NIELLO WANTS
TO ADD HIS $0.02. JUST, LET IT
BE KNOWN THAT THAT, ASSEMBLYMAN
PATTERSON'S SENATOR HAS NOT SAID
ANYTHING UNTIL NOW. OKAY, I
THINK THAT'S IN THE RECORD. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? WELL, THANKS,
I'M MOSTLY THANKFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME TO THE
SECOND FLOOR TODAY. IT'S THE
FIRST TIME I'VE BEEN HERE IN TWO
YEARS, AND. BUT I APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION. I'M SAD THAT WE
DON'T HAVE QUORUM YET, BECAUSE
I'D LIKE TO KNOW IF THIS BILL IS
GOING TO GET OUT OF COMMITTEE.
BUT I APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION. I APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND
COMMITTEE STAFF. SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WHEN THE TIME COMES. ALL RIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
OKAY. OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY WHO ARE AUTHORS OF
BILLS THAT ARE CURRENTLY
SCHEDULED TO BE HEARD IN SENATE
JUDICIARY, IT IS FIRST COME,
FIRST SERVE RIGHT NOW. SO THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE FLEET OF FOOT,
YOU MAY WANT TO HURRY ON DOWN TO
ROOM 2100.
SO THOSE OF YOU WHO Þ. HERE WE
GO. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. YOU ARE
RIGHT. FIRST COME, FIRST SERVE.
WE'RE EXCITED. IS THIS, AB 2003
77? YES. ALL RIGHT. AB C, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS. YOU TOOK ADVANTAGE. YOU
SAVED YOURSELF AT LEAST TWO
HOURS OF WAITING. SO. ALL RIGHT,
WITHOUT FURTHER ADO. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. ITEM NUMBER 34 ON
YOUR PLAY CARD, AB 2377. READY
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AND SENATORS, I WANT TO START BY
THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF.
ALISON, FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE ON THIS BILL. I ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. AS
NOTED IN PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS, AB 2377 SEEKS TO
PROVIDE ACCOMMODATION FOR K
THROUGH 12 STUDENTS PRACTICING
RELIGIOUS FASTING BY OFFERING
THEM A MODIFIED EXERCISE REGIMEN
OR PROVIDING THEM WITH ACADEMIC
ASSIGNMENTS RELATING TO PHYSICAL
EDUCATION. SPECIFICALLY, THIS
BILL REQUIRES WRITTEN PERMISSION
FROM PARENTS FOR STUDENTS UNDER
18 TO REQUEST PE ACCOMMODATIONS.
AS FASTING IS THE ACT OF
REFRAINING COMPLETELY OR
PARTIALLY FROM CONSUMING
ANYTHING OF SUSTENANCE DURING
RAMADAN, MUSLIMS FAST EVERY DAY
FOR 30 DAYS FROM SUNRISE TO
SUNSET. AS A SPIRITUAL
DISCIPLINE, PEOPLE IN THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY WHO OBSERVE YOM
KIPPUR, THE HOLIEST DAY OF THE
YEAR IN JUDAISM, PRACTICE A DAY
LONG, FAST AND INTENSIVE PRAYER
THAT REQUIRES FULL ABSTENTION
FROM FOOD AND LIQUIDS.
ADDITIONALLY, SEVERAL CHRISTIAN
DENOMINATIONS PRACTICE THIS FULL
OR PARTIAL FASTING ON CERTAIN
OCCASIONS, INCLUDING LENT. OTHER
STATES HAVE RECOGNIZED THE NEED
TO PROVIDE PROPER ACCOMMODATIONS
FOR STUDENTS OBSERVING RELIGIOUS
FASTING WITH ILLINOIS PASSING
HOUSE BILL 160, WHICH PERMITS
STUDENTS TO AVOID RIGOROUS
PHYSICAL ACTIVITY DURING PERIODS
OF RELIGIOUS FASTING. CURRENTLY,
STUDENTS FROM GRADES ONE THROUGH
EIGHT ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLETE
200 MINUTES EVERY TEN SCHOOL
DAYS, AND STUDENTS IN GRADES
NINE THROUGH 12 ARE REQUIRED.
400 MINUTES EVERY TEN SCHOOL
DAYS TO FULFILL THEIR PE
REQUIREMENTS. THERE ARE NO
GUIDELINES WITHIN THE SCHOOL
SYSTEM THAT PROVIDE
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR STUDENTS WHO
ARE FASTING DURING THE PE
PORTION OF THE DAY. THE
IMPLICATIONS OF FASTING IN
SUMMER DAYS ARE EVEN MORE
DANGEROUS, AS FACTORS LIKE
SWELTERING HEAT CAN CREATE
DANGEROUS SITUATIONS FOR
STUDENTS, SUCH AS HEADACHES AND
DEHYDRATION. TODAY I HAVE WITH
ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY, ROSA
HEYDARI, PRESIDENT OF THE AFGHAN
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AND MUSLIM
STUDENT ASSOCIATION FROM LAGUNA
CREEK HIGH SCHOOL, AND FAWZIA
FAROOQ, POLICY AND ADVOCACY
COORDINATOR AT CARE SACRAMENTO
VALLEY, CENTRAL CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. AND I'M SORRY TO
INTERRUPT, BUT JUST AS A
HOUSEKEEPING ANNOUNCEMENT,
TYPICALLY WE GO IN THE ORDER IN
WHICH YOU'RE LISTED IN
ALPHABETICAL ORDER, BUT BUT
SEVERAL OF YOU HAVE HEEDED MY
CALL. SO WE'RE GOING TO GO, THIS
WAS A PHOTO FINISH, APPARENTLY,
BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN,
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO,
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER, PELLERIN
I'M SORRY. WE ACTUALLY ASKED THE
SERGEANTS FOR AN OFFICIAL COUNT
OF WHO IS. OKAY, WE'RE NOT OKAY.
OKAY, OKAY, SO YOU KNOW WHAT?
SOME YOU GUYS CAN YOU GUYS CAN
GO AHEAD AND FILE A COMPLAINT.
IF I'VE GOTTEN THIS IN THE WRONG
ORDER, BUT AND THEN I SEE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO, AND THEN
AFTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO,
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO FILE
ORDER. OKAY ALL RIGHT. SO I'M
SORRY FOR THAT INTERRUPTION, BUT
I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT FOLKS
THAT ARE LISTENING SORT OF KNEW
WHAT WAS GOING ON. ALL RIGHT.
THE FLOOR IS NOW YOURS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHAIR, VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ROSA
HEYDARI. I'M THE PRESIDENT OF
BOTH THE MUSLIM AND AFGHAN
STUDENT ASSOCIATION AT LAGUNA
CREEK HIGH SCHOOL. THE ABSENCE
OF VALUING RELIGIOUS PRACTICES
IN EDUCATIONAL SETTINGS CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACT STUDENTS
EXPERIENCES AND ILLUSTRATIVE
EXAMPLE OF THIS ISSUE CAN BE
DRAWN FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OVER THE PAST TWO
YEARS. TWO YEARS AGO, I
SUSTAINED A KNEE INJURY THAT
REQUIRED MEDICAL ATTENTION UPON
PRESENTING A DOCTOR'S NOTE, I
WAS EXCUSED FROM ALL PHYSICAL
ACTIVITIES FOR TWO WEEKS, AND
FOR THE FOLLOWING THREE WEEKS I
WAS GIVEN ACCOMMODATED PHYSICAL
ACTIVITIES. THROUGHOUT THIS
PERIOD, MY GRADE AND PHYSICAL
EDUCATION REMAINED UNAFFECTED.
THE SCHOOL'S RESPONSIVENESS TO
MY MEDICAL NEEDS ENSURED THAT MY
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE WAS
PRESERVED DESPITE MY TEMPORARY
PHYSICAL LIMITATIONS. CONTRAST
WITH THIS EXPERIENCE. DURING MY
RELIGIOUS FASTING ABOUT A YEAR
LATER, I SUBMITTED A SIGNED
PARENTAL NOTE REQUESTING TO SIT
OUT OR HAVE ACCOMMODATED
PHYSICAL ACTIVITIES DUE TO MY
RELIGIOUS FASTING. WHILE I
WASN'T OUTRIGHT DENIED THIS
REQUEST, AN ACTION THAT WOULD
CONSTITUTE CLEAR RELIGIOUS
DISCRIMINATION, THE SCHOOL'S
HANDLING OF THIS SITUATION WAS
MARKED DIFFERENTLY. DAY BY DAY,
AS I EITHER SAT OUT OR ENGAGED
IN LESS STRENUOUS ACTIVITIES TO
HONOR MY FASTING, MY GRADE BEGAN
TO DECLINE. EVENTUALLY DROPPING
AN ENTIRE LETTER GRADE. THIS
DISPARATELY HIGHLIGHTS A
TROUBLING ISSUE THE FAILURE OF
ADEQUATELY ACCOMMODATE RELIGIOUS
PRACTICES. THE SCHOOL PROVIDED
ROBUST SUPPORT FOR MY MEDICAL
NEEDS. HOWEVER, WHEN I SOUGHT
SIMILAR ACCOMMODATIONS,
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR RELIGIOUS
PRACTICE, THE LACK OF SUPPORT
LED TO A SIGNIFICANT DROP IN MY
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE. THIS
EXPERIENCE UNDERSCORES A BROADER
CONCERN ABOUT THE RESPECT AND
VALUE PLACED ON RELIGIOUS
PRACTICES WITH THE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS. THE INSUFFICIENT
SUPPORT FOR RELIGIOUS
ACCOMMODATIONS IN SCHOOLS CAN
LEAD TO INDIRECT DISCRIMINATION,
WHERE STUDENTS ARE NOT GIVEN THE
SAME CONSIDERATION AS OTHER
NEEDS, AB 2377 TAKES A FURTHER
STEP TO TRULY HONOR THE
PRINCIPLES OF RELIGIOUS FREEDOM
AND EQUALITY. RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THESE PRACTICES, I
REQUEST THE COMMITTEE'S YES VOTE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. CHAIR, VICE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS FOZIA FAROOQ AND I'M THE
POLICY AND ADVOCACY COORDINATOR
AT THE COUNCIL ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS. WE PROUDLY
SPONSOR AB 2377, A BILL
ADDRESSING CRITICAL GAPS IN OUR
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEMS,
ACCOMMODATION OF RELIGIOUS
PRACTICES. EXCUSE ME. I'M
REFLECTING ON MY SCHOOL JOURNEY.
I FACED REPEATED CHALLENGES
DURING RAMADAN WHEN FASTING MADE
PARTICIPATING IN PE DIFFICULT
AND UNSAFE. LIKE MANY OTHERS, I
HAD TO NAVIGATE THE CONFLICT
BETWEEN ADHERING TO MY RELIGIOUS
PRACTICES AND FULFILLING SCHOOL
PE REQUIREMENTS, OFTEN RISKING
MY HEALTH AND ACADEMIC STANDING.
WHILE THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND
ARTICLE SIX OF THE US
CONSTITUTION BROADLY SUPPORTS
RELIGIOUS FREEDOMS. AB 2377
FOCUSES ON THEIR PRACTICAL
APPLICATION IN SCHOOL SETTINGS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES CLEAR,
ACTIONABLE GUIDELINES FOR
SCHOOLS, ENSURING THAT STUDENTS
WHO FAST FOR RELIGIOUS REASONS
CAN MAINTAIN THEIR OBSERVANCES
WITHOUT ACADEMIC PENALTY. THE
FIRST AMENDMENT SERVES AS THE
FLOOR, NOT THE CEILING, FOR
RELIGIOUS PROTECTIONS, ALLOWING
STATES TO OFFER GREATER
SAFEGUARDS. AB 2377 CODIFIES
THESE RIGHTS WITHIN CALIFORNIA
LAW, OFFERING SPECIFIC CLARITY
AND ENFORCEMENT THAT BROADER
CONSTITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES MAY
LACK. AB 2377 IS A PROACTIVE
MEASURE PROVIDING CALIFORNIA
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO PREVENT
POTENTIAL INJUSTICES BEFORE THEY
BECOME SYSTEMIC PROBLEMS,
DRAWING ON SUCCESSFUL PRECEDENTS
LIKE ILLINOIS HOUSE BILL 160. AB
23 ALIGNS WITH ESTABLISHED
PRACTICES SUPPORTING STUDENT
HEALTH AND INCLUSION. I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT AB TO SUPPORT AB
2377, AFFIRMING OUR COMMITMENT
TO AN EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THAT
HONORS DIVERSITY AND SUPPORTS
EVERY STUDENT'S RIGHT TO
PARTICIPATE FULLY AND SAFELY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GIVE US YOUR NAME,
YOUR AFFILIATION, AND YOUR
POSITION. SEEING NO ONE ELSE,
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2377,
PLEASE APPROACH. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. I'M DEVIN
FORD AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CAPARD, WHICH IS THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF HEALTH, PE,
RECREATION AND DANCE. FIRST, I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
PROVIDING A BALANCED BILL
ANALYSIS. AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHORS OFFICE FOR
WORKING WITH US. OUR POSITION ON
THIS MEASURE IS OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED. WE FEEL THERE'S A CLEAR
DESIGNATION. THERE NEEDS TO BE A
CLEAR DESIGNATION OF IDENTIFIED
RELIGIONS, A DEFINITION OF
FASTING, AND A CLARIFICATION ON
ALTERNATIVE ASSIGNMENTS. HERE
WITH ME TODAY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AND ANSWER QUESTIONS.
IS DOCTOR CHRISTOPHER BUSH 23
YEARS OF EXPERIENCE TEACHING
PHYSICAL EDUCATION AND PE AND
HEALTH? HE'S A PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT AND BOARD MEMBER OF
CAPERED AND WAS PREVIOUSLY A
SCHOOL DISTRICT ADMINISTRATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE, I'M DOCTOR
CHRISTOPHER BUSH, AND I'M A
PHYSICAL EDUCATOR, AND I HAVE
HAD EXPERIENCE IN THE FIELD FOR
23 YEARS. MY ORGANIZATION,
CAPERED, IS A NONPROFIT
EDUCATIONAL ORGANIZATION WHICH
ACHIEVES ITS MISSION BY TAKING A
STRONG STAND FOR SUPPORTING AND
ENCOURAGING AND PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE FOR QUALITY PROGRAMS
IN HEALTH, PHYSICAL EDUCATION,
RECREATION, DANCE, SPORTS, AND
OTHER MOVEMENT RELATED
ACTIVITIES. PROMOTING AN
ACTIVITY. EXCUSE ME? PROMOTING
AN ACTIVE AND HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
VÀ. IN REFERENCE TO THIS
MEASURE, AB 2377. LET ME BEGIN
BY SAYING THAT WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL IS WELL MEANING AND SUPPORT
RELIGIOUS FREEDOM. WE DON'T WANT
STUDENTS TO BE PENALIZED
ACADEMICALLY FOR THEIR RELIGIOUS
OBSERVANCES. WHAT WE FIND
CONCERNING IS THE ABSENCE OF
DEFINED RELIGIONS AND THE TIME
LIMITS WITHIN THOSE PROPOSED
BILL. THE CURRENT VERSION OF THE
BILL DOES NOT SPECIFY ANY TIME
CONSTRAINTS OR OFFER A CLEAR
DEFINITION OF WHAT CONSTITUTES
RELIGIOUS FASTING. THIS
AMBIGUITY RAISES THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER A STUDENT COULD SEEK,
EXCUSE ME, EXCUSAL FOR VARYING
DURATIONS RANGING FROM A SINGLE
DAY TO AN ENTIRE YEAR. WE
BELIEVE THE LACK OF GUIDELINES
WITH SPECIFIED TIME LIMITS,
DEFINED RELIGIONS, AND
DEFINITION FOR FASTING ARE
CRUCIAL ISSUES THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED. I'M AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS. ALRIGHTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION,
PLEASE APPROACH. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING, LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SENATOR WILK,
I'M TAKING SENATOR ARCHULETA'S
PLACE TODAY. I SUPPORTED THIS IN
EDUCATION PLAN AND SUPPORT IT
AGAIN TODAY. BUT I THOUGHT THOSE
WERE REALLY I THOUGHT THOSE
POINTS WERE WERE ON THE MARK. SO
IS THAT SOMETHING AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD, YOU'RE GOING TO TRY TO
ADDRESS WITH THE OPPOSITION?
WELL YOU KNOW, THE THIS STUDENTS
ARE EXPECTED TO BE ACCOMMODATED
ONLY FOR THE DURATION OF TIME
THAT THEY ARE RELIGIOUSLY
MANDATED TO FAST FOR. RIGHT.
IT'S NOT A YEAR LONG
ACCOMMODATION AND THEY'RE NOT
EXEMPT FROM PHYSICAL EDUCATION.
SO IT'S AN ACCOMMODATION EITHER.
IT COULD BE A LIGHTER WORK
WORKOUT REGIMEN OR, YOU KNOW,
SOME TYPE OF ALTERNATIVE. YOU
KNOW, ASSIGNMENT DURING THE PE
PERIOD. BUT IT IS NOT A YEAR
LONG OR YEARS LONG,
ACCOMMODATION. OKAY I KNOW THIS
IS HARD FOR YOU TO BELIEVE, BUT
I WAS KIND OF A SMART ALEC WHEN
I WAS YOUNG, AND I AND MOST
PEOPLE WHO DO THIS ARE, ARE
SINCERE. FOLLOWING THEIR
RELIGIOUS BELIEFS. I COULD SEE
PEOPLE GAMING, CATALOGING
CERTAIN RELIGIONS THAT WE KNOW.
I GUESS THAT STUMBLES ON FREEDOM
OF RELIGION. BUT IT'S NOT THIS I
DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE IT'S THE
STATE'S PLACE. RIGHT. TO DEFINE
RELIGION. WELL YOU. RIGHT I
MEAN, OBVIOUSLY OUR INTENTION.
YOU KNOW, I DID, IN MY, OPENING
STATEMENT, DID, YOU KNOW, TALK
ABOUT RAMADAN BECAUSE THIS THIS
IDEA FOR THIS BILL, CAME FROM MY
LEGISLATIVE AIDE, OMAR, FROM HIS
OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCES,
FASTING DURING RAMADAN WHEN HE
WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL. RIGHT. SO
THAT'S KIND OF THE WHERE THIS
BILL ORIGINATES FROM. BUT. AND
SO THAT'S WHAT I AM. I MEAN, I'M
SURPRISED THAT WE HAVEN'T
ALREADY DONE THIS. SO I SALUTE
YOU FOR THAT. I DON'T KNOW, I
LIKE YOU AS YOU GO ALONG TO
MAYBE I HAVE I HAVEN'T RECEIVED
A MEETING REQUEST. OKAY, FROM
THE OPPOSITION WITH ME. DID YOU
GUYS HEAR THAT, OKAY. AND, AND
LOST CONTROL. NO NO, NO, I SAW
TODAY. WAIT WAIT WAIT WAIT.
WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS QUESTION
AND ANSWER FORMAT, OKAY? ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR WILK, YOUR
QUESTION. NO, I'M GOOD. SO OKAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR SAYING
THAT AGAIN. SUPPORTING THE
EDUCATION I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
IT TODAY. RIGHT OKAY. THANK YOU,
WHEN SENATOR WILK MOVES TO
AMERICA, AS HE'S PLEDGED TO DO
NEXT YEAR, AND HE FORMS HIS
RELIGION, THE QUESTION I THINK
IS, IS HOW DO YOU DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN RELIGIONS THAT ARE WELL
ESTABLISHED VERSUS RELIGIONS
THAT HAVE, YOU KNOW, MAYBE
RECENTLY EMERGED THAT PROVIDE
FOR, YOU KNOW, FASTING FOR A
YEAR, WHATEVER IT MAY BE? I'VE
HEARD WHAT YOU'VE SAID. I'VE
HEARD WHAT THE OPPOSITION SAID,
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU TO FURTHER MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WILK ISM IS
INCLUDED AS, AS ONE OF THE
RELIGIONS THAT THAT MAY PROVIDE
FOR SOME. I JUST, I MEAN, I
RIGHT? I MEAN, I, I JUST, YOU
KNOW, I DO HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
THE STATE, YOU KNOW, I THINK
THERE IS FOR FREEDOM OF RELIGION
. RIGHT, AND SO I'M, I AM BEING
VERY HONEST WITH THE COMMITTEE.
RIGHT ON WHO, WHO GETS TO DEFINE
RELIGION IN OUR STATE, I GUESS.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? IS THAT
YOUR CLOSE, WELL, NO, I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND THE COMMITTEE, FOR, YOU KNOW
, YOUR SUPPORT OR. I'M ASKING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT, TODAY, AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. AND I
TAKE YOUR POINT ABOUT THE STATE
ESTABLISHING RELIGIONS, BUT I
ALSO TAKE SENATOR WILKS POINT IN
ALL SERIOUSNESS THAT THAT THERE
COULD BE SOME SORT OF,
DETERMINER OR DISCRIMINATOR
BETWEEN RECENTLY REFORMED
RELIGIONS THAT MAY NOT HAVE A
HISTORIC BASIS VERSUS ISLAM, FOR
EXAMPLE, WHICH HAS, YOU KNOW, A
FEW THOUSAND YEAR BASIS. SO, ALL
RIGHT, WITH THAT, WE DO NOT HAVE
A QUORUM, BUT WE WILL I EXPECT
THERE'LL BE A MOTION AND A VOTE
AT SUCH TIME AS WE HAVE A
QUORUM. OKAY. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRIEDMAN. SO JUST TO NOTE THAT
WHEN I ASKED FOR FOLKS TO aE
DOWN, AUTHORS, THAT THERE WERE
FIVE FEMALE MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY THAT IMMEDIATELY
APPEARED AND UNTIL RECENTLY, NO
MALES, JUST THAT THEY APPEAR TO
BE A BIT SLUGGISH. MALES APPEAR
TO BE A BIT SLUGGISH IN THE
ASSEMBLY. SO ALL RIGHT, SO
MEMBER FRIEDMAN, GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU. MR. CHAIR AND MEMBERS, AND
THANK YOU FOR ACKNOWLEDGING MY
FIRST PLACE FINISH IN THE RACE
TO BE HERE AS YOU MAY REMEMBER,
IN 2018, I HAD THE HONOR OF
CHAIRING THE JOINT RULE
SUBCOMMITTEE ON SEXUAL
HARASSMENT PREVENTION AND
RESPONSE. IN THAT COMMITTEE, WE
HEARD FROM EXPERTS AND ADVOCATES
FROM ACROSS THE SPECTRUM ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES IN PREVENTING
HARASSMENT. AND IN THE
LEGISLATURE, BOTH THE SENATE AND
THE ASSEMBLY TOOK STEPS TO
REFORM OUR OWN CULTURE AND TO
PROTECT OUR STAFF AND MEMBERS.
IT'S PAST TIME THAT WE HAVE
SIMILAR PROTECTIONS FOR STAFF
AND STUDENTS AT OUR COLLEGES,
AND UNIVERSITIES. AB 810 BUILDS
ON EXISTING BEST PRACTICES
ESTABLISHED BY UC DAVIS. BY
CODIFYING THEIR EMPLOYEE
VERIFICATION PROCESS FOR PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES. THIS
BILL PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL
LAYER OF PROTECTION FOR CAMPUS
COMMUNITIES BY PROVIDING ANOTHER
TOOL FOR HUMAN RESOURCES
OFFICERS TO ENGAGE WITH PREVIOUS
EMPLOYERS TO ASCERTAIN WHETHER
THE APPLICANT HAS SUSTAINED
ALLEGATIONS THAT MAY REMEMBER A
SUSTAINED AS IMPORTANT
ALLEGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT WHILE
EMPLOYED BY THEIR PREVIOUS
EMPLOYER. UNDER CURRENT LAW,
COLLEGES DO BACKGROUND CHECKS,
BUT UNFORTUNATELY, BACKGROUND
CHECKS DO NOT CATCH INCIDENCES
OR ACTIONS OF MISCONDUCT OR
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. THIS HAS
OPENED THE DOOR TO WHAT MANY
PEOPLE BELIEVE IS A COMMON
PRACTICE OF EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS PASSING THE
HARASSER, AS IT'S COME TO BE
KNOWN IN BOTH ACADEMIC AND
ATHLETIC SPACES. ACCORDING TO A
WHITE PAPER DONE BY THE NATIONAL
ACADEMICS ACTION COALITION ON
PREVENTING SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN
HIGHER EDUCATION, THE TERM IS
WELL KNOWN IN ACADEMIC CIRCLES
AND REFERS TO INSTANCES WHERE
FACULTY MEMBERS WHO ARE FOUND
RESPONSIBLE FOR SEXUAL
HARASSMENT CAN QUIETLY RESIGN
AND SEEK EMPLOYMENT AT ANOTHER
INSTITUTION, OFTEN WITHOUT
HAVING TO NOTIFY THEIR NEW
EMPLOYER OF PAST MISCONDUCT. MY
STAFF IS ALSO PROVIDED TO YOU
WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
COMMITTEE FROM A VICTIM THAT IS
UNFORTUNATELY EXPERIENCED SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AT HER UNIVERSITY,
ONLY TO SEE THAT SAME PROFESSOR
FIND EMPLOYMENT AT ANOTHER
NEARBY COLLEGE THAT WAS UNAWARE
OF THE SUSTAINED CLAIMS AGAINST
THIS PROFESSOR. BY REINFORCING
MORE ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE
HIRING PROCESS, ABA TI¾N AIMS TO
REDUCE THE PASSING OF THE
HARASSER FROM CAMPUS TO CAMPUS
TO PROMOTE A MORE SAFE AND
EQUITABLE ENVIRONMENT FOR CAMPUS
STAFF AND STUDENTS. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON IS
KATE ROGERS FROM CHEN UP. THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND IS ALSO PART OF THE
CALL TO ACTION PACKAGE MOVING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE. I
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATION AND WOULD REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIRMAN AGAIN. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. SO MY NAME IS
STILL KATE ROGERS, A CHIEF OF
POLICY FOR CHEN UP, SO WE'RE
REALLY PROUD TO BE CO-SPONSORS
OF ABA TEN. I'VE ACTUALLY BEEN
WORKING ON THIS SPECIFIC BILL
WITH FRIEDMAN'S OFFICE FOR
ALMOST A YEAR AND A HALF NOW,
AND WHAT I DIDN'T KNOW WHEN I
STARTED WORKING ON THE BILL WAS
THAT IT WOULD BECOME PART OF MY
LIVED EXPERIENCE AT UCLA AND
JUST A FEW SHORT MONTHS. SO IN
MY SOPHOMORE YEAR OF COLLEGE,
I'M NOW I JUST FINISHED MY
JUNIOR YEAR, A FACULTY MEMBER
REPEATEDLY HARASSED ME. HE WOULD
FOLLOW ME AROUND. HE LEARNED MY
SCHEDULE, LINGERED OUTSIDE OF MY
CLASSROOMS, AND EVEN CHASED ME
INTO THE BATHROOM SEVERAL TIMES,
AND I WISH I COULD SAY THAT I
HAD, IMMEDIATELY REPORTED THIS
TO MY TITLE NINE OFFICE, BUT I
DIDN'T. I HAD ALREADY KIND OF
LOST FAITH IN THEIR ABILITY TO
HELP STUDENTS WITH THIS SORT OF
THING. SO I JUST WITHDREW FROM
THE CLASS, WHICH IS STILL ON MY
TRANSCRIPT TODAY, AND I JUST
NEVER WALKED AROUND
UNACCOMPANIED. AND EVENTUALLY I
JUST STOPPED SEEING HIM. AND I
REALIZED LATER THAT THIS WAS
PROBABLY JUST BECAUSE HE PICKED
A NEW STUDENT TO TERRORIZE. SO I
FOUND OUT THAT A FRIEND OF MINE,
AN ACQUAINTANCE, HAD HAD THE
SAME THING HAPPEN TO HER WITH
THIS SAME FACULTY MEMBER. AND AT
THAT POINT, I CALLED THE TITLE
NINE OFFICE, BUT EVEN WITH TWO
STUDENTS AND LIKELY MANY MORE,
WITH THE SAME EXPERIENCE, WITH
THE SAME STAFF MEMBER, THE
SCHOOL DID NOTHING. THEY NEVER
EVEN EMAILED ME BACK AFTER I
TALKED TO THEM THE FIRST TIME.
SO ABA TEN WILL ENSURE THAT
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
HAVE ACCESS TO INFORMATION
REGARDING ANY PAST SUBSTANTIATED
ALLEGATIONS OF MISCONDUCT
AGAINST JOB APPLICANTS FROM
PREVIOUS EMPLOYERS. SO WHAT I
WANT YOU ALL TO THINK ABOUT IS
THAT IF WHAT HAPPENED TO ME AND
MY FELLOW STUDENTS AT UCLA DOES
NOT RESULT IN SUBSTANTIATED
MISCONDUCT, IMAGINE HOW SERIOUS
THE VIOLATIONS ARE THAT DO SO
IT'S THAT TYPE OF HARASSMENT
THAT THIS BILL WILL PROTECT
STUDENTS FROM. SO ON BEHALF OF
GENERATION UP, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THAT FACULTY MEMBER STILL
PRESENT, YES. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT. NEXT WITNESS,
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 810, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SOME MEMBER. FRIEDMAN, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE AGAIN THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT,
AND I WOULD REQUEST YOUR VOTE
TODAY TO BETTER PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM. WHEN WE DO, I EXPECT A
MOTION AND A VOTE. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
NEXT. OH, BY THE WAY, WE HAVE A
WRITTEN COMMUNICATION FROM
HANNAH HOLFORD. AND THAT WILL BE
INCORPORATED IN THE RECORD,
NEXT, MISS, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHABO. CLOSE THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS. I AM HAPPY
TO BE HERE TODAY, AND GRATEFUL
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 2499 TO YOU. NO PERSON SHOULD
LOSE THEIR JOB BECAUSE THEY NEED
TIME TO RECOVER FROM A TRAUMATIC
OR VIOLENT EVENT. AB 2499 WILL
ENSURE THAT FAMILY MEMBERS OF
LIVING DIRECT VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF TRAUMA CAN TAKE
UNPAID LEAVE AND TIME OFF TO
ADDRESS SAFETY CONCERNS AND HEAL
OR SUPPORT THEIR FAMILY. 1 IN 6
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENT CRIME
REPORT LOSING THEIR JOBS OR
BEING DEMOTED BECAUSE THEY
NEEDED TO TAKE TIME OFF
FOLLOWING THEIR TRAUMATIC EVENT.
53% OF SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REPORT LOSING A JOB
BECAUSE OF THE ABUSE, AND SEVEN
OUT OF TEN VICTIMS DESCRIBED
FEELING UNSAFE OR SCARED
FOLLOWING VICTIMIZATION. LOW
WAGE WORKERS, INCLUDING
IMMIGRANTS, WOMEN AND NON-BINARY
WORKERS, AND WORKERS OF COLOR
WHO ARE ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO
VICTIMIZATION, ARE ALSO LEAST
LIKELY TO HAVE THE EXISTING
FLEXIBILITY TO LEAVE OR LEAVE
PROTECTIONS AT THEIR JOB. WE
WORKED WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS AND HAVE
LIMITED THE AMOUNT OF LEAVE TO
TWO WEEKS OR TEN DAYS ALONG WITH
LIMITING THE REASONS FOR TAKING
LEAVE. ADDITIONALLY LEAVE IS
ONLY AVAILABLE AND USABLE FOR
COVERED REASONS. EXPERIENCING
VIOLENCE DOES NOT ENTITLE A
WORKER OR THEIR FAMILY MEMBER TO
SIMPLY TAKE WEEKS OFF OF WORK.
FEWER THAN 215 COMPLAINTS HAVE
BEEN MADE TO THE LABOR
COMMISSION ON THE BASED ON
SURVIVOR RIGHTS IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS, FOR WHICH DATA IS
AVAILABLE TO THE CRD. EXPECTS
ONLY 50 TO 100 COMPLAINTS PER
YEAR. EMPLOYERS WILL BENEFIT AS
WELL FOR THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE FAR
MORE LIKELY TO RETURN AND BE
ABLE TO BE PRODUCTIVE AT WORK,
GIVEN THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO
RECOVER. JOINING ME TODAY IS
MANNY SANCHEZ FROM CRIME
SURVIVORS AND FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE, AND ALSO JOINING IS
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY CATHERINE
WIDGET FROM LEGAL AID AT WORK.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR.
SENATORS, MY NAME IS MANNY
SANCHEZ. I'M A MEMBER OF CRIME
SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE. OUR PROGRAM REPRESENTS
A NETWORK OF OVER 50,000 CRIME
SURVIVORS IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
HERE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
2499. I CAME TO CRIME. I CAME BE
A CRIME. SURVIVOR CRIME,
SURVIVOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE. DUE
TO THE MURDER OF MY DAUGHTER,
JUSTICE. JUSTICE WAS TAKEN FROM
US WAY TOO SOON BY GUN VIOLENCE.
SHE WAS ONLY 19 YEARS OLD. SHE
HAD GOALS AND DREAMS. SHE WAS A
VERY LOVING AND CARING WITH THE
BEAUTIFUL, WITH THE BEAUTIFUL
SMILE. SHE WAS VERY SMART. SHE
WAS VERY SMART YOUNG WOMAN. SHE
STILL HAD HER WHOLE LIFE TO LIVE
. WHEN JUSTICE HAD PASSED, I HAD
ALREADY BEEN IN THE PROCESS OF
HEALING. MY MOM HAD JUST PASSED
AND I HAD NO MORE TIME OFF TO
USE. I STRUGGLED TO TAKE TIME
OFF TO MEET WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I NEEDED TO HELP MY
DAUGHTER, MY STEPDAUGHTER GET
MENTAL HEALTH SUPPORT TO PROCESS
HER GRIEF. I NEEDED MORE TIME TO
MEET WITH FUNERAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS. I'M STILL IN THE
PROCESS OF HEALING AND
PROCESSING MY GRIEF. IT'S GOING
ON TWO YEARS SINCE JUSTICE HAS
PASSED AND I STRUGGLED TO TAKE
TIME OFF FOR GRIEVING WITHOUT
HAVING A FEAR OF LOSING MY JOB.
WE, AS SURVIVORS, NEED THE BILL
TO BECOME LAW. THANK YOU SO VERY
MUCH FOR TAKING YOUR TIME AND
HEARING OUR STORIES. THANK YOU.
AND I KNOW THIS SOUNDS TRITE,
BUT. BUT I'M SORRY FOR YOUR
LOSS. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
I'M CATHERINE WIDGET, A SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGAL AID AT
WORK, AN ORGANIZATION DEDICATED
TO ADVANCING THE RIGHTS OF
WORKING FAMILIES AT OUR
ORGANIZATION, WE HAVE A PROJECT,
SURVIVE WHERE WE HEAR FROM
SURVIVORS WHO ARE REACHING OUT
TO US BECAUSE THEY'RE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THEY CAN DO FOR
THEIR SAFETY WITHOUT LOSING
THEIR JOB. AND IT'S NOT
SURPRISING, GIVEN THAT IN SOME
SURVEYS, OVER HALF OF SURVIVORS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND MORE
THAN 1 IN 6 SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE END UP LOSING THEIR JOB
BECAUSE OF THE VIOLENCE THAT
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED OR TIME OFF
THAT THEY NEED RELATED TO IT.
WHILE CALIFORNIA DOES HAVE SOME
PROTECTIONS IN PLACE, THEY'RE
NOT ADEQUATE FOR WHAT SURVIVORS
NEED, AND AB 2499 FILLS IN SOME
OF THOSE GAPS. FIRST, IT ALLOWS
SURVIVORS TO TAKE TIME OFF FOR
ADDITIONAL SPECIFIC COVERED
REASONS AND ALLOWS FAMILY
MEMBERS TO TAKE UP TO TWO WEEKS
OFF FOR REASONS RELATED TO
SAFETY AND RECOVERY. IT'S ONLY
FOR SPECIFIC REASONS. IT'S
UNPAID TIME, AND IT'S LIMITED TO
THOSE WHO WORK FOR EMPLOYERS
WITH 25 OR MORE EMPLOYEES.
SECOND, THE BILL ALSO EXPANDS
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION RIGHTS
TO ADDITIONAL SURVIVORS OF
VIOLENCE AS WELL AS THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS. SO THESE ARE ONLY
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR THE PURPOSE
OF SAFETY, WHERE THEY ARE
REASONABLE AND THEY DON'T IMPOSE
AN UNDUE HARDSHIP ON THE
EMPLOYER. AND THEN FINALLY, IT
ALSO STREAMLINES THE PROCESS FOR
ENFORCING THESE RIGHTS BY
PLACING THEM IN THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT,
ENFORCED BY THE CIVIL RIGHTS
DEPARTMENT. CURRENTLY, MANY
SURVIVORS OF VIOLENCE NEED TO
FILE WITH BOTH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER AND WITH THE CIVIL
RIGHTS DEPARTMENT, WHICH HAVE
SEPARATE PROCESSES,
INVESTIGATIONS, TIMELINES AND IT
CAN BE CONFUSING AND BURDENSOME.
SO PUTTING THEM WITHIN ONE
AGENCY WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
THOSE TWO WHO NEED TO ENFORCE
THEIR RIGHTS TO DO SO. NOBODY
WHO'S IN THE SAME POSITION AS
MR. SANCHEZ SHOULD HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT LOSING THEIR JOB WHEN
THEY'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF THAT
TRAGEDY AND TRYING TO BE SAFE.
FOR THOSE REASONS, WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2499? PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. NAME
AFFILIATION. POSITION. DANICA
ADAMO ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE AND STRONG SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND SENATORS.
MY NAME IS ANTHONY DEMARTINO.
I'M SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND CRIME SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE. CO-SPONSORS
OF THE BILL ALSO TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE FOLLOWING
ORGANIZATIONS. FRIENDS COMMITTEE
ON LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA LÀ
ALLIANCE FOR A NEW ECONOMY. LA
BEST BABIES NETWORK, NATIONAL
COUNCIL OF JEWISH WOMEN, LOS
ANGELES, ORANGE COUNTY EQUALITY
COALITION, PARENT VOICES,
CALIFORNIA, UFCW, WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL, WOMAN INCORPORATED,
WORKING PARTNERSHIPS USA AND
WORKSAFE. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
MEMBERS JANICE O'MALLEY WITH ACM
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS CONCEPCION. I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF CRIME SURVIVORS
SAFETY. CRIME SURVIVOR SAFETY
I'M ALSO THE MOTHER OF JUSTICE.
AND WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. HELLO. SARA DIAZ WITH
THE CALIFORNIA WILK ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. AND ALSO TESTIFYING
ON SUPPORT OF CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION, ASIAN LAW
ALLIANCE, BREASTFEED, LA CALIF
BREASTFEEDING COALITION,
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP TO END
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE, CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION, CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
ACTION, AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE CENTER FOR WORKERS
RIGHTS, CITIZENS FOR CHOICE,
COMMUNITY LEGAL SERVICES IN EAST
PALO ALTO AND ELECTRIC UNIVERSE.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
SENATORS AND MEMBERS. YVONNE
FERNANDES WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JUSTIN
BOWERS WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR
KIDS.ORG. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT IN
ADDITION NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND
JUSTICE ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEACE
AND THE NCCA ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING, LET'S TURN NOW TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2499, PLEASE
APPROACH. MR. CHAIR, MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, STEPHANIE
ROBERSON, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE,
I WANT TO FIRST THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SHIAVO FOR WORKING WITH
US. ONE, TO KEEP THE INTEGRITY
OF THE BILL, BUT ALSO TAILOR IT
AND PROVIDE SOME BALANCE TO THIS
BILL. BUT BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL
BE THE 10TH EXPANDED LEAVE ON
THE BOOKS, WE MUST BE REMAIN
OPPOSED FOR THAT REASON AND THAT
REASON ALONE. BUT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS BILL. BUT WE
REMAIN RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AND
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS, MR.
SANCHEZ. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIRMAN.
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE,
BRIAN LITTLE, CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU. I'M RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION,
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE. BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATE MEMBER ZERBO, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE, I THINK THE
WITNESS TESTIMONY WAS ENOUGH FOR
ALL OF US. RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. APPROPRIATE TIME.
I EXPECT THERE'LL BE A MOTION TO
VOTE. THANK YOU, THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OUR SERGEANTS ARE SO
GOOD. I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY
MISSED THAT. I APOLOGIZE, I
KNOW. WELL, MAYBE WE'LL HAVE
ANOTHER CHANCE FOR A RERAISE.
WELL, WE'RE GOING TO ON JULY
TWO. WE'RE GOING IN THE OTHER
ORDER. SO THAT WOULD BE SOME
REDEMPTION. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN.
GOOD AFTERNOON. AND YOU HAVE TWO
BILLS. I DO. RIGHT. SO THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS,
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AB 2249. I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS AND THANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THOSE UNDER
EXISTING LAW, SPECIFIC ELECTION
MATERIALS MUST BE RETAINED BY
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
RECORDS REGARDING FEDERAL
ELECTIONS MUST BE RETAINED FOR
22 MONTHS, AND ALL OTHER
ELECTION RECORDS MUST BE
RETAINED FOR SIX MONTHS. THE
PACKAGE CONTAINING THESE
MATERIALS MUST REMAIN UNOPENED
FOR THE DURATION OF THE
RETENTION PERIOD, AFTER WHICH
THESE MATERIALS ARE DESTROYED.
IN THE PURSUIT OF TRANSPARENT
ELECTIONS. THE PRESERVATION OF
THE PAPER AND ELECTRONIC RECORD
OF THE ELECTION IS OF THE UTMOST
IMPORTANCE. HOWEVER, THERE HAVE
BEEN CASES WHERE THE SECRETARY
OF STATE AND A COURT HAVE COME
TO DIFFERING CONCLUSIONS
REGARDING WHICH DOCUMENTS MAY BE
SHARED WITHOUT COMPROMISING THE
SECURITY OF AN ELECTION. IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE MORE CLARITY
REGARDING RETENTION AND DOCUMENT
ACCESS, AB 2249 CLARIFIES WHICH
MATERIALS MUST BE RETAINED BY
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS. AB 2249
ALSO REQUIRES AN ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL TO TAKE ALL REASONABLE
STEPS TO PRESERVE PACKAGE
RECORDS IN LIGHT OF A NATURAL
DISASTER OR OTHER UNFORESEEABLE
AND UNAVOIDABLE CIRCUMSTANCE. AB
2249 CLARIFIES THAT ALL VOTERS
MAY INSPECT THE CONTENTS OF THE
PACKAGE OR PACKAGES AT ALL TIMES
DURING THE OFFICIAL CANVASS AND
RETENTION PERIOD, ACCEPTING
THOSE ITEMS THAT CONTAIN
SIGNATURES OF VOTERS, WHICH MAY
NOT BE COPIED OR DISTRIBUTED. IN
ORDER TO PRESERVE THE SECRECY OF
THE BALLOT. AB 2249 IS SPONSORED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
MY WITNESS HAD TO GO HOME. SO,
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. AND AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THOSE IN
SUPPORT OF 2249 AB 2249. PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON. CHAIR MEMBERS.
TANISHA BOATNER, ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES IN SUPPORT OF AB
2249. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
LARISSA MERCADO. ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS FOR ELECTION OFFICIALS
AND SUPPORT. AGAIN, OUR WITNESS
HAD TO LEAVE. BUT, APPRECIATE
IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALYSSA
SALEHI, ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
CLERKS ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT,
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED
THE MICROPHONE, LET'S TURN TO
THE OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED TO AB 2249, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHING, LET'S BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS
BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NONE
. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE WHEN YOU GET A QUORUM.
WHEN WE GET A QUORUM, WE'LL DO
SO. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
MATTER NUMBER TWO. SO THANK YOU
AGAIN, MISTER. NUMBER 28 AB
2493. THANK YOU AGAIN, MR. CHAIR
AND SENATORS, FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB 2493.
I WILL BE TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THE AMENDMENTS
CLARIFY THAT REUSABLE SCREENING
REPORTS MAY BE ACCEPTED BY A
LANDLORD, AND THEY CANNOT CHARGE
A FEE IF THEY ACCEPT SUCH A
REPORT FOR NO ADDITIONAL CHARGE.
PURSUANT TO SECTION 19 50.1.
WHILE MANY LANDLORDS ARE RUNNING
ABOVE THE BOARD BUSINESSES,
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING SUPPLY
CRISIS, COUPLED WITH THE LACK OF
KNOWLEDGE ABOUT TENANTS RIGHTS
AMONG THE AVERAGE RENTER,
PRESENTS THE PERFECT WINDOW FOR
BAD ACTORS. AB 2493 REQUIRE
LANDLORDS TO EITHER TAKE THE
FIRST COME, FIRST QUALIFIED
APPLICANT OR USE A REUSABLE
APPLICATION. IT ALSO REQUIRES
THE LANDLORD TO PROVIDE A COPY
OF THE CREDIT REPORT TO THE
APPLICANT. AB 2493 WILL ALSO
PREVENT A LANDLORD OR PROPERTY
MANAGEMENT COMPANY FROM CHARGING
A POTENTIAL APPLICANT A FEE TO
BE ENTERED ONTO A WAITING LIST
FOR A RENTAL UNIT. IF NO RENTAL
UNIT IS AVAILABLE AT THE TIME,
OR WILL BE AVAILABLE IN A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME BY
PROHIBITING SUCH FEES, THE BILL
ENSURES TRANSPARENCY AND
PREVENTS APPLICANTS FROM BEING
FINANCIALLY EXPLOITED WHEN THERE
IS NO IMMEDIATE PROSPECT OF
SECURING A RENTAL UNIT. I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY ANNA
LUZ ACEVEDO AND VERONICA
MARTINEZ FROM THE COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZED FOR RELATIONAL POWER
AND ACTION, COPA, TOO, WILL
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. FLOOR IS
YOURS. MY NAME IS LUIS ACEVEDO
AND I AM A COPA LEADER AT OUR
LADY OF REFUGE CATHOLIC CHURCH
IN CASTROVILLE, HERE TO SUPPORT
AB 2493 COPA IS A BROAD BASED
ORGANIZATION COMPOSED OF 27
FAITH BASED, NONPROFIT AND LABOR
UNIONS IN MONTEREY AND SANTA
CRUZ COUNTIES. MY EXPERIENCE
WITH RENTAL APPLICATION FEES
TAKES ME BACK TO MY FIRST JOB
OUT OF COLLEGE. WHEN I DIDN'T
HAVE THE MONEY TO AFFORD PAYING
FOR THE TYPICAL MOVING EXPENSES
PLUS APPLICATION FEES PLUS
SECURITY POSIT, PLUS FIRST
MONTH'S RENT, AND AT TIMES, THE
LAST MONTH'S RENT TOO. SO MUCH
SO THAT THE ONLY THING I COULD
AFFORD TO DO WAS TAKE OVER
SOMEBODY ELSE'S LEASE SO I CAN
SAVE SOME MONEY ON THESE
EXPENSES, AND HAD THE PREVIOUS
TENANTS NOT LEFT THEIR BED
BEHIND, I WOULD HAVE SPENT THE
NIGHT ON THE FLOOR UNTIL I GOT
MY FIRST PAYCHECK. AND I KNOW
THAT MY STORY RESONATES WITH
MANY OTHER YOUNG PROFESSIONALS
WHO CONSTANTLY STRESS OUT ABOUT
THE COST OF MOVING. I KNOW
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT MY PEERS
AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
CONSTANTLY OVER THE YEARS. IN MY
CASE, I PAID OVER $500 IN
APPLICATION FEES, BUT I KNOW
THAT'S STILL LOW COMPARED TO
SOME OF MY PEERS WHO I PAID OVER
$1,000. IF PASSED, AB 2493 WOULD
HELP EASE THE BURDEN ON YOUNG
PEOPLE AND KEEP TALENT IN
CALIFORNIA. I WILL ALSO BE
TRANSLATING FOR VERONICA. ALL
RIGHTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
BUENAS TARDES A TODOS VERONICA
MARTINEZ DE COPA CON MUJERES EN
ACCION VENGO DE SALINA,
CALIFORNIA. NO HABLO ESPANOL Y
MISTICO Y ME ESPOSO Y YO TENEMOS
CUATRO HIJOS. CUATRO QUEREMOS UN
LUGAR MAS GRANDE PARA NUESTROS
HIJOS Y PARA ELLO QUÊ TENGA UN
ESPACIO MAS GRANDE Y PARA ESO
LUGAR CERCA DE LA ESCUELA, PERO
EL PROCESO PARA BUSCAR NUEVA
VIVIENDA ES MALO A PARTE DE
DEPOSITO. NOSOTROS SOMOS MAS DE
$300 PARA EL PRIVILEGIO. DE
PONER NUESTRO NOMBRE EN LA LISTA
DE VIVIENDA. NO ES
DISPONIBILIDAD ME HISTORIA NO ES
LA NUEVA. I MUCHAS PERSONAS EN
ME COMUNIDAD PAGA NOVENTA CINCO
CINCO CINCO DE CINCO DE ADULTO
POR CADA UNIDAD DURANTE BUSQUEDA
PARA LA FAMILIA Y MUCHOS ADULTOS
VIVEN A CHECK, A CHECK, A SEMANA
. ESO ES POSIBLE NÓ PARA ME KNOW
PARA LA COMUNIDAD. NO ÁP DE
CUATRO NÓ 23 AYUDA A FAMILIA
COMO ME FAMILIA NECESITA UNA
OPCION DE APOYO QUIEREN UNA
MEJOR VIDA PARA SUS HIJOS Y
CAMBIAR ESO. GRACIAS SO THIS IS
VERONICA MARTINEZ. SHE'S A
LEADER WITH COPA AND MUJERES EN
ACCION IN SALINAS, SHE SAYS I
SPEAK SPANISH AND MIXTECO. AND
I'M HERE TO SUPPORT AB 2493. MY
HUSBAND AND I HAVE FOUR
CHILDREN, AND WE WANTED A BIGGER
PLACE. SO OUR KIDS WOULD HAVE
MORE ROOM TO PLAY AND DO
HOMEWORK. AND SO WE COULD BE
CLOSER TO THEIR SCHOOL. BUT THE
PROCESS TO FIND A BIGGER
APARTMENT WAS TERRIBLE. ON TOP
OF THE SECURITY DEPOSIT AND
RENT, WE HAD TO PAY MORE THAN
$300 JUST FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF
HAVING OUR NAME ON WAIT LISTS
FOR APARTMENTS THAT WE LATER
LEARNED ARE TOTALLY FULL IN. MY
STORY IS NOT NEW. THERE ARE MANY
PEOPLE IN MY COMMUNITY THAT PAY
$95, $75, $55 FOR EACH ADULT FOR
EACH UNIT DURING A SEARCH FOR
FAMILIES THAT HAVE MULTIPLE
ADULTS AND LEAVE PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK, THE PROCESS IS
IMPOSSIBLE. AB 2493 HELPS
FAMILIES LIKE MINE WHO NEED
RELIEF AND WANT A BETTER LIFE
FOR THEIR KIDS. THANK YOU, THANK
YOU. OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT,
PLEASE APPROACH. GIVE US YOUR
NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION, YOUR
POSITION. Dð, LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE WITH ACLU CALIFORNIA
ACTION, A PROUD SUPPORTER. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. HELLO. JANICE
O'MALLEY, AFSCME, CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. JOSH GALLAGHER,
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA
CRUZ AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
L.A. HOLIDAY, ON BEHALF OF COPA
AND ITS 27 MEMBER INSTITUTIONS
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH. LET'S NOW TURN TO
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
2493, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOING ONCE, GOING
TWICE. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING NONE.
THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN, FOR
JOINING US. I'M FEELING A LITTLE
BIT LIKE THE MAYTAG REPAIRMAN
HERE, IF YOU LAUGHED AT THAT,
YOU'RE TOO OLD, I IT IS
IMPACTING MY SELF ESTEEM THAT
WE'RE HAVING CHALLENGES GETTING
A QUORUM. SO IF YOU HEAR THIS,
PLEASE REPORT. WE NEED AT LEAST
TWO MORE MEMBERS TO FORM A
QUORUM, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PELLERIN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? YES. THANK YOU. SO MUCH.
I DO WANT TO THANK MY, LIZETTE
JONES AND MY DISTRICT OFFICE,
WHOSE STAFFING THIS BILL AND IS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO TODAY. SHE'S
DONE AN AMAZING JOB, AND SHE
KNOWS FIRSTHAND THE STRUGGLES OF
A RENTER IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
COST OF GETTING A UNIT. SO THIS
BILL WILL REALLY GO VERY FAR TO
HELP HER AND OTHERS IN THE SAME
POSITION. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME, I ASSUME
THERE'LL BE A MOTION TO VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
HERE. SO, MEMBER HOLDEN, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO GO NEXT?
FIRST OF ALL, LET ME THANK YOU.
CHAIR UMBERG AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY ON ASSEMBLY BILL
2193, DEALING WITH HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY. AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW, CALIFORNIA ALREADY
CODIFIES LAWS IN 2006 THAT MAKE
ENGAGING IN HAZING UNLAWFUL.
DESPITE THIS, WE CONTINUE TO SEE
HAZING INCIDENCES OCCUR AROUND
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
OFTENTIMES PROVIDING PROVING TO
BE FATAL. IT IS CLEAR THAT OUR
LAWS ARE OVERLOOKING A KEY
PLAYER WHEN IT OUTLINING
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES. THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION ITSELF.
THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR A CIVIL
ACTION TO BE BROUGHT AGAINST AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION THAT
KNEW, OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN, OF
THE DANGEROUS HAZING PRACTICES
OF AN AFFILIATE ORGANIZATION.
ADDITIONALLY, THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES A REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION THAT AN EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION TOOK REASONABLE
STEPS TO ADDRESS HAZING IF THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION HAD
TAKEN SPECIFIED ANTI-HAZING
MEASURES AND REQUIRES
UNIVERSITIES REPORTING HAZING
INCIDENCES TO THE LEGISLATURE,
IT'S TIME WE HOLD ALL PARTIES
INVOLVED RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE
TRAGEDIES, IN THE HOPE THAT WE
CAN COME TOGETHER TO PREVENT
THEM IN THE FUTURE. HERE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
2193, OUR ATTORNEY AT LAW,
KRISTA RAMEY, ALONG WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS TO A VICTIM OF HAZING,
MARSHA KIMBLE AND WILLIAM
HILLIARD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. FLOOR IS
YOURS. OKAY. THANK YOU. MY NAME
IS MARSHA KIMBLE. OUR SON, TYLER
HILLIARD, WAS BORN MARCH 26TH,
1998. HE WOULD HAVE BEEN 26
YEARS OLD IN MARCH. TYLER LOVED
SPENDING TIME WITH FAMILY AND
FRIENDS. HE LOVED DANCING AND
BASEBALL, WHICH HE STARTED
PLAYING AT THE AGE OF SEVEN. OUR
SON HAD A PASSION FOR LEARNING.
WE SENT OUR SON TO èC RIVERSIDE
TO GET AN EDUCATION, BUT ONLY
TWO YEARS INTO HIS COLLEGE, WHO
WOULD HAVE PREDICTED WE WOULD
HAVE TO LAY OUR SON TO REST? ONE
OF TYLER'S GOALS AND ASPIRATIONS
WAS TO BECOME AN ALPHA BECAUSE
ONE OF HIS ROLE MODELS, DOCTOR
MARTIN LUTHER KING, WAS ALSO AN
ALPHA. THE THOUGHT OF LOSING
TYLER IS JUST HEART WRENCHING.
THE TREATMENT THAT HE RECEIVED
FROM AN ORGANIZATION THAT HE
HELD DEAR TO HIS HEART IS
SOMETIMES UNBEARABLE. WE ARE
FORCED TO RELIVE THE NIGHTMARE
OF LOSING TYLER EVERY TIME WE
SEE A YOUNG MAN DANCING, PLAYING
BASEBALL EVERY HOLIDAY LIKE
CHRISTMAS AND THANKSGIVING,
MOTHER DAY AND FATHER'S DAY, HIS
BIRTHDAY, AND EVEN LOOKING AT
OUR YOUNGEST SON, IT IS A GUT
WRENCHING PAIN OF A NIGHTMARE
THAT I CANNOT WAKE UP FROM. THE
PAIN IS THAT MUCH MORE
UNBEARABLE BECAUSE THIS COULD
HAVE ALL BEEN PREVENTED AND THIS
BILL WOULD HELP ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THE REGENTS SAY THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A DUTY OF CARE TOWARDS MY SON,
BUT THE FRATERNITY WON'T TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY EITHER. WHO WAS
LOOKING OUT FOR OUR CHILDREN?
IMAGINE SITTING AT THE SIDE OF
YOUR CHILD'S HOSPITAL BED WHILE
HE OR SHE IS ATTACHED TO A
VENTILATOR, UNRESPONSIVE,
FEELING HELPLESS, BEGGING GOD TO
SAVE YOUR CHILD AND TO TAKE YOU
INSTEAD BECAUSE YOU KNOW,
WITHOUT A SHADOW OF A DOUBT. YOU
WOULD TRADE PLACES WITHOUT A
SECOND THOUGHT, AND NOW YOU HAVE
TO MAKE THE DECISION TO REMOVE
YOUR CHILD FROM LIFE SUPPORT,
BECAUSE THERE IS NOTHING ELSE
THAT COULD BE DONE. WE BEG YOU
TODAY, IN THE NAME OF TYLER AND
OTHERS BEFORE HIM TO PASS THIS
BILL SO THAT NO OTHER PARENT HAS
TO EXPERIENCE THE LOSS OF A
CHILD AS A RESULT OF HAZING.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, AND WE'RE
SORRY FOR YOUR LOSS. AND THANK
YOU FOR CHANNELING YOUR PAIN
INTO SOMETHING THAT MAY BENEFIT
OTHERS. ALL RIGHT. OTHER
WITNESSES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN, AND I HAVE A STRICT
POLICY NEVER TO LET ANYONE CRY
ALONE IN MY PRESENCE. SO I'M
GOING TO PULL IT TOGETHER. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MY NAME IS KRISTA
RAIMI. I'M AN ATTORNEY, AND I'M
HERE TO TALK ON BEHALF OF AB
2193, I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
CONSUMER ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA. I'M AN ATTORNEY WHO
REPRESENTS, KIDS THAT HAVE BEEN
THE VICTIMS OF BULLYING, SEX
ABUSE AND HAZING. PARENTS CALL
ME WHEN SCHOOLS FAIL THEM AND
FAIL THEIR CHILDREN. AND MY
HEART BREAKS WHEN I HEAR STORIES
LIKE TYLER AND IN THEIR CASE,
THE REGENTS HAS SAID THAT IT
OWED NO DUTY, TO HIM, IN HIS OFF
CAMPUS ACTIVITIES WITH THE
FRATERNITY. WHILE FRATERNITIES
MIGHT EXIST OFF CAMPUS, THEY
FIND THEIR MEMBERS ON CAMPUS AND
THE CAMPUSES, WHICH, THEY FIND
THESE MEMBERS ON BENEFIT FROM
FRATERNITIES BEING THERE,
SCHOOLS HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY
NOT JUST TO TEACH OUR KIDS, BUT
TO KEEP THEM SAFE. WE BELIEVE
THAT 2193 MADE THE NECESSARY
CHANGES THAT THE GOVERNOR ASKED
FOR IN HIS VETO MESSAGE LAST
YEAR TO THIS BILL, AND WE MADE
CLEAR CHANGES WHEN IT COMES TO
WHEN LIABILITY ATTACHES. THIS
BILL NOW USES THE MORE STANDARD
LANGUAGE FOR NOTICE, AND THAT IS
USED WITH ALL GOVERNMENT ENTITY
CLAIMS FOR KNOWN OR SHOULD HAVE
KNOWN STANDARD. THERE IS ALSO A
COMPROMISE WITH THE REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION. THE CÁC HAS NEVER
SUPPORTED A BILL WITH A
REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION, BUT THE
CÁC HAS DECIDED THAT THEY WOULD
LOOK AT THIS ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS. THIS COMPROMISE WAS DONE
BECAUSE IN THIS INSTANCE, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS THE CURRENT
HOLES WITHIN THE LAW WHEN IT
COMES TO HAZING LAWSUITS ARE
ULTIMATELY A CHECK ON THE FREE
MARKET. HOLDING AN INSTITUTION
ACCOUNTABLE WILL ULTIMATELY,
CAUSE THAT INSTITUTION TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THEIR PRACTICES AND MAKE
THE NECESSARY CHANGES. AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES. THE
IDEA THAT THIS, IF THIS LAW
PASSES, WILL OPEN SOME SORT OF
LITIGATION FLOODGATE IS NOT
CORRECT. SUBSECTION C OF THE
PROPOSED LEGISLATION, THÀNH
ADDRESSES HOW TO AVOID LIABILITY
WHILE MAKING CAMPUSES SAFER. IF
THESE STEPS ARE FOLLOWED IN A
REASONABLE MANNER, THERE WILL BE
A REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION THAT
THIS SCHOOL ACTED REASONABLY.
IF, ON THE OTHER HAND, THEY DO
NOT, AND THEIR ACTIONS HAVE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE HARM, THEN
THEY MAY BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE. WE
RECOGNIZE THAT LAWSUITS ONLY
MAKE UP FOR THE HARM THAT IS
CAUSED. WRAP IT UP. AND, AND BUT
THIS LAW WILL HELP MAKE SCHOOLS
SAFER FOR OUR CHILDREN. I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR. AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. GIVE US
YOUR NAME, YOUR AFFILIATION,
YOUR POSITION. HI. JUSTIN BOWERS
WITH CLEAN EARTH FOR KIDS. ORG
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS. IN
ADDITION, ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO
NORTH COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE
ECO SUSTAINABILITY AND THE NCCA
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHED THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2193,
PLEASE APPROACH. GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS JOANNA HULL AND I'M A
LITIGATOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. HEARING FROM
THE PARENTS ABOUT THE PAIN OF
LOSING THEIR CHILD IS
HEARTBREAKING. CSU EXTENDS OUR
DEEPEST AND MOST HEARTFELT
SYMPATHIES TO THE FAMILY. WHILE
CSU IS HERE TODAY AND IN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED, POSITION, WE
WANT TO BE CLEAR THAT THE CSU
SHARES THE AUTHOR'S GOAL TO WIPE
OUT HAZING PRACTICES AND PROTECT
OUR STUDENTS. THE CSU SUPPORTS
THE PREVENTION MEASURES OUTLINED
IN THE BILL, AND WE BELIEVE THEY
STRENGTHEN OUR EXISTING
POLICIES. THE CSU IS ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED TO PREVENTING HAZING.
AB 2193 IS CURRENTLY IN PRINT.
GOES A LONG WAY IN ADDRESSING
THE CSU'S CONCERNS, AND WE
BELIEVE ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS
ARE NEEDED TO CLARIFY THE SCOPE
OF UNIVERSITY'S POTENTIAL
LIABILITY UNDER THE BILL FOR
EXAMPLE, WE BELIEVE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE BILL CLEARLY
SET FORTH WHEN HAZING INCIDENTS
MUST OCCUR FOR THE NEW CIVIL
LIABILITY TO ATTACH, AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED. THE BILL IS
UNCLEAR AS TO WHICH DUTY
ATTACHES WHETHER EXISTING LAW OR
THE BILL WE ARE SEEKING CLARITY
ABOUT THE TIMING OF THE DUTIES
AND OBLIGATIONS SET FORTH IN THE
BILL AS TO THE DATE OF THE
HAZING INCIDENT. WE HAVE SHARED
OUR PROPOSED AMENDMENTS WITH THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AND THE
AUTHOR. WE APPRECIATE THE
DIRECTION THE BILL HAS TAKEN SO
FAR, BUT WE BELIEVE ADDITIONAL
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS ARE
NEEDED. WE ARE MAINTAINING AND
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED, POSITION
AND WOULD BE WILLING TO SHIFT
OUR POSITION TO NEUTRAL IF AND
WHEN THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS ARE
ACCEPTED AND IN PRINT. I AM
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
MEMBERS MAY HAVE. THANK THANK
YOU. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND MEMBERS,
ALEX GRAVES WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES. I
WOULD ECHO THE COMMENTS FROM MY
CSU COLLEAGUE IN THAT ONE, WE
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH THE GOAL,
AND I DON'T THINK WE DISPUTE
MUCH IF ANY OF WHAT WAS WAS
SHARED BY THE LAST WITNESS IN
SUPPORT. AGAIN, I WOULD JUST ADD
THAT WE HAVE WORKED IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE CSU ON THE
ADDITIONAL CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS
THAT WE BELIEVE ADDRESS ANY
REMAINING CONCERNS AROUND
POTENTIAL AMBIGUITY IN THE BILL,
AND THINK WE'RE REALLY CLOSE TO
GETTING TO THAT POINT WHERE THE
LANGUAGE IS WORKABLE FROM AN
IMPLEMENTATION PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU. ALRIGHTY THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION. GOOD
AFTERNOON, NINA GRIFFIN, ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA, IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
. GOOD AFTERNOON. BRENDA BASS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SENATOR YELLOW. I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH. MY CONCERN IS THE
POSSIBLE REACTIONS THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE BILL COULD
CREATE, SPECIFICALLY THAT THE
AFFILIATED ORGANIZATIONS BECOME
NONAFFILIATED SO AS TO JETTISON
THE LIABILITY. HOW WOULD YOU
RESPOND TO THAT? YOU CAN'T
PREVENT IT. EXCUSE ME, SENATOR,
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THAT IF AN AFFILIATE HAD
COMMITTED AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
HAZING WAS BEING DONE AGAINST
YOUNG PEOPLE ARE DONE OR OUR
DAUGHTERS AND OUR SONS, THAT
THERE IS A RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
UNIVERSITY TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR SAFETY WHEN THEY STEP ON
THE CAMPUS. THE AFFILIATE IS A
PART OF THE UNIVERSITY, THE
FABRIC OF THE UNIVERSITY,
BECAUSE THERE'S BENEFIT THAT'S
GAINED FROM THAT AFFILIATE.
BEING A PART OF THE UNIVERSITY
EXPERIENCE. WHEN WE LOOK AT A
SITUATION WHERE AFFILIATE HAS TO
TAKE DUE CARE, AND THERE IS
LIABILITY THAT ASSIGNS TO THE
AFFILIATE, THERE IS ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY THAT THE
UNIVERSITY SHOULD HOLD. WE LAID
OUT A FAIRLY CLEAR AND I THINK,
VERY APPROPRIATE SET OF
STANDARDS TO BE FOLLOWED. THE
UNIVERSITY, QUITE FRANKLY, IF
THEY KNEW OR SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
AND THE AFFILIATE DID NOT DO
WHAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO DO,
THAT QUITE FRANKLY, THEY SHOULD
NOT WANT TO BE AFFILIATED WITH
THAT PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION IF
THEY ARE NOT, IF THEY ARE
CREATING AN UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT
FOR THE YOUNG PERSON TO WHETHER
IT'S A FRATERNITY OR SORORITY.
WE HEARD THE WITNESS TESTIFY TO
HER SON BEING IN AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT HE WANTED TO BE IN BECAUSE
THERE WAS VALUE TO THAT
ORGANIZATION THAT HE CONNECTED
TO. BUT IF THAT AFFILIATE
CREATED AN UNSAFE ENVIRONMENT,
THAT THERE SHOULD BE STANDARDS
OF WHICH WE SHOULD ALL WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF THEY CONTINUE
TO DO THOSE TYPE OF ACTIVITIES,
WE SHOULD NOT WANT TO BE
AFFILIATED WITH THEM IF THEY CAN
MEET THE APPROPRIATE STANDARDS
OF SAFETY, THEN BY ALL MEANS
THERE'S VALUE ADDED, BUT I
BELIEVE THAT QUITE FRANKLY, THE
UNIVERSITIES WOULD SHOULD LOOK
AT THIS ASSOCIATION AND QUESTION
IT THEMSELVES WHETHER OR NOT
THEY WOULD NOT WOULD BE WILLING
TO OR SHOULD CONTINUE TO HAVE
THAT AFFILIATE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE UNIVERSITY. YOUR LAST POINT
GOT TO MY QUESTION, THE
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES ARE
AFFILIATED IN MOST INSTITUTIONS
OF HIGHER EDUCATION. SOME CASES
THEY'RE NOT, AND THEY DON'T HAVE
TO BE IF THE INSTITUTION
ASSESSED THEIR LIABILITY, IF
THIS MEASURE PASSED AND THEY
ASSESSED THEIR LIABILITY
SITUATION, STATION AND THE
AFFILIATES AS THEY EXISTED, IF
THEY HAD CONCERNS ABOUT THAT
LIABILITY, IF THEY HAD THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE SAFETY OF
THOSE AFFILIATES, CGRTS, THEY
COULD JUST UNAFFILIATED ALL OF
THEM, WHICH WOULD SOMEWHAT IN A
WAY, GET TO THE INTENT IN THAT
THAT WOULD PUT THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS OUT AS
NONAFFILIATED. I'M NOT SURE THAT
IT WOULD STOP THE SYSTEM FROM
EXISTING, BUT IT WOULD FREE THE
INSTITUTION OF THE POTENTIAL
LIABILITY WITHOUT ACTUALLY
ALTERING THE UNDERLYING
POTENTIAL ISSUE. SO I'M TALKING
ABOUT UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. I
DON'T THINK THAT THE THAT YOU
INTEND FOR THIS TO RESULT IN
FRATERNITIES AND SORORITIES
BECOMING, UNAFFILIATED FROM THE
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION, BUT THE MERE PASSAGE
OF THIS MAY INDEED RESULT IN
THAT BECAUSE OF A FEAR OF
SIGNIFICANT LIABILITY. WELL I
THINK WHAT WE TRY TO AND YOUR
ARGUMENT, I THINK, PROBABLY HAD
AND MAYBE CERTAINLY RESONATED, I
THINK TO SOME DEGREE WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND I THINK WE HAVE
ADDRESSED THAT THIS YEAR, WITH
THE ISSUE OF REBUTTABLE
PRESUMPTION. AND TO LAY OUT
STANDARDS IN WHICH THERE COULD
BE A RELEASE OF LIABILITY FROM
THE UNIVERSITY. I DON'T THINK
WE'RE THIS THIS IS NOT AN EFFORT
TO TRY TO TORPEDO AFFILIATES
THAT OBVIOUSLY HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONNECTIVITY K¾T TO THE
UNIVERSITY EXPERIENCE, BUT IT IS
MAKING IT VERY CLEAR THAT WITH
LAWS THAT ARE CURRENTLY ON THE
BOOKS, THEY AREN'T GETTING THE
JOB DONE TO THE LEVEL THAT THEY
SHOULD. THIS. THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY. THE
UNIVERSITIES HAVE THEIR RELEASE
FROM A LOT OF LIABILITY, BUT WE
HAVE NOW THE OPPORTUNITY TO STEP
IN AND FILL THE GAP WHERE WE SEE
THERE'S A NEED TO DO SO. AND
WHEN YOU SEE YOUNG PEOPLE GOING
TO SCHOOL, GOING TO A UNIVERSITY
AND FINDING THEMSELVES IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY DON'T
RETURN HOME, SOMETHING
ADDITIONAL HAS TO BE DONE. AND
I'M HOPING THAT IT DOESN'T
BECOME A SITUATION. I DON'T
THINK IT NECESSARILY WILL, WHERE
THE AFFILIATES DECIDE THEY DO
NOT WANT TO BE A PART OF THE
UNIVERSITY, OR VICE VERSA, BUT
THERE HAS TO BE A RECOGNITION
THAT THE STANDARDS THAT WE ARE
PUTTING OUT THERE, THAT THERE IS
A DESIRE AND A AND A REAL,
CLARITY ON HOW THAT THE
STANDARDS WOULD BE ESTABLISHED
SO THAT THE UNIVERSITIES CAN
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
ON HOW TO ADDRESS ADDITIONAL
ISSUES THAT WE MAY HAVE TO
ADDRESS. I'M NOT EVEN IMPLYING
THAT IT IS THE INTENT OF YOUR
LEGISLATION TO, RESULT IN WHAT
I'M SUGGESTING COULD RESULT. I'M
TALKING ABOUT AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF THE LEGISLATION,
AND I'M NOT SUGGESTING THAT THE
AFFILIATED ORGANIZATIONS ARE
GOING TO AN AFFILIATE. I'M
SUGGESTING THE INSTITUTION OF
HIGHER EDUCATION WOULD REFUSE TO
RECOGNIZE THEM AS AFFILIATIONS.
THE STORY THAT WE HEARD IS
TRAGIC INDEED. I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE WITH THAT. I ABSOLUTELY
AGREE THAT WE SHOULD TAKE STEPS
TO TRY TO PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN. BUT WHAT I FEAR
IS THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
OF THIS LEGISLATION MAY NOT END
UP WITH THAT PREVENTATIVE EFFECT
. WELL, I THINK WHAT WE NEEDED
TO DO IS MAKE SURE WE HAD
APPROPRIATE STANDARDS TO GIVE
THE UNIVERSITIES AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVING MET THEM, TO BE NOT
HELD LIABLE. AS YOU HEARD OUR
WITNESS IDENTIFY. BUT AT SOME
POINT THAT COULD BE AN OUTCOME,
INTENDED OR OTHERWISE. THAT'S MY
CONCERN. BUT AT THE END, YEAH, I
HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING, BUT IF
WE CAN TIGHTEN THIS UP, WHICH I
THINK WE HAVE FROM LAST YEAR TO
THIS YEAR, I THINK WE ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE HOPEFULLY THE
UNIVERSITIES WILL SEE AN
APPROPRIATE RECOGNITION OF HOW
THEY CAN HOLD THE AFFILIATES
ACCOUNTABLE AND YET PROTECT
THEMSELVES IN IN THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU. OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? SENATOR STERN? YEAH,
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BACK.
I KNOW WE HAD, SIMILAR DEBATE ON
SOME OF THESE ISSUES LAST YEAR,
AND A LOT OF THE A LOT OF THE
TOUGH CALLS WERE MADE AROUND
THIS REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION
QUESTION, OR IF THE IF THE
UTILITY WAS IF THE UNIVERSITY
WAS MAKING BEST EFFORTS, HOW CAN
THEY PROTECT THEMSELVES? I'M
JUST I'D LOVE TO GET A SENSE
FROM EITHER YOU OR THE SPONSORS,
HOW HOW THINGS ARE GOING IN
TERMS OF THE CLARIFICATION
QUESTION THAT THE OPPOSITION
RAISED AND, YEAH, HOW FAR APART
ARE YOU? IT DIDN'T SOUND LIKE,
ANY MAJOR STRUCTURAL ISSUES, BUT
MORE SO WHAT, IS THIS GOING TO
BE BASED ON CURRENT LAW OR THE
NEW FRAMEWORK? AND THAT THEY
WERE TRYING TO GET SOME FOOTING
ON THAT? IF I COULD. SO, SO WITH
RESPECT TO THAT, WE DID GET
AMENDMENTS, PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
RECENTLY THAT WERE FORWARDED TO
ME. AND I'VE TAKEN A LOOK AT
THEM. AND SO THAT PROCESS IS
WORKING THROUGH THAT, THE FIRST
THAT I'VE HEARD ABOUT THE TIMING
OF THE LAW, I, I THINK THAT THAT
MAY HAVE BEEN ADDRESSED, I MIGHT
HAVE OVERLOOKED IT IN A MARKUP
OF, OF THE LEGISLATION THAT WAS
PROPOSED. AND I WOULD CERTAINLY
AGREE THAT THERE SHOULD BE
ABSOLUTE CLARITY AS TO WHEN A
LAW TAKES EFFECT AND WHEN
WHETHER OR NOT IT INCLUDES
INCIDENCES THAT HAPPENED BEFORE
THE LAW TAKES EFFECT OR NOT. SO
THERE NEEDS TO BE THAT CLARITY.
AND IF THERE'S NOT, WE'LL I
DON'T THINK THAT ANYONE HAS ANY
PROBLEM WITH MAKING SURE THAT
THERE IS, BECAUSE ALL
INSTITUTIONS NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY KNOW WHERE THEIR
LIABILITY MIGHT CHANGE. SURE.
THAT'S VERY HELPFUL. AND SO JUST
WHAT I'M HEARING FROM YOU OR AND
I PRESUME THE AUTHOR IS, WANT
THIS TO BE A GO FORWARD
FRAMEWORK, NOT A, NOT A
RETROACTIVE FRAMEWORK. IS THAT
OKAY? OKAY. VERY HELPFUL. THANK
YOU. ESPECIALLY FOR THE NOVEL,
STRETCHING WITH THE COWS HERE,
LOOK, THIS IS THIS IS TOUGH
TERRITORY, RIGHT? AND, I THINK
IT DOES TAKE CREATIVITY AND
FLEXIBILITY TO GET TO THIS, THIS
GRAY AREA OF THESE, YOU KNOW,
THESE ENTITIES, WHEN IT'S A
PARTY OFF CAMPUS AND TERRIBLE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING AND KIDS
LIVES ARE BEING LOST, HOW DO WE
GET THAT UNIVERSITY TO REALLY
STEP IN AND GO MAYBE ABOVE AND
BEYOND WHAT CURRENT NEGLIGENCE
LAW REQUIRES THEM TO DO AND THE
RESOURCES THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
ASKING OF THEM TO, TO UNDERTAKE.
SO I THINK IT'S ONLY RIGHT THAT
WE MANAGE THAT, THE LIABILITIES
THAT'S GOING TO GO WITH THAT
EXTRA DUTY OF CARE THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ASSIGNING. SO I
APPRECIATE THAT HOPE YOU ALL CAN
KEEP TO WORK WITH THAT
OPPOSITION. AND WE CAN LAND THIS
TO GET TO A NEUTRAL PLACE AND
GET THIS BILL SIGNED INTO LAW,
BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, OUR STUDENTS
NEED IT, ANYWAY, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
SENATOR STERN, LET ME JUST PUT
THIS IN A LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT.
I KNOW SOME OF THEM ARE HOLDING.
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR,
MORE THAN A YEAR. MORE THAN TWO
YEARS? AS A MATTER OF FACT, AND
THIS THIS HAS COME A VERY LONG
WAY. AND LET ME JUST POINT OUT
THAT, THE CONCERN ABOUT A ROGUE
ORGANIZATION OR A ROGUE
AFFILIATION DOING SOMETHING THAT
WAS OUT OF CHARACTER, THAT DOES
NOT, AT LEAST AS I READ THE
LANGUAGE THAT DOES NOT IMPUTE
LIABILITY TO THE INSTITUTION.
YOU'VE INCLUDED SOMETHING THAT
IS, VERY DIFFERENT THAN IN YEARS
GONE BY. SO FOR THE EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTION I'M READING NOW FROM
THE ANALYSIS, HAD DIRECT
INVOLVEMENT IN OR KNEW OR SHOULD
HAVE KNOWN EITHER ACTUAL OR
CONSTRUCTIVE KNOWLEDGE OR
ACTUALLY PARTICIPATED IN THE
HAZING PRACTICE OF THE
ORGANIZATION AND THE
ORGANIZATION INVOLVED IN THE
HAZING WAS AFFILIATED WITH THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTION. THIS IS
A VERY DIFFERENT THAN THAN THE
LANGUAGE THAT WE HAD BEFORE. AND
IT'S AND IT'S A FAIRLY HIGH BAR,
FOR LIABILITY TO BE ATTACHED TO
THE INSTITUTION. AT LEAST THAT'S
MY READ OF IT. SO, I APPRECIATE
THAT, AND HAVING SAID THAT, IF
THERE ARE OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS, I SEE NONE. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? WELL, FIRST OF
ALL, I WANT TO THANK YOU, CHAIR,
FOR YOUR COLLABORATION IN THIS
PROCESS AS WELL. YOU KNOW, I
I'VE GOT TODAY JUST SO HAPPENS
TO BE A COINCIDENCE THAT, MY
YOUNG LEGISLATORS ARE HERE
VISITING THE CAPITOL. ALL
GRADUATES OF HIGH SCHOOL, AND
WILL BE ENTERING COLLEGE IN THE
FALL. IF I COULD JUST HAVE THEM.
JUST. YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAND.
BUT WAVE YOUR HANDS, THERE WE GO
. YEAH. THANK YOU. THESE YOUNG
FOLKS ARE GOING TO HAVE AN
AMAZING COLLEGE EXPERIENCE.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
ALL THAT REPRESENTS THE COLLEGE
EXPERIENCE. AND THESE AFFILIATES
CGRTS PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
OPPORTUNITY. THEY MAY PLEDGE FOR
SORORITY OR FRATERNITY, BUT WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
PUT IN PLACE IN CALIFORNIA
STRENGTHENED LAW. AND AS WAS
POINTED OUT, I THINK WE HAVE
TRIED TO GO A NOVEL ROUTE TO BE
RESPONSIVE TO THE GOVERNOR'S
CONCERNS. AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
THIS COMMITTEE MOVING THE BILL
FORWARD. WE WILL CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONVERSATION WITH THE
OPPOSITION, AS I HAVE ON ALL OF
MY BILLS, AND TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE DOING OUR VERY BEST TO I
THINK AS SOMEONE MENTIONED, LAND
THE PLANE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. I
AM HOPING FOR A QUORUM VERY
SOON. MY SELF-ESTEEM IS QUICKLY
BEING RIGHT IMPACTED HERE. SO
COULD I JUST SAY ONE LAST THING
I WANT TO? I WANT TO THANK ALSO
MY WITNESSES, BECAUSE I THINK
THAT, YOU KNOW, EVERY TIME WE
PRESENT A BILL LIKE THIS AND
PRESENT THIS BILL TO A COMMITTEE
, THEY COME OUT AND HAVE TO
RELIVE IN FRONT OF THE PUBLIC
PAIN AND LOSS. AND I APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOGNITION OF
THAT, BUT I THINK THEY'RE
GROWING A BIT WEARY OF THIS
PROCESS. I KNOW I WOULD BE, AND
I KNOW I AM. SO I HOPE THAT WE
CAN GET THIS TO A PLACE WHERE
THERE'S A SENSE OF COMFORT THAT
THIS INSTITUTION HAS HEARD THEIR
CONCERNS AND NOT JUST THEIRS,
BUT FOR ALL THE FAMILIES THAT
THEY'RE SPEAKING TO. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. ALL RIGHT. SO,
CONSISTENCY IS THE HOBGOBLIN OF
SMALL MINDS. AND SO I'M GOING TO
GO AHEAD AND DEMONSTRATE THAT I
DON'T HAVE A SMALL MIND AND CALL
FOLKS IN THE ORDER IN WHICH THEY
ARRIVED VERSUS THE ORDER IN
WHICH WE HAVE FILE. SO, THAT
WOULD MEAN THAT WE WOULD GO WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON, THEN
HANEY, THEN MCKINNEY, THEN
ALVAREZ. SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WILSON, YOU NGUYEN RIGHT. I TO
MY COLLEAGUES, I WILL BE SURE TO
BE AS BRIEF AS POSSIBLE. AND I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE MY WITNESSES
ARRIVED IN THE ROOM. THEY'RE
HERE IF YOU'RE READY, SIR. I'M
READY. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, SENATORS,
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB 2257,
A BILL DESIGNED TO ENHANCE THE
TRANSPARENCY, EFFICIENCY AND
FAIRNESS OF THE RATE SETTING
PROCESS FOR WATER AND SEWER
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA. AT ITS
CORE, AB 2257 IS ABOUT FOSTERING
A CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOG BETWEEN
PUBLIC AGENCIES AND THE PEOPLE
THEY SERVE. UNDER EXISTING LAW,
PROPOSITION 218 REQUIRES PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE ADVANCE
NOTICE TO PROPERTY OWNERS, A
PUBLIC HEARING FOR PROTEST, AND
RESTRICT THE IMPOSITION OF FEES
UNLESS THEY REPRESENT THE ACTUAL
COST OF SERVICES. HOWEVER, THE
INCREASE IN PROP TWO, A TIME
PROP 218 LITIGATION CHALLENGES
LOCAL AGENCIES ABILITY TO SET
FAIR RATES TO COVER OPERATIONAL
AND INVESTMENT COSTS. OFTEN,
THESE LEGAL CHALLENGES COME
WITHOUT PRIOR OBJECTIONS BEING
RAISED DURING THE PUBLIC COMMENT
PERIOD, LEADING TO COSTLY AND
UNFORESEEN LAWSUITS THAT STRAIN
THE FINANCIAL RESOURCES OF THESE
AGENCIES. THIS BILL AIMS TO
RESOLVE DISPUTES EARLY AND
REDUCE THE FREQUENCY OF
LITIGATION, WHICH CAN BE COSTLY
AND TIME CONSUMING FOR BOTH
PARTIES. AB 2257 REPRESENTS A
BALANCED APPROACH TO RATE
SETTING. THIS BILL IS ABOUT MORE
THAN JUST PROCEDURAL ADJUSTMENTS
. IT'S ABOUT ENSURING OUR PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND OUR COMMUNITIES CAN
WORK TOGETHER MORE EFFECTIVELY
TO TACKLE THE CHALLENGES WE
FACE. WE'VE ACCEPTED ALL OF THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS, WHICH
PRIORITIZES THE PUBLIC NOTICING
PROCESS AND REQUIRES A LINK TO
THE FEES WRITTEN BASIS BE
PROVIDED IN PORTANTINO. THIS
BILL STILL PROTECTS THE RIGHT TO
LITIGATE AGAINST ONGOING
FAILURES BY AN AGENCY TO
IMPLEMENT RATES AND COMPLIANCE
WITH THE SUBSTANTIVE
REQUIREMENTS OF PROPOSITION TWO,
18. THIS ENSURES THAT AGENCIES
CANNOT MISUSE FEES FOR PURPOSES
OTHER THAN THOSE EXPLICITLY
STATED WITH ME TODAY ARE
CHRISTOPHER ANDERSON, SENIOR
STATE RELATIONS ADVOCATE AT THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES, ALSO KNOWN AS AQUA AND
CAITLIN BURSEY, ASSOCIATE AT
BAKER, MANOCK AND JENSEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FLOOR IS YOURS,
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS. CHRIS ANDERSON, ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES, AND
WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF AB 2257
PUBLIC WATER AND SEWER AGENCIES
PROVIDE ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT
SERVICES FOR THE BENEFIT OF
COMMUNITIES, AGRICULTURE,
INDUSTRIES AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
THESE AGENCIES ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ENSURING A CONSISTENT AND
RELIABLE WATER SUPPLY,
SAFEGUARDING THE QUALITY OF
DRINKING WATER, PLANNING,
CONSTRUCTING AND MAINTAINING
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE, AND
MUCH MORE. WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
PRESENTING UNPRECEDENTED
CHALLENGES, THESE AGENCIES ALSO
MUST ADAPT AND ENHANCE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MITIGATE THE
IMPACTS OF INCREASINGLY FREQUENT
AND SEVERE CLIMATE RELATED
EVENTS. BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS ARE
NECESSARY TO ENSURE WATER SUPPLY
RELIABILITY FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. PROP 218 PLACES
STRICT LIMITATIONS ON HOW
AGENCIES CAN RAISE REVENUE, AND
AS A RESULT, PUBLIC AGENCIES
PREDOMINANTLY RELY ON REVENUE
FROM SERVICE RATES AND
ASSESSMENTS TO FINANCE THEIR
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS.
WHILE THESE AGENCIES REQUIRE
FINANCIAL STABILITY TO MEET
INCREASING DEMANDS, A RISE IN
PROP 218 LITIGATION IS MAKING IT
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO ENSURE
AGENCIES CAN PASS FAIR AND
REASONABLE RATES TO COVER THE
COSTS OF OPERATIONS AND
INVESTMENTS. OFTENTIMES, THESE
SUITS ARE FILED WITHOUT FIRST
HAVING RAISED CONCERNS DURING
THE RATE MAKING PROCESS. THESE
SURPRISE LAWSUITS PREVENT PUBLIC
AGENCIES FROM ENDEAVORING TO
RESOLVE THE DISPUTE AND AVOID
LITIGATION, AND THEY ALSO HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO UNDERMINE AN
AGENCY'S ABILITY TO MAINTAIN,
MAINTAIN STABLE BUDGETS
NECESSARY TO OPERATE
EFFECTIVELY. THIS BILL WILL
BOLSTER THE EXISTING RATE MAKING
PROCESS IN ORDER TO ENHANCE
DIALOG AND TRANSPARENT Kò
BETWEEN PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
THEIR CUSTOMERS. THE GOAL OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS TO SHINE
SUNLIGHT ON POTENTIAL OBJECTIONS
TO PROPOSED RATES OR
ASSESSMENTS. WHEN AGENCIES HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS. JUST WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE, THE STAFF, CERTAINLY
THE AUTHOR, FOR CARRYING THIS
BILL. AND ALSO NOTE A ME TOO, IN
SUPPORT FOR PADRE DAM MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME
IS CAITLIN BURSEY, AND I'M AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE FRESNO BASED
LAW FIRM OF BAKER, MANAK AND
JENSEN. AND AMONG OTHER THINGS,
I HELP PUBLIC AGENCIES AS THEY
NAVIGATE THE RATEMAKING OR
ASSESSMENT PROCESS AND IF
NEEDED, HELP THEM DEFEND THEIR
RATES AND LITIGATION. NOW,
PROPOSITION 218 IMPOSES BOTH
PROCEDURAL REQUIREMENTS AND
SUBSTANTIVE LIMITATIONS ON THE
ADOPTION OF NEW, EXTENDED OR
INCREASED PROPERTY RELATED FEES
OR ASSESSMENTS FOR WATER OR
SEWER SERVICE. PUBLIC AGENCIES
ALREADY ARE AT A STEEP
DISADVANTAGE IF THEY FIND
THEMSELVES DEFENDING THEIR RATES
OR ASSESSMENTS IN A COURTROOM
FOR A FEW REASONS. FIRST, UNDER
PROPOSITION 218, THE BURDEN
SHIFTS FROM A PLAINTIFF
CHALLENGING THE ASSESSMENTS OR
THE FEES TO THE PUBLIC AGENCY TO
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE WITH
PROPOSITION 218. SECOND, THE
STANDARD OF REVIEW FOR A TRIAL
COURT WILL EXERCISE ITS
INDEPENDENT REVIEW IN A
PROPOSITION 218 CASE, MEANING
THE AGENCY IS NOT ENTITLED TO
DEFERENCE AND THIRD, IN
LITIGATION. THE AGENCY'S
EVIDENTIARY UNIVERSE IS LIMITED
TO THE ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD
THAT WAS BEFORE THE AGENCY'S
GOVERNING BODY. WHILE IT WAS
MAKING THE DECISION ON THE
PROPOSED RATE OR ASSESSMENT,
DEFENDING THESE FEES OR
ASSESSMENTS IN LITIGATION
BECOMES EVEN MORE CHALLENGING.
IF A RATEPAYER DID NOT RAISE THE
ISSUE WITH THE PROPOSED RATE OR
FEE DURING THE RATE MAKING
PROCESS. WHEN THE PUBLIC
AGENCY'S GOVERNING BODY AND
STAFF STILL COULD HAVE DONE
SOMETHING ABOUT IT, OR AT LEAST
ANSWERED QUESTIONS, OR ADDRESS
THE ISSUE IN MORE DETAIL IN
THEIR RECORD BEFORE ADOPTION.
NOW, THE GOAL HERE IS TO HELP
BOLSTER PUBLIC PARTICIPATION,
DEVELOP SOUND AND WELL INFORMED
FEES, AND PROMOTE FINANCIAL
STABILITY FOR PUBLIC AGENCIES.
AB 2257 WILL HELP PUBLIC
AGENCIES ACHIEVE THAT GOAL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND I'M
HAPPY TO HELP THE AUTHOR AND
ANSWERING ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR MEMBERS ROSS BUCKLEY, ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, KRISTY
FOY WITH ARNOLD AND ASSOCIATES
HERE ON BEHALF OF THREE VALLEYS
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ALYSSA SALEHI, ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF SANTA ROSA, CITY OF
CARLSBAD, CITY OF CORONA, CITY
OF RANCHO CUCAMONGA, AND TOWN OF
HILLSBORO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
JENNIFER WILLIAMS WITH THE EAST
BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU, JAMIE
MINER ON BEHALF OF EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT, SANTA
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT, AND
THE CALIFORNIA STORMWATER
QUALITY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU, LIZZY KUTSUNA HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN OF THE SOUTH,
SAN JOAQUIN IRRIGATION DISTRICT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DENISHA
BOETTNER. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. DAWN KOBQ,
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ECONOMIC BALANCE, SEEBE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON. MARCUS DETWILER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OPPOSITION IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 2257,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
HELLO AGAIN. AND HELLO MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. I'M SCOTT
KAUFMAN WITH THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. AB 2257
REQUIRES NOTHING MORE OF AN
AGENCY THAN MAILING THE NOTICE
THAT IS ALREADY REQUIRED UNDER
PROPOSITION 218, STATING THE
AMOUNT OF THE CHARGE AND THE
BASIS OF THE COMPUTATION, AND
THEN FORECLOSES LITIGATION FOR
ANY PROPERTY OWNER OR RATEPAYER
WHO FAILS TO RAISE A SPECIFIC
LEGAL OBJECTION WITHIN 45 DAYS.
NOTHING IN THIS BILL REQUIRES AN
ENGINEER'S REPORT, RATE STUDY,
OR ANY OTHER DOCUMENTATION THAT
WOULD ALLOW RATEPAYER TO SPECIFY
GROUNDS UPON THE PROPOSED RATES
MIGHT BE INVALID TO BE AVAILABLE
FOR REVIEW DURING THE NOTICE
PERIOD. SOME WATER AGENCIES MAY
MAKE THESE MATERIALS AVAILABLE
DURING THE 218 NOTICE PERIOD,
BUT IT IS NOT REQUIRED BY LAW
AND NOT ALL AGENCIES DO, AND WE
FEAR SHOULD THIS BILL BECOME
LAW, THERE WILL BE A PERVERSE
INCENTIVE TO NOT RELEASE THEM
UNTIL THE LAST POSSIBLE MINUTE.
BUT EVEN IF THIS INFORMATION IS
PROVIDED, 45 DAYS IS SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH TIME FOR A RATEPAYER TO
SCHEDULE A CONSULTATION WITH AN
ATTORNEY. HAVE THE ATTORNEY
RESEARCH WHETHER THERE IS A
VIOLATION. FIND AND RETAIN AN
EXPERT WITNESS, AND HAVE THE
EXPERT PREPARE A REPORT AND HAVE
AN ATTORNEY TO DRAFT AND SUBMIT
A THOROUGH OBJECTION. PRESERVING
ALL LEGAL THEORIES. FURTHER,
THERE IS ALREADY A 120 DAY
LIMITATIONS PERIOD THAT IS
REALLY 75 DAYS BECAUSE THERE IS
AN AGENCY RESPONSE PERIOD BAKED
INTO IT THAT APPLIES TO WATER
AND SEWER RATES, THAT TIME
FRAME, AND OUR VIEW IS ALREADY
TOO SHORT. AND TO AND FURTHER
LIMITATIONS ARE JUST CREATING AN
IMPOSSIBLE TIME TRAP BY DESIGN.
TO FURTHER THIS POINT, I HAVE
BROUGHT AMY SPARROW, SENIOR
COUNSEL FOR THE HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION, WITH ME.
SHE HAS 20 YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
WITH PROP 218, REPRESENTING BOTH
RATEPAYERS AND RATE MAKING
AGENCIES. SHE WILL EXPLAIN THE
REAL LIFE IMPLICATIONS OF THIS
BILL. I THANK YOU AND ASK THAT
YOU OPPOSE AB 2257. ALL RIGHTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. HI. GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NAME IS AMY SPARROW AND I'M ON
BEHALF OF HOWARD JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION. AND I'D
LIKE TO DISCUSS THE IMPACT OF
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE ON DUE
PROCESS BY CALLING OUT MY OWN
EXPERIENCE WITH THE CITY OF
PASADENA, WHICH RECENTLY ADOPTED
NEW WATER RATES. ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS CONTACTED ME WITH
CONCERNS ABOUT THE NEW PASADENA
RATES, SO I WENT TO THE CITY'S
WEBSITE EXPECTING TO FIND THEIR
RATE STUDY IN THIS CASE,
PASADENA NOT ONLY FAILED TO POST
ITS RATE STUDY ONLINE, BUT
INCREDIBLY, INITIALLY REFUSED AT
THE ADVICE OF THEIR ATTORNEY TO
RESPOND TO MY PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST FOR A COPY OF THE
REPORT, WHICH TURNED OUT TO BE
OVER 100 PAGES LONG, WITH CHARTS
, TABLES, GRAPHS AND TECHNICAL
ANALYSIS, WHICH IS REALLY
REQUIRED IN ORDER TO EVALUATE
THE VALIDITY OF WATER RATES. THE
POINT THAT I'M MAKING HERE IS
THAT AGENCIES ARE NOT REQUIRED
TO MAKE THESE RATE STUDIES
AVAILABLE IN THE ABSENCE OF A
PUBLIC RECORDS ACT REQUEST, AND
EVEN THEN, THEY MIGHT NOT MAKE
THAT STUDY AVAILABLE UNTIL AFTER
THE NEW RATES ARE ADOPTED, AT
WHICH POINT THE COURTHOUSE DOOR
WILL HAVE ALREADY SLAMMED SHUT.
UNDER THIS BILL, WHICH REQUIRES
SPECIFIC OBJECTIONS DURING A
TIME PERIOD WHEN THE RATE STUDY
NEED NOT BE AVAILABLE TO THE
PUBLIC. SO I'D REALLY LIKE TO
KNOW HOW DOES ANYBODY EXPECT
RATEPAYERS TO VOICE SPECIFIC
OBJECTIONS TO NEW RATES WITHOUT
ACCESS TO THE TECHNICAL RATE
STUDY? SO THIS JUST OPENS THE
DOOR TO A BLATANT VIOLATION OF
DUE PROCESS. AND THE LEGISLATIVE
DECLARATION THAT THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE, QUOTE, A
MEANINGFUL OPPORTUNITY FOR
RATEPAYERS TO PRESENT
OBJECTIONS, WHICH IS, QUOTE,
ESPECIALLY VALUABLE IN CASES
WHERE EVIDENCE IS HIGHLY
TECHNICAL. BEALL IS, QUITE
FRANKLY, JUST PAINFULLY CYNICAL.
YES, THE EVIDENCE IS HIGHLY
TECHNICAL, AND THAT IS EXACTLY
WHY RATE STUDIES SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE WITH ADEQUATE TIME FOR
LEGAL EVALUATION BEFORE THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS CLOSES,
RATHER THAN AFTERWARD, AS WOULD
BE THE CASE UNDER THIS BILL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. OTHERS
IN OPPOSITION, YOUR NAME, YOUR
AFFILIATION, YOUR POSITION. MY
NAME IS STEPHANIE SUELA AND I
HAVE DONE THE 218 PROCESS AS A
RATEPAYER OUT IN RIO LINDA
ELVERTA THEY DO NOT HAVE SEWER.
MA'AM, YOUR NAME? STEPHANIE SULA
AND YOUR AFFILIATION? I AM A
RATEPAYER WITH THE RIO LINDA
ELVERTA COMMUNITY WATER
DISTRICT. THANK YOU. AND YOUR
POSITION. OKAY. MY POSITION I
OPPOSE THE 218 IS MY JOB TO
OPPOSE IT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT,
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
NOW. QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I DO NOT SEE ANY
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SO, MEMBER WILSON, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU. I
APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS THAT
HAVE BEEN BROUGHT FORTH BY THE
OPPOSITION. THÀNH, AND THOSE
CONCERNS HAVE BEEN ONGOING
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS, AND
WE'VE MADE ADJUSTMENTS
ACCORDINGLY, BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE DAY, OUR MY ABILITY OR MY
STRONG SENSE IS TO PROTECT
RATEPAYERS AS, AS, AS I'M
WORKING WITH, TRYING TO SUPPORT
OUR AGENCIES THAT ARE PROVIDING
A SERVICE TO THE RATEPAYERS. AND
I APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS, THE
THOROUGH REVIEW FROM THIS
COMMITTEE AND HAVE AGREED TO
TAKE THOSE AMENDMENTS. SO WITH
THAT, AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
I'D ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, WE DO STILL DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM. WE NEED TWO MORE
MEMBERS, AND THEN WE WILL HAVE A
QUORUM. SO LET ME JUST DO A
LITTLE HOUSEKEEPING HERE. SO
HERE'S HOW WE'RE GOING TO GO,
NEXT WE'RE GOING TO CALL UPON
ON, LET'S SEE PHYLUM NUMBER 12,
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY AB
2747. ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY WILL
ALSO BE PRESENTING PHYLUM NUMBER
17, AB 3281, THEN FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCKINNON WITH
ITEM NUMBER 23, AB 2833, AND
THEN WE'RE GOING TO GET BACK ON
TRACK WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ WITH ITEM NUMBER THREE,
AB 2326. AFTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALVAREZ WILL GO WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN AND THEN, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE, THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN. ALL RIGHT. SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HANEY, PHYLUM
NUMBER 12, AB 2747. THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS. AB 2747
WILL BRING RENT REPORTING UP TO
STANDARD PRACTICE BY REQUIRING
SOME LANDLORDS TO GIVE TENANTS
THE OPTION TO OPT IN TO
REPORTING THEIR POSITIVE RENT
PAYMENTS TO A CREDIT BUREAU
AGENCY. CREDIT SCORES ARE
DESIGNED TO REFLECT THE GOOD AND
THE BAD OF A PERSON'S FINANCIAL
HISTORY, USUALLY, IF A PERSON
MISSES A CREDIT CARD PAYMENT,
THEIR SCORE WILL GO DOWN, AND IF
THEY STAY ON TOP OF THEIR
PAYMENTS, THEIR SCORE WILL
INCREASE. HOWEVER, THIS IS NOT
HAPPENING WHEN LANDLORDS REPORT
RENT PAYMENTS TO A CREDIT BUREAU
AGENCY FOR MOST TENANTS,
MILLIONS OF RENTERS AROUND THE
STATE ARE PAYING THEIR RENT ON
TIME, YET THEY NEVER SEE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON THE CREDIT
SCORES UNFAIRLY. IF THEY FALL
BEHIND ON THEIR RENT, THEY CAN
AT TIMES HAVE THAT NEGATIVELY
SHOW UP ON THEIR REPORT AND
BRING THEIR SCORES DOWN.
ADDITIONALLY, ALTHOUGH CREDIT
SCORES ARE A FUNDAMENTAL PART OF
LIVING IN THE UNITED STATES,
ONLY 1 OR 1 IN TEN AMERICANS DO
NOT HAVE A CREDIT SCORE. THIS IS
BECAUSE THEY DON'T. THEY
HAVEN'T. THIS IS NOT BECAUSE
THEY HAVEN'T BEEN PAYING THEIR
BILLS ON TIME, BUT BECAUSE NONE
OF THEIR MONTHLY EXPENSES ARE
ABLE TO BE USED TO BUILD THEIR
CREDIT. FOR THOSE WHO HAVE
CREDIT SCORES, MILLIONS OF THEM
HAVE POOR CREDIT ONLY BECAUSE
THE BILLS THEY HAVE TO
PRIORITIZE ARE NOT REPORTED TO
CREDIT THE CREDIT BUREAU. THIS
WILL ENSURE THAT MANY MORE
TENANTS HAVE THEIR POSITIVE
RENTAL HISTORY REPORTED TO
CREDIT BUREAUS. THE MOST RECENT
AMENDMENTS REMOVED OPPOSITION
FROM THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION AND ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS, ALLOWING LANDLORDS TO
COLLECT A FEE OF $10 OR THE
ACTUAL COST OF RENT REPORTING,
WHICHEVER IS LESS, FROM TENANTS,
AND EXEMPT BUILDINGS WITH LESS
THAN 15 UNITS FROM THE BILL. I'M
ALSO LOOKING AT SOME OF THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS FROM SOME
OF THE TENANT ORGANIZATIONS, AND
WILL BE IN CONVERSATION WITH
THEM TO HELP TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THOSE QUESTIONS AND CONCERNS. IF
THIS BILL IS TO MOVE OUT WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL, I HAVE DAVID RAMIREZ, THE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS COMMITTEE
CHAIR FOR THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU. MR.
RAMIREZ. GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR
LUNDBERG. AND SENATORS, MY NAME
IS DAVID RAMIREZ. I SERVE AS A
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS CHAIR FOR
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION,
REPRESENTING OVER 230,000
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. I
RECENTLY GRADUATED FROM UCLA AND
WHICH IS WHERE I CURRENTLY LIVE,
IN AN OFF CAMPUS APARTMENT IN
ONE OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE RENTAL
MARKETS IN THE COUNTRY. LAST
YEAR, WHEN I WAS SEARCHING FOR A
LEASE, WHAT BECAME ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR TO ME IS THAT WITHOUT A
COSIGNER, I WOULD BE UNABLE TO
QUALIFY FOR ANY OFF CAMPUS
HOUSING UNITS DESPITE HAVING THE
MEANS TO PAY FOR MY RENT, I'VE
BEEN RENTING AN OFF CAMPUS
HOUSING FOR THE LAST YEAR, BUT
MY RENT PAYMENTS HAVE NEVER
SHOWN UP ON MY CREDIT SCORE. AS
I BEGIN MY LIFE AFTER
GRADUATION, I'M REALIZING HOW
CRUCIAL HAVING GOOD CREDIT IS TO
BUYING A CAR AND RENTING MY
FIRST HOME AFTER COLLEGE. BUT
ONE MAIN, CONSISTENT PAYMENT HAS
NEVER BEEN REPORTED TO A CREDIT
BUREAU AGENCY. HAVING MY RENT
PAYMENTS COUNT TOWARDS MY CREDIT
HISTORY WOULD HAVE MADE
TRANSITION TO POST COLLEGE LIFE
MUCH EASIER. COLLEGE STUDENTS
OFTEN HAVE LOW OR NONEXISTENT
CREDIT SCORES AND ARE DENIED
HOUSING DUE TO THEIR LACK OF
CREDIT HISTORY AND CREDIT
SCORES. THIS IMPACTS OUR MOST
VULNERABLE STUDENTS, WHICH IS
OUR LOW INCOME, FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS WHO OFTEN CANNOT RELY
ON THEIR PARENTS OR GUARDIANS TO
SERVE AS COSIGNERS FOR THEIR
RENTAL APPLICATIONS. AT UCLA,
OAN HOMELESSNESS IS AT 8%
SYSTEM WIDE AND FAR MORE FACING
HOUSING INSECURITY. HOMELESSNESS
IS FAR WORSE AT THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITIES.
ADDITIONALLY, MANY COLLEGE
STUDENTS HAVE NO WAY TO BUILD
CREDIT WHILE IN COLLEGE OTHER
THAN THEIR ON TIME RENTAL
PAYMENTS, WHICH THEY ARE ALREADY
MAKING DUE TO THEIR AGE AND LACK
OF CREDIT HISTORY. COLLEGE
STUDENTS TEND TO HAVE LOWER
CREDIT SCORES, WHICH ARE MUCH
MORE DIFFICULT TO BUILD. MANY
PEOPLE DO NOT APPLY FOR THEIR
FIRST CREDIT CARD UNTIL AFTER
COLLEGE, DUE TO FEARS OF RUINING
THEIR CREDIT, BUT FOR THE
MAJORITY OF OFF CAMPUS COLLEGE
STUDENTS, ALL THEIR ALL TIME
RENTAL PAYMENTS THROUGHOUT
COLLEGE ARE CURRENTLY DOING
NOTHING TO BUILD THEIR CREDIT
SCORE. THIS IS WHY UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS SUPPORT AB
2747, WHICH WOULD ALLOW MANY
CALIFORNIANS, INCLUDING MANY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO ARE
CURRENTLY LIVING IN LARGE
APARTMENT COMPLEXES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. IF YOU'D WRAP IT UP,
CREDIT SCORES, AND TO USE THEIR
PAYMENTS TO ACCOUNT FOR THEIR
CREDIT HISTORY. AND I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB 2747,
PLEASE APPROACH. CHRIS MYERS
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO A B 2747,
PLEASE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
READY? YES. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS TINA
ROSALES TORRES WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY. I'M A
HOUSING ATTORNEY AND ADVOCATING
ON BEHALF OF A MAJORITY OF
RENTERS IN CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE A
RESPECTFUL, UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THIS BILL TO REMOVE
THE PROVISIONS EXEMPTING CERTAIN
LANDLORDS FROM OFFERING RENT,
REPORTING THE EXEMPTION THAT THE
MEMBER REFERRED TO IS ONE WHERE
THIS BILL DOES NOT APPLY TO
RENTAL PROPERTIES THAT CONTAIN
15 OR FEWER UNITS, UNLESS THE
LANDLORDS ARE MORE THAN OWNS
ONE. MORE THAN ONE RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING IS A REIT, A
CORPORATION, OR AN LLC IN WHICH
A MEMBER IS A CORPORATION. THAT
IS COMPLETELY UNWORKABLE BECAUSE
IT IS NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR A
TENANT TO DETERMINE IF THEIR
PROPERTY OWNER OWNS MORE THAN
ONE BUILDING AND LLCS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO LIST THEIR
BENEFICIAL OWNERS. SO THERE'S
REALLY NO WAY TO DETERMINE IF
THIS BILL WILL APPLY TO THEM OR
NOT. FURTHERMORE FOR THE 15 UNIT
EXEMPTION LANGUAGE COMES FROM AN
EXISTING BILL THAT WAS PASSED
PREVIOUSLY YEARS BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRADFORD. AND THEN THIS
COMMITTEE GOT ANOTHER VERSION OF
THE BILL PASSED TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET AND WHAT'S UNIQUE ABOUT
THAT IS IT REQUIRES THE 15 UNIT
EXEMPTION ONLY FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING COMPLEX REYES, WHICH
MOST CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS DO NOT
LIVE IN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMPLEXES AND THE WAY THAT IT'S
STRUCTURED, IT'S REALLY
NEGLIGIBLE AND WON'T ACTUALLY
EXEMPT ANYONE FROM THE BILL.
HOWEVER, USING THAT LANGUAGE IN
THIS BILL DOES HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON CALIFORNIA
RENTERS. IN FACT, THE WAY THAT
THIS BILL IS WRITTEN, IT WILL
EXCLUDE 72% OF CALIFORNIA
RENTERS WHO LIVE IN UNITS WITH
20 OR, EXCUSE ME, BUILDINGS WITH
20 OR LESS UNITS. 68% OF SAN
FRANCISCO RESIDENTS LIVE IN
BUILDINGS WITH 20 OR LESS UNITS,
SO CREATING A LAW OR AN
EXEMPTION THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
HELP RENTERS, THAT ACTUALLY
EXCLUDES A MAJORITY OF THEM,
REALLY JUST SETS BAD PRECEDENT
AND SHOULDN'T BE REPLICATED
THROUGHOUT THIS BODY. WITH THAT,
WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT
THIS PROVISION BE REMOVED FROM
THE BILL AND YOUR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THAT WAS
TWO MINUTES, RIGHT. THAT'S TWO
MINUTES. THERE YOU GO. RIGHT,
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. MY NAME IS ANDRES RAMOS
. I SERVE AS LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES, WE'RE A
NONPROFIT LAW FIRM AND ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS WITH
RENTERS AND RENTER ADVOCATES TO
STRENGTHEN THE VOICES OF RENTERS
AND PUBLIC POLICY AND TO ADVANCE
RENTERS RIGHTS. WE ALSO
RESPECTFULLY, ARE OPPOSE, UNLESS
AMENDED ON THIS BILL. WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S GOAL TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO POSITIVE CREDIT
FOR RENTERS, THIS BILL IS
WRITTEN WILL SET A HARMFUL
PRECEDENT BY CONTINUING TO TREAT
RENTERS DIFFERENTLY BASED ON HOW
MANY UNITS THEIR LANDLORD
HAPPENS TO OWN. THIS OPENS THE
DOOR TO EXCLUDING MOST RENTERS
FROM TENANT PROTECTIONS FOR NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN, AND
THREATENS TO UNDERMINE THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF TENANT LAWS.
OTHER CRITICAL LAWS IN RECENT
YEARS THAT PROTECT RENTERS DON'T
DO THIS. IMAGINE HOW LESS
MEANINGFUL AB 1482 OR THE
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM WOULD HAVE
BEEN IF THEY DIDN'T APPLY TO 15
UNIT OR LESS PROPERTIES. AND HOW
MANY MORE CALIFORNIANS WOULD BE
FACING HOMELESSNESS IF THEY HAD
BEEN EXCLUDED FROM THESE
CRITICAL PROTECTIONS FOR THIS
ARBITRARY THRESHOLD? AS MY
COLLEAGUE INDICATED, IT'S ALSO
DIFFICULT TO KNOW WHICH PROPERTY
OWNERS THIS WOULD APPLY TO,
SINCE LLCS DON'T HAVE TO
DISCLOSE THEIR BENEFICIAL OWNERS
. ON A PERSONAL NOTE, I'M A
RENTER HERE IN SACRAMENTO. I
LIVE IN A SEVEN UNIT BUILDING.
THE OWNER OF MY BUILDING IS AN
LLC THAT I THINK OWNS MULTIPLE
RENTAL PROPERTIES, BUT I HAVE NO
IDEA IF A CORPORATION IS A
MEMBER OF THE LLC. SO I DON'T
KNOW IF THIS BILL WOULD APPLY TO
ME AND MY NEIGHBORS AND IT WOULD
BE REALLY DIFFICULT TO FIGURE
THAT OUT. BUT I KNOW FOR SURE
THAT THAT LLC IS NOT A QUOTE.
MOM AND POP LANDLORD LAST, I'D
NOTE THAT IF YOU LOOK IN THE
ANALYSIS, RENTER ORGANIZATIONS
AND RENTER ADVOCATES ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL. WE DIDN'T AGREE TO
THE 15 UNIT CARVE OUT, NOR WE
PART OF THE NEGOTIATION. WHEN
RENTERS ARE NOT AT THE TABLE,
OUR VOICES AND NEEDS GET LOST
AND IT'S EASY TO HORSE TRADE
AWAY OUR RIGHTS TO THE LANDLORD
LOBBY. WE ENCOURAGE THE AUTHOR,
ESPECIALLY AS CHAIR OF THE
RENTERS CAUCUS, TO WORK WITH US
EARLY AND ENSURE THAT RENTERS
HAVE A MEANINGFUL SEAT AT THE
TABLE FROM THE OUTSET. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION. FOR
THESE REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY
URGE A NO VOTE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION, PLEASE APPROACH
CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ WITH THE
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION AND THE
NATIONAL HOUSING LAW PROJECT
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
, MR. CHAIR, AND MEMBERS, PAT
MORAN WITH AARON REID AND
ASSOCIATES, REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION, IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT, SEEING NO OTHER
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE,
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SEEING NO QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YES. THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW, THIS HAS BEEN IN
EFFECT FOR SUBSIDIZING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR SOME
TIME. THANKS TO SENATOR
BRADFORD. THIS WOULD BE A LARGE
EXPANSION OF WHAT I THINK IS A
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM THAT
OFFERS TENANTS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD THEIR CREDIT. WHAT I
LIKE IT TO APPLY TO 100% OF
TENANTS, FOR SURE. ABSOLUTELY
THIS IS STILL PROGRESS. MILLIONS
MORE TENANTS WOULD HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND I THINK THE
EXEMPTION FOR THE SIZE IS ALSO
BECAUSE FOR THE SMALLEST OF
LANDLORDS, IT MAY BE HARD FOR
THEM TO LOGISTICALLY FIGURE OUT
HOW TO ENSURE THE CREDIT
REPORTING. I THINK FOR THE ONES
THAT HAVE A PROPERTY MANAGER,
THAT WAS WHY FROM A POLICY
STANDPOINT, WE DECIDED TO DRAW
THAT LINE WHERE WE DID. I STILL
THINK IT'S AN EXPANSION OF
SOMETHING THAT WILL HELP A LOT
OF PEOPLE. AND WITH THAT,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. I'VE
ALREADY REMARKED AS TO HOW IT'S
IMPACTING MY SELF-ESTEEM. IF WE
GET ONE MORE PERSON, WE WILL
HAVE A QUORUM, WE DO HAVE 100%
OF THE REPUBLICANS HERE, AS
NOTED PREVIOUSLY. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY, NEXT
WE WILL HAVE, ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCKENNA WITH ITEM NUMBER 20. I
HAVE THE Þ. YOU HAVE TWO BILLS.
I'M SORRY. YES, I APOLOGIZE
SORRY TO CREATE THAT,
ANTICIPATION. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HANEY. GO AHEAD. YOU'VE GOT
ANOTHER BILL. THAT'S FILE NUMBER
17, AB 3281, AB 3281 IS THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S ANNUAL
CIVIL LAW OMNIBUS BILL CONTAINS
NUMEROUS MINOR UPDATES TO
VARIOUS CODE SECTIONS WITHIN THE
JURISDICTION OF THE COMMITTEE,
SAVING THE LEGISLATURE FROM
HAVING TO CONSIDER DOZENS OF
ADDITIONAL BILLS. ALL THE
CHANGES IN THE BILL ARE FAIRLY
MINOR AND GENERALLY CLARIFYING
IN NATURE. THESE CHANGES HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED BY SEVERAL STATE
AGENCIES AS WELL AS NGO SOURCES,
AND ARE ALL CONSENSUS. THIS BILL
HAS NO FORMAL OPPOSITION AND AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. IF YOU'RE
IN SUPPORT OF AB 23. EXCUSE ME.
STRIKE THAT 3281, PLEASE.
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHING. IF YOU'RE
OPPOSED, PLEASE APPROACH. SEEING
NO ONE APPROACHING. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEEING THAT
THERE ARE NONE, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR.
AT THE RIGHT TIME. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. NOW, WE'LL
WILL WE AT THE RIGHT TIME. WE
WILL HAVE A QUORUM. I'M HOPING.
AND YOUR BILL WILL BE MOVED. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. MEMBER
MCKENNA, THIS FILE ITEM NUMBER
23, AB 2833. FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ,
FOLLOWED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'BRIEN. OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR. MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT AB 2833, A
BILL THAT WILL PROVIDE
COMPREHENSIVE AND, ADMISSIBILITY
AND CONFIDENTIALITY PROTECTIONS
FOR ALL RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROCESSES THAT OCCUR WITHIN THE
STATE. CURRENTLY, SEVERAL
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROGRAMS IN
CALIFORNIA ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
CONFIDENTIALITY BY ENTERING INTO
MOUS WITH LOCAL PROSECUTORS
OFFICES AND OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. THESE MOUS TYPICALLY
GOVERN ASPECTS OF THE PROGRAM'S
OPERATION, INCLUDING
CONFIDENTIALITY, K¾T THEY CHOOSE
WHAT IS CONFIDENTIAL AND
TYPICALLY PREVENT INFORMATION
OBTAINED DURING A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PROCESS FROM BEING USED
AGAINST THE PERSON WHO CAUSED
HARM IN FUTURE PROCEEDINGS.
HOWEVER, NOT ALL ORGANIZATIONS
USE MOUS, AND IT'S AN INCREDIBLY
LABOR INTENSIVE TO NEGOTIATE AND
RENEGOTIATE THESE AGREEMENTS. IT
ALSO LEADS TO INCONSISTENCY
ACROSS JURISDICTIONS AND RESULT
IN A PATCHWORK OF UNDERSTANDING
REGARDING CONFIDENTIALITY FOR
CALIFORNIA, RATHER THAN A
COMPREHENSIVE PROTECTION RELATED
TO RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROCESSES. ADDITIONALLY THESE
MRAS ARE HIGHLY SUBJECT TO
LOCALIZED POLITICS AND THUS IN
NEED OF STANDARDIZING AND
GUARDRAILS THAT CAN COME FROM
WELL CRAFTED LEGISLATION. WITH
ME HERE TODAY IS DANIKA WITH
INITIATE JUSTICE. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. DANIKA ODOM, ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE,
PROUD CO-SPONSOR AND MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE POLICY COALITION, AB
2833 DOES SEEK TO PROTECT
STATEMENTS THAT ARE MADE DURING
THE COURSE OF A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE PROCESS FROM BEING USED
IN FUTURE COURT PROCEEDINGS,
THAT IS, IN ORDER TO REALLY
ENCOURAGE PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE
INCLINED TO PARTICIPATE IN A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROCESS TO
DO SO FULLY AND OPENLY. WE KNOW
THAT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS MOST
EFFECTIVE WHEN PEOPLE ENTER
THOSE PROCESS REYES AND FEEL
LIKE THEY CAN TRULY SHARE, BE
VERY ACCOUNTABLE FOR ACTIONS
THAT THEY HAVE DONE HARM THEY
MAY HAVE CAUSED, AND FOR
SURVIVORS TO BE ABLE TO SHARE
VERY OPEN AND HONESTLY ABOUT HOW
THEY'VE BEEN IMPACTED BY THAT
HARM. A LOT OF THE CONVERSATION
IN THE CAPITOL THUS FAR ABOUT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE HAS BEEN
CENTERED ON, IN LESS SERIOUS
CASES AND IN EDUCATIONAL
SETTINGS, AND I WANT TO NOTE
THAT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE IS
ACTUALLY MOST PROMISING IN THE
MOST SERIOUS OF CASES, WHERE IN
CRIMINAL CASES IN PARTICULAR,
WHERE DEFENDANTS ARE DISCOURAGED
FROM SPEAKING AND MEANT TO
REMAIN SILENT, AND SURVIVORS
HAVE VERY LIMITED OPPORTUNITY TO
EVER BE HEARD ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCE, AS A PERSONAL NOTE,
I'M THE SURVIVOR OF A WOMAN WHO
WAS RAPED IN 1982. THE MAN WHO
WAS ARRESTED FOR THAT RAPE HAS
BEEN CIVILLY COMMITTED AS A
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR. AND I
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO A
VICTIM OFFENDER DIALOG WITH HIM
LAST NOVEMBER. AND I WILL SHARE
THAT THAT EXPERIENCE WAS VERY
MEANINGFUL, IN PART BECAUSE HE
WAS ABLE TO BE VERY OPEN AND
HONEST, BECAUSE HE'S ALREADY
CIVILLY COMMITTED, RIGHT?
THERE'S NOWHERE ELSE FOR HIM TO
GO. THERE'S REALLY NO MORE
RIGHTS OR ACCESS FOR HIM TO
LOSE. AND SO THERE'S REALLY
NOTHING THAT HE COULD SHARE IN
THAT SPACE WITH ME THAT COULD BE
USED AGAINST HIM. BUT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE. WE
WANT TO ENCOURAGE TO BE A PART
OF THESE PROCESSES, PEOPLE DO
RISK LOSING THEIR FURTHER
LIBERTIES, OR MAYBE BEING
INCARCERATED FOR LONGER OR BEING
CHARGED WITH A SEX OFFENSE AND
LABELED A SEX OFFENDER. AND NONE
OF THOSE THINGS ACTUALLY HELP
SURVIVORS TO HEAL OR HAVE
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO PROCESSES
THAT MAY ACTUALLY HELP THEM. SO
WITH THAT, I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
ON THIS BILL, AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT, OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANTHONY DEMARTINO, ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND CRIME, SURVIVORS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE, PROUD
CO-SPONSORS OF THE BILL. THANK
YOU. GRACE GLASER, ON BEHALF OF
OUR US, CALIFORNIA SEXUAL
ASSAULT COALITION AND SUPPORT,
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TURN NOW TO THE, OH, THERE WE
GO. ONE MORE. LAST BUT NOT
LEAST. Dð. COONEY, ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION, PROUD TO
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
, AB 2833, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE SEEING NO ONE
APPROACHES THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS,
COMMENTS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THERE ARE NONE. OH, I'M SORRY,
SENATOR NIELLO. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. RESTORATIVE JUSTICE CAN
BE VERY BENEFICIAL. I THINK, IN
PARTICULAR WITH REGARD TO
JUVENILE JUSTICE, I THINK IT CAN
HAVE A TREMENDOUSLY, POSITIVE
EFFECT ON JUVENILE OFFENDERS WHO
ARE WHO HAVE REACHED, A PROBABLY
A MEANINGFUL MOMENT IN THEIR
TIME AND BE ABLE TO MAKE AMENDS,
MY CONCERN WITH REGARD TO ADULTS
IS. WHAT WOULD KEEP AN OFFENDER,
IN DIALOG WITH A VICTIM OF IN
THAT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PROCESS
TO TALK ABOUT OTHER OFFENSES
THAT HE OR SHE COMMITTED AND
THEN ABSOLVE THEMSELVES FROM
THAT BEING PROSECUTED UNDER THE
TERMS OF THIS BILL. IT DOESN'T
I'M SORRY. IT DOESN'T GO INTO
DETAIL ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS DURING
THE MEETING. WE HAVE A MEDIATOR
FOR SURE, AND I'M SURE THAT THE
MEDIATOR WOULD GUIDE THEM INTO
TALKING ABOUT THE ONE PARTICULAR
CASE, WHAT HAPPENED TO THEM,
BECAUSE IT'S USED AS ALSO A
THERAPY. IT'S LIKE NOT JUST
PUNISHING PEOPLE, BUT ALSO BEING
ABLE TO HEAL THE VICTIM AND THE
PERSON THAT DID THE HARM. BUT DO
YOU HAVE A MEDIATOR THERE? SO
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM. SO I DON'T I
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THEM GOING OFF
ON OTHER OTHER CRIMES. AND WHAT
WOULD BE THE PURPOSE OF THE
LEGISLATION IF THE IF THE
MEDIATOR KEEPS THE CONVERSATION
NARROWLY TO THE WHAT HAPPENED?
BECAUSE MAYBE THAT MAYBE THAT,
THAT WHATEVER HAPPENED IN THE IN
THE HARM BETWEEN THE VICTIM AND
THE PERSON THAT DID THE HARM,
MAYBE THAT WASN'T BROUGHT UP IN
THEIR CASE. AND SO THEY START TO
TALK ABOUT MAYBE WHAT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT HAPPENED LEADING UP TO THE
CRIME. AND SO WE JUST WANT THEM
TO BE ABLE TO COME AND TALK
FREELY BECAUSE THEY WON'T THEY
WON'T GO THROUGH THIS IF THEY
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
CHARGED. BUT WE WANT THEM TO
BECAUSE IT'S A WE DON'T JUST
WANT TO PUNISH PEOPLE, WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE HEALING.
AND I THINK THIS IS A WAY FOR
THEM TO HEAL AND THE VICTIM TO
HEAL, BECAUSE AS WE PUT PEOPLE
AWAY, WE DON'T WANT TO JUST
WE'RE NOT JUST IN A PUNISHING
BUSINESS. WE ALWAYS SAY THAT
WE'RE REHABILITATING FOLKS. SO I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A PART OF
REHABILITATION. SO THANK YOU,
SENATOR. I THINK YOUR WITNESS
WANTS TO CONTRIBUTE HERE TO THAT
QUESTION. DO YOU HAVE A FURTHER
ANSWER? I IMPORTANT QUESTION.
YEAH. I MEAN, NOTHING IN THE
BILL WOULD PROHIBIT SOMEBODY
FROM BEING PROSECUTED FROM ANY
OTHER ACTION IF THEY IF THEY
WERE INVOLVED IN ANY OTHER CRIME
OR HARM OUTSIDE OF WHAT THE
TOPIC OF DISCUSSION IS WITHIN
THAT RESTORATIVE JUSTICE
PROCESS, EVEN IF THEY TALKED
ABOUT IT IN THERE, WOULD NOT
STOP PEOPLE FROM BEING ABLE TO
BE PROSECUTED FOR THAT. SO LET
ME ASK A QUESTION. SO IF SOMEONE
THIS IS A FOLLOW ON TO SENATOR
NEAL'S QUESTION. SO IF SOMEONE
IN A SESSION APOLOGIZES TO THE
VICTIM WHO'S THERE AND THEY HAVE
A COLLOQUY, BUT THE PERPETRATOR
SAYS, AND I'M ALSO SORRY FOR THE
OTHER THREE MURDERS I COMMITTED,
WHICH HAVE NOT BEEN IDENTIFIED,
HAVE NOT BEEN HAD. I ASSUME IT'S
A HE NOT ASSOCIATED. CAN THAT
INFORMATION BE USED IN THE
PROSECUTE OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
UNDER AFTER THE AMENDMENTS AND
SENATE PUBLIC SAFETY. YES. OKAY.
ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU. I DON'T
KNOW SENATOR YELLOW I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU HEARD THAT ANSWER. DID
YOU. SO THE ANSWER WAS THAT IF A
IF A PERPETRATOR REVEALS OTHER
CRIMES, AT LEAST AS FAR AS I
UNDERSTAND, THE AMENDMENTS
PROVIDE THAT THAT INFORMATION AS
TO OTHER CRIMES CAN BE USED FOR
PURPOSES OF PROSECUTION. IF
OKAY, IF THEY RESULT IN A LIFE
TERM. OKAY. MEANING CERTAINLY
CERTAIN SPECIFIED CRIMES. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM, BUT WE WILL, I HOPE,
SOON. SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
THERE'LL BE A MOTION TO VOTE.
OKAY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALVAREZ,
YOU'RE UP NEXT. THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN. ITEM NUMBER THREE.
WE'RE BACK ON TRACK. AB 2326.
GLAD TO PUT YOU BACK ON TRACK,
MR. CHAIR. THANK YOU, AND
MEMBERS, THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
TODAY AND PRESENT AB 2326, FOR
DECADES, THERE HAVE BEEN
ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS
DISCRIMINATION AT OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. HOWEVER,
A LACK OF COMPLIANCE AND
ACCOUNTABILITY HAS OCCURRED TO
ADDRESS THE SERIOUSNESS AND
SENSITIVITY OF THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY. SO LAST YEAR, I, AS
CHAIR OF THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
AUDIT COMMITTEE, HAD A HEARING
IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE, WHERE WE
LEARNED THAT WE MUST INCREASE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR SAFE
LEARNING, ENVIRONMENT FOR OUR
STUDENTS. THERE WAS A 232 PAGE,
SYSTEM WIDE REPORT THAT WE
DISCUSSED AT THAT JOINT HEARING
FOR SEVERAL HOURS, AND WE FOUND
THAT CAMPUSES DO NOT HAVE A
SYSTEM IN PLACE ADEQUATELY
RESPOND TO OTHER MISCONDUCT THAT
DOESN'T RISE TO THE LEVEL OF
OUTRIGHT DISCRIMINATION OR
HARASSMENT. ADDITIONALLY, THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR FOUND
THAT CAMPUSES LACKED CLEAR
RATIONALES FOR CLOSING CASES,
CAUSING US TO QUESTION AS TO
WHETHER THEY SHOULD HAVE
INVESTIGATED THE ALLEGATIONS,
WHICH THEY NEVER DID. THEY JUST
CLOSED IN SOME INSTANCES, JUST
CLOSED THOSE CASES BECAUSE OF
THE FEAR THAT STUDENTS HAVE
ABOUT THEIR SAFETY AND A RESULT
OF THE LEGISLATURE'S FINDINGS. I
STAND HERE PROUD AUTHOR OF AB
2326, BECAUSE OF THE, FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN THE LEGISLATURE'S
HISTORY, WE ARE HOPING TO BRING
OVERSIGHT AND COMPLIANCE TO THIS
PROGRAM. I'M ALSO PROUD TO BE
PART OF A PACKAGE OF OTHER BILLS
TO ATTEMPT TO DO THE SAME. THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIES WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE WITHIN EACH
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENT
FOR ENSURING THAT CAMPUS
PROGRAMS ARE FREE FROM
DISCRIMINATION, AND WHO HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO OVERSEE AND MONITOR
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAWS RELATED TO
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION. WITH THIS
BILL, WE ARE CREATING A CLEAR
PATH SO THAT OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION, OUR COLLEGES, OUR
UNIVERSITIES, CAMPUSES ARE FREE
FROM SEX DISCRIMINATION FOR
STUDENTS AND FOR FACULTY AND
STAFF. I LIKE TO NOW TURN IT
OVER TO OUR WITNESSES. FIRST,
KATE ROGERS WITH CHEN UP AND
THEN, CATHY VAN AUSTIN ON BEHALF
OF AAUW. SORRY. THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD. YOU'RE GETTING YOUR STEPS
IN. SO I WAS GOING TO SAY, I
PROMISE THIS IS THE LAST TIME
YOU'LL ALL BE HEARING FROM ME
TODAY, SO ONE LAST TIME, I'M
KATE ROGERS WITH CHEN UP, WE'RE
PROUD TO BE THE CO-SPONSORS OF
AB 26 OR 23, 26. SO UNLESS
YOU'RE LIVING EVERY DAY, I THINK
IT'S PRETTY DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND THE CULTURE
SURROUNDING SEXUAL VIOLENCE AND
HARASSMENT ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
IT'S LIKE VERY EASY TO LOOK AT
THE TITLE NINE SYSTEM WE
CURRENTLY HAVE IN PLACE ON PAPER
AND THINK EVERYTHING IS FINE.
BUT AFTER THREE YEARS AT UCLA, I
CAN CONFIDENTLY TELL YOU THAT
EVERYTHING IS NOT FINE, SEXUAL
VIOLENCE FEELS LIKE A LURKING
THREAT ON CAMPUS, AND THAT'S
BECAUSE IT IS, 1 IN 4
UNDERGRADUATE WOMEN WILL BECOME
SURVIVORS BY THE TIME THEY
GRADUATE. AND FOR STUDENTS, THAT
1 IN 4 IS OUR CLASSMATES, OUR
FRIENDS, OR OURSELVES, AND I
UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT THAT OUR
UNIVERSITIES CAN'T HELP US IF WE
DON'T REACH OUT, SO WHEN I FOUND
MYSELF ON UCLA'S TITLE NINE
WEBSITE, STARING AT THE FILE A
REPORT BUTTON, I THOUGHT OF ALL
THE STORIES THAT I'D HEARD ABOUT
THE TITLE NINE OFFICE DOING
NOTHING WHEN THEY HAD A
COMPLAINT, AND I JUST CLOSED
THAT TAB. SO NEARLY TWO YEARS
LATER, AFTER A SEPARATE INCIDENT
INVOLVING A FACULTY MEMBER THAT
I DESCRIBED PREVIOUSLY IN THIS
HEARING, I DID CONTACT THE TITLE
NINE OFFICE, AND THE
REPRESENTATIVE I SPOKE WITH ON
THE PHONE ASSURED ME THAT THEY
WOULD DO SOMETHING. AND LIKE I
SAID, I NEVER HEARD FROM THEM
AGAIN. SO THIS IS WHY STUDENTS
DON'T REACH OUT FOR HELP. WE
DON'T TRUST THAT OUR TITLE NINE
OFFICES WILL KEEP US SAFE NOW
BECAUSE THEY NEVER HAVE IT.
INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES HAVE PROVEN
THEMSELVES INCAPABLE OF HOLDING
THEMSELVES ACCOUNTABLE. WE NEED
AB 2326 SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE
YOU ALL CAN WITH MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND OVERSIGHT,
LAWMAKERS AND ADVOCATES ALIKE
WILL HAVE THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED
TO PROTECT CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
SO ON BEHALF OF GENERATION UP, I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR AND
MEMBERS. KATHY VAN OSTEN,
REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN,
CALIFORNIA, PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS BILL, AND AGAIN, WANT TO
THANK THE ASSEMBLYMAN FOR NOT
ONLY CARRYING THIS BILL, BUT
ALSO ASKING FOR THE AUDIT. I
THINK THAT WAS REALLY
INCREMENTAL IN IN ADVANCING AND
MOVING TITLE NINE FORWARD, FIRST
OF ALL, AAUW CALIFORNIA, WE'VE
GOT 95 ACTIVE MEMBERS AROUND THE
STATE ABOUT 2000 MEMBERS AT
LARGE. THIS HAS BEEN A VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR US FOR A FEW
YEARS. AND, WE WE'VE BEEN DOING
QUITE A BIT OF RESEARCH, TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO TRY TO
MOVE THIS, THIS NEEDLE ON THIS
LAW THAT'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR 52
YEARS. AND YET WOMEN, FACULTY,
MEN, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE OF ALL
KINDS ARE HARASSED, BULLIED,
SEXUALLY ASSAULTED, RAPED, FOR
THEM TO NOT HAVE A PLACE TO GO
AT THEIR UNIVERSITY IS IT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE. THESE DAYS, WITH
ALL THE HEIGHTENED
SENSITIVITIES, THIS SHOULD BE IN
PLACE. AND THERE ARE SOME VERY
GOOD PUBLIC HIGHER ED
INSTITUTIONS IN CALIFORNIA, MY
CLIENT, AAUW, ONE OF OUR POLICY
CO-CHAIRS, ACTUALLY WORKS ON
THIS ISSUE AT CSU LONG BEACH.
AND THEY HAVE A FANTASTIC
PROGRAM. BUT THERE'S
INCONSISTENCY AND THE WAY THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THAT IN
CONSISTENCY, I'M SORRY, THE WAY
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO GET THAT
CONSISTENCY IS IF YOU HAVE FOLKS
AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF EACH
INSTITUTION PAYING ATTENTION,
MAKING SURE THEIR CAMPUSES ARE
COMPLYING, THAT THEIR LOCAL,
PRESIDENTS, CHANCELLORS, WHAT
HAVE YOU ARE FOCUSED ON THIS
ISSUE AND MAKING SURE THAT THEY
HAVE THE RIGHT PEOPLE IN PLACE
AND MAKING SURE THAT COMPLAINTS
ARE BEING INVESTIGATED AND
RESPONDED TO? IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THOSE EYES ON THIS ISSUE AT THIS
POINT, THIS WILL NEVER HAPPEN,
THESE STUDENTS ARE JUST GOING TO
BE VICTIMS, SO WE IMPLORE YOU,
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'M LEAVING. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT. BRENDA WOODBURY, ON
BEHALF OF LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ELENI KOUNALAKIS AND SUPPORT YOU
, LIZZIE KUTSUNA HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE ELSE.
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION TO AB
2326. SEEING NO ONE APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEEING NONE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND I ONCE AGAIN
WANT TO THANK, MISS ROGERS FOR
HER TESTIMONY. I THINK IT'S
REALLY POWERFUL. I HOPE YOU,
TAKE AWAY THE SERIOUSNESS OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADDRESS
WITH THIS AND THE OTHER PACKAGE
OF BILLS IN THE OTHER BILLS IN
THE PACKAGE ON TITLE NINE.
APPRECIATE YOUR. I VOTE WHEN THE
RIGHT TIME COMES. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MEMBER ALVAREZ. ALL RIGHT. WE DO
HOPE TO HAVE A QUORUM SOMEDAY,
SO. ALL RIGHT, SOME MEMBER
BRIAN. RIGHT FOR THOSE OF YOU
WHO ARE WATCHING, ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES TODAY IS THERE ARE
MULTIPLE COMMITTEES BEING
CONDUCTED RIGHT NOW, BOTH IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE. SO
VARIOUS SENATORS HAVE EITHER
BILLS TO PRESENT OR HAVE OTHER
RESPONSIBILITIES AND OTHER
COMMITTEES. SO THANK YOU. HAVING
SAID THAT, ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRIAN,
THE FLOOR IS YOURS. ABSOLUTELY.
ARE WE DOING AN AB 3049?
WHICHEVER ORDER YOU'D LIKE TO GO
IN, WE'LL START WITH 3049.
THAT'S PHYLUM NUMBER SEVEN, AB
3049. JUST WANT TO KEEP YOU ALL
ON YOUR TOES. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR, AND COLLEAGUES, TODAY I'M
HERE TO PRESENT AB 3049, A BILL
THAT HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT THUS FAR. I
WANT TO START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL WORK ON THIS
BILL. A RECENT STATEWIDE SURVEY
CONDUCTED BY ADVOCATES IN THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY REVEALED THAT MANY
FOSTER CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA,
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN RURAL
COUNTIES, DO NOT HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MEET WITH OR
SPEAK TO THEIR COURT APPOINTED
ATTORNEY BEFORE THE HEARINGS.
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. IT'S
SHAMEFUL. WE CAN DO BETTER.
CHILDREN IN THE CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM DEPEND ON THEIR COUNSEL
TO HELP THEM NAVIGATE AN OFTEN
TRAUMATIC AND CONFUSING
DEPENDENCY PROCESS. AB 3049 AIMS
TO IMPROVE OUR DEPENDENCY COURT
SYSTEM BY EMPOWERING A JUVENILE
JUDGE TO CONTINUE A HEARING IF
THEY FIND THAT A FOSTER YOUTH
HAS HAD HAS NOT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONSULT WITH
THEIR ATTORNEY. THE BILL ALSO
CODIFIES EXISTING RULES OF
COURT, WHICH ESTABLISH
GUIDELINES FOR COURT APPOINTED
ATTORNEYS, INCLUDING REQUIRE
THEM TO HAVE SUFFICIENT CONTACT
WITH THEIR MINOR OR NON-MINOR
DEPENDENT CLIENTS. THIS IS IN
ALIGNMENT WITH GUIDANCE FROM THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES, WHICH STATES THAT
ATTORNEYS MUST SPEND SIGNIFICANT
TIME WITH THEIR CLIENTS TO BUILD
A TRUSTING AND SUPPORTIVE
RELATIONSHIP, AND TO COUNSEL
CLIENTS ON ALL LEGAL MATTERS. AB
3049 WILL BRING ACCOUNTABILITY,
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE DEPENDENCY
COURT PROCESS AND ENSURE THAT
WHEN LIFE ALTERING DECISIONS ARE
MADE ABOUT A CHILD, THAT
DECISION IS INFORMED BY THE
CHILD'S VERY OWN OPINIONS AND
LIVED EXPERIENCES. WE'VE WORKED
WITH VARIOUS STAKEHOLDERS,
INCLUDING THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL,
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS AS EVIDENCED
THROUGH TODAY'S COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS, AND I REMAIN
COMMITTED TO HAVING
CONVERSATIONS AROUND ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES IF THOSE
STILL EXIST. JOINING ME TO
TESTIFY TODAY ARE MARGARET COIN,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR ADVOCATES
, AND CHRISTOPHER HERNANDEZ, THE
STATEWIDE LEGISLATIVE
COORDINATOR FOR CALIFORNIA YOUTH
CONNECTION. THANK YOU. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, SENATOR
UMBERG AND HONORABLE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. I'M MARGARET COIN,
CO-FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF ADVOCATES, A LEGAL
ADVOCACY NONPROFIT, STATEWIDE
LEGAL ADVOCACY NONPROFIT FOR
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE. SINCE 2004, ADVOCATES HAS
PROVIDED THE ONLY FREE TELEPHONE
HOTLINE AND LEGAL SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR ANYONE CONCERNED
ABOUT A CHILD OR YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE. WE MANAGE OVER 700 CASES
ANNUALLY, INVOLVING OVER 1000
CHILDREN. OUR LEGAL SERVICES ARE
A CRITICAL LEGAL LIFELINE FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. FOSTER AND
RELATIVE CAREGIVERS AND
RELATIVES OF CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE. VERY OFTEN, THEY CALL
ADVOCATES BECAUSE A CHILD IS AT
RISK OF EXPERIENCING OR
CURRENTLY EXPERIENCING A
TRAUMATIC EVENT. THE FIRST
QUESTIONS MY STAFF ASKS ANY
CAREGIVER WHO CALLS AND ANY
FOSTER YOUTH WHO CALL OUR
HOTLINE IS, HAVE YOU TALKED TO
THE CHILD'S ATTORNEY? BECAUSE
WHEN A CHILD IS FACING A
TRAUMATIC EVENT, AS CHILDREN AND
YOUTH IN FOSTER CARE SO OFTEN
DO, A CHILD'S ATTORNEY HAS QUICK
AND DIRECT ACCESS TO THE
JUVENILE COURT TO SEEK
PROTECTION OF THE CHILD. TOO
OFTEN, WHAT MY STAFF HEAR EVERY
DAY FROM OUR CAREGIVER AND
FOSTER YOUTH CALLERS IS NO, I
DIDN'T KNOW THAT THE CHILD HAD
AN ATTORNEY OR NO. I DON'T KNOW
THEIR NAME OR YES, I KNEW THEY
HAD AN ATTORNEY. I REACHED OUT,
BUT HAVE NEVER HEARD BACK.
ADVOCATES COLLECTS DATA FROM
EVERY FOSTER YOUTH AND CAREGIVER
WHO CALLS US AND HAS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS AND, WE ASK EVERY
CAREGIVER AND FOSTER YOUTH
CALLER WHETHER OR NOT THEY, THE
CHILD IN THEIR CARE OR THE
FOSTER YOUTH THEMSELVES HAS HAD
CONTACT WITH THEIR APPOINTED
ATTORNEY, WHAT'S CLEAR FROM THE
DATA WE COLLECT AND FROM OUR
STATEWIDE INVESTIGATIVE REPORT
WAS THAT IN MANY, MANY COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE AND AGAIN, SO
OFTEN IN RURAL COUNTIES,
ATTORNEYS FOR CHILDREN ARE
FAILING TO MEET TWO OF THEIR
BASIC OBLIGATIONS. IF YOU'D WRAP
IT UP. OH, SURE. YES, ONE IS TO
PROVIDE THEIR CONTACT
INFORMATION AND LET THE FOSTER
YOUTH OR THE CAREGIVER KNOW WHO
THEY ARE AND HOW TO REACH THEM.
AND TWO, TO HAVE SOME CONTACT
WITH THEM. SO IT IS UNDER THE
WELFARE AND INSTITUTION CODE,
SECTION 317 Â SEVEN. IT IS THE
COURT'S OBLIGATION TO PROTECT
URGING, AND I VOTE SORRY. YOU
URGE AN AYE VOTE, I ASSUME I DO
URGE AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. AND
JUST TO SAY ONE LAST THING,
PLEASE, SENATOR, IS THERE'S ONLY
ONE RULE OF COURT RIGHT NOW THAT
PROVIDES ANY PROTECTION FOR
CHILDREN WHO AREN'T AREN'T
HAVING CONTACT WITH THEIR
LAWYERS. ALL RIGHT. AND THANK
YOU. IT'S NOT GEARED. THE REMEDY
IS NOT FOR CHILDREN OR YOUTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY. NEXT
WITNESS, PLEASE. HELLO. MY NAME
IS. YEAH. OKAY. HELLO. MY NAME
IS CHRISTOPHER HERNANDEZ. I RUN
THE LEGISLATIVE DEPARTMENT AT
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION. CIC
IS A YOUTH LED ORGANIZATION THAT
DEVELOPS LEADERS WHO EMPOWER
EACH OTHER AND THEIR COMMUNITIES
TO TRANSFORM THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM THROUGH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING, LEGISLATION, POLICY,
AND PRACTICE. CHANGE OUR
MEMBERSHIP BASE IS MADE UP OF 14
TO 24 YEAR OLDS WHO ARE CURRENT
AND FORMER FOSTER YOUTH FROM ALL
ACROSS THE STATE. CIC IS A
UNIQUE POSITION IN CHILD WELFARE
BECAUSE IT HAS SUCH AN UNMATCHED
DIRECT CONNECTION TO YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY OR
FORMERLY IN THE SYSTEMS WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY. OUR
ADVOCACY THIS YEAR HAS BEEN
CENTERED ON SYSTEM
ACCOUNTABILITY AND PROTECTING
FOSTER YOUTH RIGHTS. WHEN
INTRODUCING THIS BILL TO OUR
MEMBERSHIP, THEY IMMEDIATELY
SUPPORTED THE IDEA BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATION IS DIRECT CONNECTION
TO ACCOUNTABILITY, MEET FAITH OR
AS THE STATE MAY KNOW, HER,
ARIANNA. SHE WAS TWO WHEN SHE
WAS TAKEN FROM HER FAMILY. HER
VISITS STOPPED SHORTLY AFTER SHE
WAS ADOPTED AND SHE TURNED 16
THIS YEAR. IT'S BEEN 12 YEARS
SINCE SHE HAS HAD ANY CONTACT
WITH HER FAMILY. I KNEW HER AS
MY YOUNGER SISTER, BUT NOW I'D
PROBABLY CONSIDER HER A
STRANGER. DURING OUR
INTRODUCTION TO THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM, I HAD LITTLE TO NO
SUPPORT FROM MY WORKERS OR
ASSIGNED ATTORNEYS. FAITH AND I
WERE NAVIGATING THE SYSTEM ALONE
WITH NO ACCOUNTABILITY TO ENSURE
WE REMAINED IN CONTACT OR WERE
REPLACED TOGETHER. IF I HAD
REGULAR CONTACT WITH AN
ATTORNEY, I WOULD HAVE
UNDERSTOOD WHAT WAS HAPPENING.
SOMEONE WOULD HAVE RECOGNIZED
THE SIGNS OF SEPARATION, AND
SOMEONE WOULD HAVE FOUGHT ON MY
BEHALF TO ENSURE THAT I REMAINED
IN CONTACT WITH MY LITTLE
SISTER. THIS BILL IS A TRUE STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY. I SHOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN EXPECTED TO NAVIGATE
OR ADVOCATE FOR MYSELF AT TEN,
BUT THERE WAS NO ACCOUNTABILITY
IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT I WAS
MEETING REGULARLY WITH MY
ASSIGNED ATTORNEY. MY STORY IS
ONE OF THOUSANDS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE. CIC AND I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
BECAUSE YOUTH NAVIGATING THIS
COMPLICATED SYSTEM DESERVE AN
ADVOCATE WHO WILL TRULY FIGHT
FOR THEIR RIGHTS. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. REBECCA
GONZALEZ, WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE APPROACH
MICROPHONE. LET'S TURN TO THE
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 1349, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, TRACY KENNEY,
ON BEHALF OF THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. WE WERE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED TO THE LEGISLATION AS IT
CAME TO THIS COMMITTEE. WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE PROPOSED IN
THE ANALYSIS AND APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE AUTHOR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF ON BEATING US, PART OF THE
WAY IT'S STILL UNDER REVIEW,
WHETHER OUR OPPOSITION WILL BE
ABLE TO BE REMOVED. I DO WANT TO
MAKE VERY CLEAR THAT THE COUNCIL
ABSOLUTELY SHARES ALL OF THE
GOALS OF THIS LEGISLATION. WE
WERE THE SPONSOR OF THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION REQUIRING APPOINTED
COUNSEL FOR CHILDREN IN THESE
CASES, AND WE THINK IT'S VITAL
THAT THEY HAVE ZEALOUS
REPRESENTATION BECAUSE IF THEIR
VOICES ARE NOT HEARD, THEN THE
COURTS CAN'T MAKE THE BEST
DECISIONS IN THEIR BEST
INTERESTS. WE'RE JUST
QUESTIONING WHETHER A SYSTEMIC
RESPONSE IS NECESSARY OR WHETHER
THIS IS A MORE LIMITED PROBLEM.
AND WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN THE JUDGE
AND A CHILD BEFORE THEM IN COURT
ARE THE MOST PRODUCTIVE AND
COMFORTABLE FOR THAT YOUTH IN
THAT SITUATION. SO WE WILL BE
TAKING THESE AMENDMENTS UNDER
REVIEW AND CONTINUING OUR
CONVERSATIONS. WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE EFFORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NO ONE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE. COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS. SEEING
NONE. ALL RIGHT. COAUTHORS.
OKAY. I CAN SEE IT IN YOUR EYES.
YES. ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRYANT,
JUST TO BE SURE, YOU'VE ACCEPTED
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. YES,
SIR. ALL RIGHT, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? ABSOLUTELY. I MEAN,
THIS THIS BILL CAME ABOUT
BECAUSE WE, WERE INFORMED ABOUT
A STATEWIDE ISSUE WHERE THERE
ARE MANY, MANY KIDS WHO HAVE
COURT APPOINTED ATTORNEYS BUT
HAVE NOT HAD CONTACT WITH THEM
IN THE LAST SIX MONTHS. THERE
ARE MANY INSTANCES WHERE THOSE
ATTORNEYS ARE GOING AND
ADVOCATING FOR CHILDREN WITH
WHOM THEY HAVE NOT TALKED TO,
AND WE CAN DO BETTER. I THINK WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO DO
BETTER, AND THIS BILL IS A STEP
TOWARDS HELPING US DO BETTER. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE SHOULD YOU EVER HAVE A
QUORUM. SHOULD WE EVER HAVE A
QUORUM? THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT CAVEAT. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU, YOU'VE GOT ANOTHER BILL.
ITEM NUMBER SIX, AB 2046. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES.
AB 2046 EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE
FOR THE AUTHORIZATION OF SINGLE
GENDER SCHOOLS AND CLASSES IN
LOS ANGELES IN 2017. AB 23
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED TO ALLOW
LAUSD TO CONTINUE OPERATING ITS
PILOT PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
SPECIFIC EDUCATIONAL GOALS AND
HAVE A BIANNUAL EVALUATION TO
TRACK THE RESULTS. THESE SCHOOLS
WERE ESTABLISHED TO SUPPORT
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY BY INCREASING
THE REPRESENTATION OF WOMEN AND
YOUNG GIRLS AND MINORITIES IN
STEM AND LEADERSHIP ROLES. THE
EVALUATIONS DURING THE PILOT
PERIOD WERE IMPACTED
SIGNIFICANTLY BY THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC, EXTENDING THE SUNSET
DATE ALLOWS FOR A MORE
COMPREHENSIVE AND UNINTERRUPTED
EVALUATION OF THE PROGRAM'S LONG
TERM IMPACTS. AB 2046 WILL
MAINTAIN ALL ORIGINAL
PROVISIONS, INCLUDING BI ANNUAL
EVALUATIONS, TO ENSURE ONGOING
ACCOUNTABILITY. IT WILL ALSO
MAKE EVALUATION FINDINGS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE ON THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT WEBSITE TO INCREASE
TRANSPARENCY. TO GIVE TESTIMONY.
I AM JOINED TODAY BY ANA ONA
ARCHIMEDES REPRESENTING LA USD.
THIS BILL AND THE STATE ASSEMBLY
PASSED THROUGH COMPLETELY ON
CONCURRENCE, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE. ALRIGHTY.
THANK YOU. PLEASE APPROACH. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR UMBERG AND
MEMBERS ANA IOAKIMIDIS ON BEHALF
OF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT, LOS ANGELES UNIFIED IS
PROUD TO SPONSOR ASSEMBLY BILL
2046, WHICH WILL EXTEND THE
SUNSET DATE OF A PILOT PROGRAM
AUTHORIZING SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WITH A DAILY ATTENDANCE OVER
250,000 STUDENTS TO OFFER SINGLE
GENDER EDUCATIONAL OPTIONS. LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED WAS FIRST
AUTHORIZED TO OFFER THIS OPTION
IN 2017, WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB
23. WE HAVE IMPLEMENTED THREE OF
THESE EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
FOR STUDENTS, EACH FOCUSED ON
STEM EDUCATION AND LEADERSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES. LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED IS ALSO THE AUTHORIZER
FOR THE GIRLS ACADEMIC
LEADERSHIP. EXCUSE ME, THE GIRLS
ATHLETIC LEADERSHIP SCHOOL, A
CHARTER SCHOOL FOCUSED ON HEALTH
AND WELLNESS FOR MIDDLE SCHOOL
GIRLS PURSUANT TO AB 23, LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED HAS CONTRACTED
WITH AN INDEPENDENT THIRD PARTY
RESEARCH FIRM TO CONDUCT
EVALUATIONS EVERY TWO YEARS OF
ITS PILOT PROGRAM. THE RESULTS
ARE PROMISING. STUDENTS
FREQUENTLY OUTPERFORM THEIR
PEERS AT MATCHED CO-EDUCATIONAL
SCHOOLS AND REPORT HIGHER LEVELS
OF FEELINGS OF BELONGING AND
ACCEPTANCE AT THEIR SCHOOL THAN
THE DISTRICT AVERAGE OR AVERAGE
OF PEER SCHOOLS. THE ANALYSIS
REVEALED THAT THESE SCHOOLS AND
CLASSES ARE ACCEPTING AND
SUPPORTING OF LBGTQ STUDENTS.
WHILE THESE EARLY RESEARCH
REPORTS ARE PROMISING, THE THREE
EVALUATIONS CONDUCTED THUS FAR
WERE SUBSTANTIALLY IMPACTED BY
THE DISRUPTIONS OF THE COVID 19
PANDEMIC. FOR THIS REASON, WE
BELIEVE IT IS APPROPRIATE TO
EXTEND THE AUTHORIZATION FOR THE
PILOT PROGRAM TO ALLOW FOR A
LONGITUDINAL ASSESSMENT THAT IS
NOT IMPACTED BY A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. LOS ANGELES UNIFIED IS
COMMITTED TO ENSURING ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS RECEIVE, RECEIVE THIS
OPTION TO CHOOSE THEIR BEST
EDUCATIONAL SETTING SO THEY CAN
THRIVE IN COLLEGE, CAREER AND
LIFE. AND THESE SCHOOLS ARE
PROVIDING THAT OPTIONS FOR
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WHO CHOOSE
TO ENROLL THERE. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE. ALRIGHTY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. OTHERS
IN SUPPORT OF AB 2046. PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
LET'S TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED, AB 2046, PLEASE
APPROACH YOUR MICROPHONE SEEING
NO ONE APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR YES, I
DO. I DON'T REALLY HAVE A
QUESTION, BUT, WE STILL DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM. BUT I GOT YOU
WHEN THIS ONE COMES UP AND WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. OKAY. SO SENATOR
ASHBY HAS YOU. ALL RIGHT. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO
ALWAYS HAVING ME. RIGHT, AND
THIS IS A BIPARTISAN BILL, JUST
TO EXTEND A SUNSET IN L.A. USD
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ACCOUNTING FOR THE DELAYS
THAT COVID 19 HAD IN OUR
EVALUATION PROCESSES. THIS IS
ONE OF THOSE BILLS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL
RIGHT. AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME,
I EXPECT THEY'LL BE. THERE IS A
MOTION. THERE WILL BE A MOTION.
ALL RIGHT. LET'S NOW TURN TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE. THEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN AND
THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPPIN. SO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE, WE STILL
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. I DON'T
KNOW IF PEOPLE ARE LISTENING,
BUT I MIGHT HAVE MENTIONED WE
DON'T HAVE A QUORUM. WE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE A QUORUM. IF PEOPLE
SHOW UP, WE WILL HAVE A QUORUM.
SO SOMETHING THAT, CHAIRMAN DODD
DID AT GEO COMMITTEE LAST WEEK
WHEN WE HAD A SIMILAR SITUATION,
AFTER EVERY BILL, HE CALLED OUT
BY NAME, THE SENATORS WHO SHOULD
BE HERE, WHO ARE NOT HERE. THAT
IS AN EXCELLENT SUGGESTION,
THÀNH. I DON'T YOU KNOW, WE'RE
CASTING ASPERSIONS AND THE OTHER
SENATORS ARE ACTUALLY IN OTHER
COMMITTEE HEARINGS, BUT YOUR
SUGGESTION IS WELL TAKEN. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU. SO, MEMBER
LEE, PHYLUM NUMBER 20, AB 3031.
ALL RIGHT. WELL, THANK YOU SO
MUCH, MR. CHAIR. AND SENATORS, I
WANT TO START BY THANKING YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE ON THE BILL, AND I
COMMIT TO TAKING THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE, WHICH IS GEO
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION. THE
BILL CREATES THE LGBTQ PLUS
COMMISSION IN STATE GOVERNMENT
TO SERVE AS A STATE LEVEL FOCAL
POINT FOR THE WIDE RANGE OF
ISSUES FACING FACING THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY, AND WILL SERVE
AS A VALUABLE VOICE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER POLICIES
THAT IMPACT OUR STATE. IT WILL
BE TASKED WITH IDENTIFYING THE
STATEWIDE NEEDS OF THE LGBTQ
PLUS COMMUNITY AND PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE IN POLICY
IMPLEMENTATION. IN ADDITION, THE
COMMISSION WILL COLLECT DATA AND
INFORMATION TO REPORT TO THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
WITH RECOMMENDATIONS, POLICIES
THAT ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITY WITH THE AMENDMENTS.
THE BILL IS MODELED AFTER
EXISTING COMMISSIONS,
PARTICULARLY THE COMMISSION ON
THE STATUS OF WOMEN AND GIRLS.
AS A STATE AND SOCIETY, I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MADE STRIDES TO
CELEBRATE AND ENCOURAGE THE
VALUES OF EVERY PERSON. BUT THE
JOB IS NEVER DONE AND THIS
COMMISSION, SEEKS TO FURTHER
THAT. AND I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTES THAT WHEN THE TIME COMES
WITH ME TODAY, I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES, ALICE KESSLER, WHO IS
REPRESENTING EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
, AND ALLIE HUGHES, REPRESENTING
BAYMAK. THANK YOU. FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS. ALICE KESSLER, I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL, YOU KNOW,
TO THERE ARE A LOT OF AREAS, AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED,
THAT WE AT EQUALITY CALIFORNIA
HAVE WORKED ON IN TERMS OF
ADVANCING CIVIL RIGHTS
LEGISLATION IN THE STATE. BUT
THE IMPLEMENTING OF A LOT OF
THOSE PROGRAMS IS A DAUNTING
CHALLENGE IN A STATE AS BIG AS
OURS, WITH AS DIVERSE OF AN LGBT
, Q PLUS COMMUNITY AS WE HAVE.
AND WE THINK HAVING THIS BODY
THAT WILL GIVE ATTENTION, YOU
KNOW, THERE ARE LOTS OF ISSUES
THAT DESERVE ATTENTION IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT WE'VE SEEN SOME
REALLY TROUBLING FIGURES AND
STATISTICS COMING OUT. ONE, I
JUST WANTED TO SHARE QUICKLY IS
THAT BETWEEN 2021 AND 22, THERE
WERE OVER 391 REPORTED HATE
INCIDENTS, MOTIVATED BY SEXUAL
ORIENTATION BIAS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT'S A 29% INCREASE SINCE
THE PREVIOUS YEAR. SO WE'RE
SEEING THESE THINGS ON THE RISE,
AND WE NEED MORE ATTENTION, MORE
RESOURCES AND MORE DEDICATION
FROM OUR STATE TO SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS. SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS. MY NAME
IS ALI HUGHES. I'M REPRESENTING
BAYMAK, FIRST OF ALL, HAPPY
PRIDE MONTH, SO I'M THE
SECRETARY TO BAYMAX, EXECUTIVE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS, AND BAYMAX
IS ONE OF THE NATION'S LARGEST
AND OLDEST ORGANIZATIONS
REPRESENTING AND EMPOWERING THE
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY. AND WE'RE
AND WE'RE BASED IN, THE BAY
AREA. SO, AS YOU MAY KNOW, THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOES NOT
CURRENTLY HAVE A COMMISSION
ADVISING ON POLICIES THAT RELATE
TO THE WELL-BEING OF ADULT,
LGBTQ PLUS PERSONS. AND I FIRMLY
BELIEVE THAT CALIFORNIA'S QUEER
COMMUNITY DESERVES A SPACE WHERE
OUR VOICES ARE ELEVATED,
EMPOWERED, AS WELL AS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE TO
ADDRESS ISSUES THAT PARTICULARLY
AFFECT OUR COMMUNITY.
CALIFORNIA'S LGBTQ PLUS
COMMUNITY IS BEAUTIFULLY
DIVERSE, REPRESENTING EVERY
CULTURE, BACKGROUND, ETHNICITY,
RELIGION, THÀNH AND
UNFORTUNATELY, WE'VE SEEN
HUNDREDS OF ANTI-LGBTQ, C¯ PLUS
AND ANTI-TRANS BILLS INTRODUCED
IN OTHER STATE LEGISLATURES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY. SO THE
TIMING IS IT'S VERY TIMELY THAT
THIS COMMISSION WILL OFFER
INVALUABLE OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE TO CREATE POLICIES
THAT POSITIVELY ELEVATE OUR
COMMUNITY, AND AS WELL AS
WORKING TO ADDRESS ISSUES THAT
NEGATIVELY IMPACT US, CREATING
AND PROTECTING SPACES FOR THE
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY ARE IS
NECESSARY AS WE STRIVE TO CREATE
A BETTER CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF AB
3031, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. JOSH
GALLAGHER, ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AFTERNOON.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICHOLAS
WEISS, DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE
ELSE APPROACHING, LET'S TURN TO
OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 3031, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. SEEING NO ONE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE, LET'S
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BY THE WAY, LET ME THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, SENATOR CABALLERO.
SENATOR CABALLEROS HERE. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHER QUESTIONS.
QUESTIONS, COMMENTS. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS, NO COMMENTS, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE? I VOTE NGUYEN TIME COMES.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, WE'LL DO
NEXT, WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN, THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PAPPIN. ACTUALLY, WE
DON'T HAVE ANY AUTHORS HERE, SO
IF SOMEBODY SHOWS BEFORE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN,
THEN THEY WILL BE ABLE TO WALK
RIGHT UP TO THE PODIUM AND
PRESENT THEIR BILL. THIS IS A
SPECIAL ONE TIME OFFER.
SO I MISSPOKE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PAPINES, ITEM NUMBER 20, FILE
NUMBER 25 HAS BEEN PULLED FOR
TODAY. WILL BE HEARD A LATER
DATE, SO THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
AFTER SOME OF OUR MAIN SHINE,
THAT WOULD BE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS FOLLOWED BY,
SPEAKER EMERITUS RENDON. HE.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. MAIENSCHEIN
YOU'RE UP. OKAY. THANK. YOU
KNOW, FILM NUMBER 22, AB 2935,
THANK YOU SO MUCH, MR. CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS, I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS AS
PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS. AB
2935 IS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION TO
PROTECT FOSTER YOUTH. FOSTER
YOUTH ARE ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE
TO HAVING THEIR IDENTITIES
STOLEN DUE TO THE LARGE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE ACCESS TO
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THÀNH. EACH TIME A FOSTER CHILD
CHANGES PLACEMENTS, ADDITIONAL
INDIVIDUALS GAIN ACCESS TO THEIR
INFORMATION, INCLUDING THEIR
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER. CHILDREN
HAVE ALWAYS BEEN AN ATTRACTIVE
TARGET FOR IDENTITY THIEVES
BECAUSE THEIR CREDIT REPORTS ARE
CLEAN AND ARE OFTEN LEFT
UNMONITORED FOR MANY YEARS,
PROVIDING AMPLE TIME TO CAUSE
SUBSTANTIAL DAMAGE TO THE
CHILD'S CREDIT. ONCE A FOSTER
YOUTH REACHES 14, OR IF THEY
COME INTO THE SYSTEM AFTER THE
AGE OF 14. CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
COUNTY WELFARE DEPARTMENTS TO
CHECK WITH THE THREE CREDIT
BUREAUS TO SEE IF A CREDIT
REPORT EXISTS. BECAUSE CHILDREN
SHOULD NOT HAVE CREDIT REPORTS,
THE EXISTENCE OF A REPORT IS
LIKELY THE RESULT OF FRAUD.
HOWEVER, OUR CURRENT LAWS ONLY
COME INTO PLAY AFTER A YOUTH HAS
BEEN VICTIMIZED. THIS BILL SEEKS
TO PREVENT IDENTITY THEFT IN THE
FIRST PLACE BY REQUIRING THE
CREDIT BUREAUS TO AUTOMATICALLY
FREEZE AN INDIVIDUAL'S CREDIT
REPORTS WHEN THEY RECEIVE AN
INQUIRY FROM A COUNTY WELFARE
DEPARTMENT REGARDING A FOSTER
YOUTH, PLACING THE AUTOMATIC
FREEZE WILL PREVENT SIMILAR
MAIENSCHEIN. I'VE NEVER DONE
THIS BEFORE. IT DOESN'T BOTHER
ME AT ALL. I COMPLETELY CONCUR
WITH WHAT YOU'RE ABOUT TO SAY
SO, BUT I APOLOGIZE, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FOR PURPOSES OF ESTABLISHING A
QUORUM. BURKE HERE. BURKE HERE.
WILK PRESENT. WILK PRESENT. ALAN
ASHBY HERE. ASHBY HERE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. HERE.
RUSSELL. LAIRD NILO. NILO. HERE.
ROTH ROTH. HERE. STERN. WAHAB,
YOU HAVE A QUORUM. WE HAVE A
QUORUM. NO APPLAUSE. ALL RIGHT,
SO, THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M
SORRY. THANK YOU. JUST TO
CONCLUDE, PLACING THE AUTOMATIC
FREEZE WILL PREVENT NEFARIOUS
ACTORS FROM BEING ABLE TO OPEN
ACCOUNTS IN A CHILD'S NAME. AND
MY WITNESS IS IN ANOTHER,
HEARING. SO. ALL RIGHT, SO YOUR
WITNESS IS SOMEWHERE ELSE,
CORRECT? IS THERE ANY ANYBODY
HERE THAT WANTS TO, OFFER ME TWO
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL? SEEING NONE. ANYBODY HERE
IN OPPOSITION? AMENDMENT ON
BEHALF OF THE SILVERGATE
ASSOCIATION, WE SUPPORT ABOUT
WHAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROTECTING THE YOUTH AND THEIR
CREDIT REPORTS. WHERE WE WOULD
SUGGEST AN AMENDMENT IS WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT A FREEZE SHOULD BE
LIFTED AUTOMATICALLY AT AGE 18.
WE BELIEVE IT'S MORE IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
INFORMATION REMAINS SEALED. BUT
IF THE PERSON WANTS IT UNFROZEN,
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT. IT'S VERY EASY TO DO IT.
IF YOU GO ONLINE NØ ALL THE
CREDIT BUREAUS YOU JUST TYPE IN,
UNFREEZE YOUR CREDIT REPORT, ALL
THE INFORMATION COMES UP HOW YOU
CAN DO IT. SO WE THINK IT'S MUCH
BETTER TO HAVE THE PERSON OPT IN
TO SAY THEY WANT THEIR FREEZE
REMOVED, AS OPPOSED TO
AUTOMATICALLY REFUSING IT.
EXCUSE ME OF LIFTING IT FOR
THOSE REASONS, WE ARE OPPOSING
THE BILL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. LET'S
PULL IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS, COMMENTS,
CONCERNS. SEEING NONE, CAN I?
FIRST OF ALL, I'D LOVE TO BE A
COAUTHOR. POSSIBLE. HAPPY TO.
AND I'D LOVE TO SEE SOMEBODY
ACTUALLY MAKE A MOTION. SENATOR
ALLEN, THANKS FOR PARTICIPATING.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION WITH THAT.
WOULD YOU LOVE TO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YES, I WOULD ACTUALLY
EVEN LOVE TO CLOSE. I APPRECIATE
THE SUPPORT, MR. CHAIR. I YOU
KNOW, THE RESPONSE IS FAIRLY
DISINGENUOUS ABOUT FOSTER KIDS
BEING ABLE TO VERY EASILY DO
THIS. OF COURSE THEY CAN'T. AND
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE THE VICTIMS
OF IDENTITY THEFT SO OFTEN. AND
THEY'VE ALREADY, WITH ALL THE
HURDLES THAT THEY FACE TO THEN
HAVE THEM TRY TO NAVIGATE. AND I
DON'T KNOW IF ANYONE IN THIS
ROOM HAS EVER TRIED TO NAVIGATE
AN IDENTITY THEFT OR HAD A
RELATIVE. WHAT A COMPLETE AND
TOTAL NIGHTMARE IT IS FOR PEOPLE
WITH RESOURCES TO IMAGINE AN 18
YEAR OLD FOSTER KID, OR 14,
TRYING TO DO IT, IS OUTRAGEOUS.
SO WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON THAT.
OKAY. AND THE RECOMMENDATION IS,
DO PASS IS AMENDED TO SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES. OKAY DO PASS IS
AMENDED TO HUMAN SERVICES. SO
WITH THAT, LET'S CALL ROLL. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 22 AB 2935.
THE MOTION IS Dð PASSES AMENDED
TO SENATE HUMAN SERVICES NUMBER
WILK. Ã WILK I ALAN ALLEN I
ASHBY. CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
DURAZO DURAZO I LAIRD. NILO I
NILO I ROTH. ROTH I STERN.
WAHAB. YOU HAVE 6 TO 0 RIGHT NOW
WITH MEMBERS MISSING. ALL RIGHT.
SIX ZERO, MR. CHAIRMAN. AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. Þ IS OTHER ONES ON
CONSENT, I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS, ITEM NUMBER 29.
IT DOESN'T SEEM RIGHT. YOU JUST
GOT HERE AND YOU GET TO PRESENT.
BUT, FILE ITEM 29 AB 2004.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN PETRIE-NORRIS, THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
WITH THAT, THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
WELL, THANK YOU, MR. VICE CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO PRESENT
AB 2004, THIS BILL WILL MAKE
MINOR CHANGES TO IMPROVE REMOTE
ONLINE NOTARIZATION IN
CALIFORNIA. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK, AS WELL AS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE FOR
THEIR COLLABORATION ON THIS
BILL. AND WE WILL BE ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS. AS YOU MAY RECALL,
LAST YEAR, CALIFORNIA
ESTABLISHED A LEGAL FRAMEWORK
FOR REMOTE ONLINE NOTARIZATION.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS FRAMEWORK
DID NOT CONSIDER THE CONSTRAINTS
OF 13 CALIFORNIA COUNTIES THAT
ARE NOT CURRENTLY EQUIPPED TO
ACCEPT ELECTRONIC DOCUMENTS FOR
RECORDING PURPOSES, SO THIS BILL
WILL MAKE CHANGES TO ENABLE ALL
COUNTIES TO INTEGRATE ELECTRONIC
NOTARIZATIONS INTO THEIR
PROCESS. WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE SECRETARY OF
STATE'S OFFICE TO RESOLVE THEIR
CONCERNS. THIS IS A CLARIFYING
MEASURE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
ONLINE NOTARY SYSTEM WORKS AS
INTENDED IN ALL COUNTIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I'D NOW
LIKE TO INTRODUCE ANTHONY
HELTON, WHO IS JOINING US ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LAND
TITLE ASSOCIATION. WONDERFUL.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS. ANTHONY HELTON WITH
CALIFORNIA LAND TITLE
ASSOCIATION, AB 2004 IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD MEASURE JUST
INTENDED TO CREATE A PROCESS BY
WHICH REMOTELY NOTARIZED
DOCUMENTS, WHICH INHERENTLY
EXIST IN ELECTRONIC FORMAT, CAN
BE CONVERTED TO PAPER FOR THE
PURPOSE OF BEING RECORDED IN
REAL PROPERTY RECORDS.
LEGISLATION FOLLOWS THE EXAMPLE
OF 35 OTHER STATES THAT PROVIDE
FOR THE PAPERING OUT OF REMOTELY
NOTARIZED DOCUMENTS WAS DRAFTED
AND COORDINATION WITH THE
NATIONAL NOTARY ASSOCIATION,
AND, AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED,
REFLECTS THE PRODUCT OF A
THOUGHTFUL AND DELIBERATE DIALOG
WITH THE OFFICE OF THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO PRESERVE THE CORE
INTENT OF THE BILL WHILE
MAINTAINING NOTARIES PRESENCE IN
THE CERTIFICATION PROCESS, BUT
IN THEIR TRADITIONAL ROLE AS
THAT OF AN IMPARTIAL WITNESS AND
DOCUMENT SIGNINGS. THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS UNDER AB
2004 IS SIMPLE, SECURE AND WOULD
ENABLE THE RESIDENTS OF 13
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES THAT TODAY
ONLY ACCEPT PAPER DOCUMENTS FOR
RECORDING TO BENEFIT FROM RON AS
AN OPTION WHEN THEY LOOK TO HAVE
DOCUMENTS RECORD NOTARIZED
SEPARATELY. IN RECOGNITION OF
THE FACT THAT RON MAKES
TECHNICAL DEFECTS AND AN
ACKNOWLEDGMENT LESS LIKELY TO
OCCUR, BUT IN SOME CASES HARDER
TO DETECT, AB 2004 WOULD SHORTEN
THE TIME AT WHICH HARMLESS
ERRORS MADE IN THE
ACKNOWLEDGMENT OF REAL PROPERTY
RELATED DOCUMENTS ARE CURED,
THEREBY DECREASING THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT A HOMEOWNER
WOULD HAVE TO UNDERTAKE THE TIME
AND EXPENSE OF ACTIVELY
CORRECTING THE ERROR IN TANDEM.
WE BELIEVE THESE PROVISIONS
OFFER SUBSTANTIAL BENEFIT TO
CALIFORNIANS, PARTICULARLY FOR
RESIDENTS IN THE MORE RURAL
AREAS OF THE STATE, AND THAT
THEY WILL HELP PROVIDE
INDIVIDUALS WITH GREATER CHOICE
AND HOW THEY CAN HAVE THEIR
DOCUMENTS NOTARIZED. HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT THE
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE AS BEST I
CAN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN
SUPPORT? NAME ORGANIZATION, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS, TIM CARMODY,
ON BEHALF OF SECRETARY OF STATE,
DOCTOR SHIRLEY AND WEBER, WE
PREVIOUSLY HAD A POSITION OF
OPPOSE, UNLESS AMENDED WITH THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I'M HERE
TO CONFIRM THAT WE ARE PLEASED
TO REMOVE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
. THANK YOU. SIR MATT REMOTE
WITH NEMO PAPPAS ASSOCIATES HERE
ON BEHALF OF PROOF HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE. THANK
YOU, SIR INDIRA MCDONALD HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. GOOD AFTERNOON. EMILY
DOE, WITH THE CALIFORNIA CREDIT
UNION LEAGUE IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION?
SEEING NONE, WE'LL PULL BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS. SENATOR
ALLEN, DID YOU MAKE A MOTION?
ALL RIGHT. SENATOR ALLEN'S MADE
A MOTION. ASSEMBLYMAN NGUYEN,
YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU. I'LL
JUST CLOSE BY RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR YOUR I VOTE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. VERY WELL DONE.
AND WITH THAT ALREADY SAID WHAT
THE RECOMMENDATION WAS, I
ALREADY FORGOT IT. BUT WE'RE
GONNA KEEP MOVING ON, SO CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM 29
AB 2004. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT NUMBER WILK. Ã WILK
I ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I DURAZO.
DURAZO I LAIRD. NILO. NILO I.
ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB. 6 TO
0 6 TO 0. WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN
FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU SENATOR. YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, BLANCA RUBIO,
ITEM 35 866 WANTS THE
RECOMMENDATION. THÀNH DO PASS.
JUST DO PASS. YES I I'M GOING TO
START DOING THAT. I WILL STOP
HERE. I DON'T KNOW, I'M HERE. I
DID NOT DID I? WELL, I APOLOGIZE
, ALL RIGHT. APOLOGIES ARE GOOD.
ALL RIGHT. YEAH. IT'S A
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE. OKAY. I'M
GOING TO FORGIVE YOU. ALL RIGHT,
UP NEXT IS FILE ITEM 35 AB 866
BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN RUBIO. THE
RECOMMENDATION IS Dð. PASS TO
THE FLOOR. AND WITH THAT, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. AND SENATORS. AB 866 IS A
CONTINUATION OF OUR EFFORTS TO
FURTHER PROTECT OUR FOSTER
YOUTH, ESPECIALLY IN THE FACE OF
OUR ONGOING OPIOID CRISIS. JUST
LAST YEAR, THE STATE REVISED
RESTRICTIONS ON FEDERALLY
APPROVED OPIOID USE DISORDER
TREATMENTS, WHICH CAN BE
ADMINISTERED OUTSIDE OF A
CLINICAL SETTING. THIS ALLOWED
YOUTH 16 YEARS OF AGE AND OLDER
TO SEEK TREATMENT WITHOUT THE
STIGMA OF, OR FEAR OFTEN
ASSOCIATED WITH, SEEKING STATE
SUPPORT. IN CASES OF OPIOID
ADDICTION, RECEIVING TIMELY AND
ACCESSIBLE TREATMENT IS, WITHOUT
EXAGGERATION, A MATTER OF LIFE
OR DEATH. SINCE THE PASSAGE OF
AB 816 LAST YEAR, OUR COLLEAGUES
REPRESENTING FOSTER YOUTH IN THE
LEGAL SYSTEM HAVE FOUND THAT
THERE IS UNCERTAINTY IN THE
APPLICATION OF THE LAW, LEAVING
FOSTER YOUTH WITHOUT THE SAME
TREATMENT CERTAINTY AS THOSE
OUTSIDE OF THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. THESE SAME YOUTH OFTEN
HAVE TRAUMA HISTORIES THEY HAVE
THAT HAVE ARISEN FROM BOTH
WITHIN AND OUTSIDE OF THE
SYSTEM, RESULTING IN ESPECIALLY
DANGEROUS ADDICTION
CIRCUMSTANCES. ADDITIONALLY,
MANY OF THESE YOUTHS HAVE
GENETIC AND ENVIRONMENTAL RISK
FACTORS THAT INCREASE THEIR
CHANCES OF ADDICTION AND
OVERDOSE. WHILE THIS IS TRAGIC,
WE EVEN NEED LEGISLATION SUCH AS
THIS OR ITS PREDECESSOR FOR THAT
MATTER. THE REALITY IS THAT BY
ENSURING FOSTER YOUTH HAVE
ACCESS TO THESE TREATMENTS,
LIVES WILL BE SAVED BY
CLARIFYING THE ROLE OF COURT
OVERSIGHT. IN THESE CASES. THIS
MEASURE PROVIDES CERTAINTY FOR
FOSTER YOUTH WHO COULD BENEFIT
FROM AND PROACTIVELY SEEK
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREATMENT,
JUST LIKE OTHERS OUTSIDE OF THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. I WANT TO
REITERATE REITERATE THIS MEASURE
SIMPLY ENSURES THAT FOSTER YOUTH
CAN RECEIVE THE SAME TREATMENT
AS YOUTH OUTSIDE OF THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM, AS ALREADY ALLOWED
BY CURRENT LAW. THIS MEASURE HAS
A COALITION OF FOSTER YOUTH
ADVOCATES AND SUPPORT AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION WITH ME. TODAY ON
BEHALF OF OUR SPONSOR IS ANN
QUIRK, A POLICY ATTORNEY WITH
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHTY, UNDER COMMITTEE RULES,
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES, AND
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY, GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. I AM ANN
QUIRK, POLICY ATTORNEY AT
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA, THE LARGEST
CHILDREN'S LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION IN THE NATION,
ADVOCATING FOR OVER 25,000
CHILDREN AND YOUTH IN THE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM IN LOS
ANGELES, SACRAMENTO AND PLACER
COUNTIES. WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR
AB EIGHT, SIX SIX AND ARE
GRATEFUL FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO'S PARTNERSHIP IN ENSURING
OLDER FOSTER YOUTH SUFFERING
SUFFERING FROM OPIOID ADDICTION
RECEIVE THE CARE AND TREATMENT
THEY NEED. IT'S HEARTBREAKING TO
LOSE A TEENAGE CLIENT, AND WE'VE
LOST FAR TOO MANY BOTH TO
OVERDOSE AND TO THE DANGERS AND
VIOLENCE THAT OFTEN ACCOMPANY
OPIOID ADDICT THÀNH. THIS BILL
WILL CLARIFY THAT FOR OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH CAN GET THE MEDICAL
TREATMENT THEY NEED RIGHT AWAY.
ANYONE WHO HAS UP CLOSE
EXPERIENCE WITH ADDICTION,
EITHER THEIR OWN OR LOVED ONES,
KNOWS HOW SHORT THAT WINDOW CAN
BE. WHEN SOMEBODY WILL TAKE HELP
. THE COURT PROCESS DOES NOT
MOVE QUICKLY. IT CAN TAKE WEEKS,
EVEN MONTHS. WE DON'T HAVE THAT
KIND OF TIME. THE CONSEQUENCE OF
NOT GETTING TIMELY ACCESS CAN BE
DEVASTATING. IT MEANS THE DRUG
ABUSE CONTINUES ALONG WITH THE
DANGERS OF IT. IN ADDITION TO
THE RISK OF OVERDOSE AND DEATH,
OPIOID ADDICTION IS EXPENSIVE.
PREDATORS TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE YOUNG PEOPLE'S
DESPERATION, AND THEY EXPLOIT
THEM IN EXCHANGE FOR PROVIDING
DRUGS. GETTING HELP IS
INTIMIDATING. CURRENTLY, OUR 16
AND 17 YEAR OLDS CAN CONSENT TO
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREATMENT BY
THEMSELVES, BUT MAY DO SO IN
SECRET. THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT
THE YOUNG PERSON CAN SEEK HELP
FROM THEIR SOCIAL WORKER, THEIR
CASA, THEIR ATTORNEY, WITHOUT
REQUIRING THEIR STRUGGLE WITH
ADDICTION TO BECOME A PART OF
THEIR PERMANENT COURT FILE. THEY
CAN ALSO BE OPEN WITH THEIR
DOCTOR ABOUT BEING IN FOSTER
CARE, SO THAT A TREATMENT PLAN
CAN BE INDIVIDUALLY TAILORED TO
BEST MEET THEIR NEEDS AND ENSURE
SAFE PLACEMENTS. I WANT TO ONCE
AGAIN THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO FOR AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND WOULD
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM THAT WANT TO ADD THEIR
VOICE IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL?
PLEASE COME FORWARD. NAME,
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. LIZZY
KUTSUNA, CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
CHILD AND ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY
AND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU CAP BEST WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF CHILD
AND FAMILY SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
ELIZABETH ESPINOSA, ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF SANTA CLARA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ANYONE IN THE ROOM IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE, PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS. CALL SENATOR NILO.
I'M A LITTLE UNCLEAR WITH REGARD
TO THE CURRENT SITUATION.
PRESUMABLY THE THRESHOLD IS 18
BECAUSE THAT'S THE AGE AT WHICH
THEY BECOME ADULTS. BUT WHAT
CURRENTLY HAPPENS WITH FOSTER
KIDS BETWEEN 16 AND 18. SO,
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION. SO
CURRENTLY THE LAW WAS CHANGED TO
ALLOW 16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS TO
CONSENT TO SEEK TREATMENT. AND
THOSE ARE I'M GOING TO CALL THEM
REGULAR KIDS. YOU MEAN OUTSIDE
THE FOSTER? OUTSIDE THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM? WE CAN DO THAT IN
THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. THEY
HAVE TO GO GET APPROVAL BY
EITHER THE COURT OR THE SOCIAL
WORKERS HAVE TO TAKE IT TO A
JUDGE TO BE ABLE TO OBTAIN THIS
KIND OF TREATMENT, BECAUSE
THEY'RE IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. SO REGULAR KIDS 16 AND
17 YEAR OLDS CAN JUST GO AND GET
TREATMENT WHILE THE FOSTER KIDS
CAN'T. AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
ALIGN THAT. I GET THAT I, I VIEW
THE TWO POPULATIONS AS BEING
SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT, BUT BUT
NONETHELESS, WHAT HAS HAPPENED
WITH REGARD TO FOSTER KIDS
BETWEEN 16 AND 18? DO WE HAVE
DATA ON THAT? I DO WE HAVE ANY
OF THAT DATA AVAILABLE? WE IT'S
JUST BEEN A YEAR, SO WE DON'T IT
HASN'T EVEN BEEN A FULL YEAR
YET, SO WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
ON IT. WHAT, MAYBE YOU DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND MY QUESTION. IT'S
BEEN A YEAR ON THE ALLOWANCE FOR
KIDS OUTSIDE THE FOSTER SYSTEM.
I GET THAT, BUT. BUT THE
EXISTING CASE HAS BEEN THE
SITUATION ALL ALONG FOR FOSTER
KIDS BETWEEN 16 AND 18 CANNOT
PROVIDE THEIR OWN PERMISSION. DO
WE HAVE DATA ON WHAT'S HAPPENED
WITH THOSE KIDS? RELATIVE TO, A
TREATMENT FOR DRUG ABUSE? HAVE
THEY BEEN ABLE TO READILY GET
APPROVAL FROM A SOCIAL WORKER, A
FOSTER PARENT, OR THE COURT OR
OTHERWISE? OR ARE THERE
SIGNIFICANT, PROBLEMS WITH THAT
POPULATION? WELL, IF I IF I MAY
JUST SHE CAN ANSWER THE MORE
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS, BUT THEY
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THROUGH
COURT. AND, YOU KNOW, THAT
DOESN'T HAPPEN OVERNIGHT. SO,
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE TO GO PETITION
AND THEN, IT TAKES ANYWHERE
BETWEEN, YOU KNOW, A MONTH TO
SIX, SOMETIMES EIGHT MONTHS TO
GET THAT KIND OF APPROVAL WHEN A
REGULAR CHILD CAN JUST GO AND
GET IT. SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO, AND I KNOW YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT PART, BUT, JUST WANT TO
REITERATE THAT THIS WOULD BE
JUST SIMPLY SAYING TO THE SOCIAL
WORKER, I THINK I WANT TREATMENT
AND THAT THEY CAN JUST GO DO IT
AS OPPOSED TO HAVING TO GO
THROUGH THE COURT SYSTEM, WHICH
CAN TAKE AGAIN, IMPACTED COURT
SYSTEM CAN TAKE ANYWHERE BETWEEN
TWO, 6 OR 8 MONTHS FOR THEM TO
GET THAT KIND OF TREATMENT. SO
THAT'S WHY, WITHOUT EXAGGERATION
, I AM SAYING THAT IF THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN, SOME OF THESE
KIDS CAN DIE BECAUSE IF THEY'RE
READY TO SEEK TREATMENT, IT'S
BECAUSE THEY'RE ALREADY AT THAT
POINT, THE LOWEST POINT IN THEIR
LIFE THAT THEY CAN BE. I CAN SEE
THAT WITH FOSTER KIDS, I, I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL, BUT
NOT BECAUSE I SUPPORT THE
CAPABILITY FOR THOSE NOT IN THE
FOSTER SYSTEM. I DO NOT,
ABSOLUTELY, KIDS CANNOT. I
BELIEVE WELL, IT'S HARD FOR
ANYBODY TO GO THROUGH.
ABSOLUTELY, TO GET OFF DRUG
ADDICTION ON THEIR OWN. KIDS
WERE ADULTS. I COMPLETELY
DISAGREE WITH THE POLICY THAT
WAS APPROVED BEFORE FOR KIDS NOT
IN THE FOSTER SYSTEM, IN
PRESUMABLY NORMAL HOMES HAVE
PARENTS. THEY NEED THEIR PARENTS
WITH THEM. I I, I'M NOT
APPROVING THIS TO MAKE IT
CONSISTENT. I DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE. THE FOSTER CHILD
SITUATION IS DIFFERENT. YES.
BECAUSE OF THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES.
ABSOLUTELY AND I YOU KNOW, AND I
CAN APPRECIATE THAT THAT, I CAN
TELL YOU AS A SCHOOL TEACHER, I
TAUGHT FOR 16 YEARS AND, YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES THE KIDS ARE IN
THE SAME BOAT WITH THEIR
PARENTS, SO SOMETIMES SOME OF
THOSE KIDS CAN'T SEEK TREATMENT
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS ARE IN THE
SAME SITUATION OF ADDICTION. YOU
KNOW, IT'S IT TENDS TO BE THAT
THAT DRUG ADDICTION AND NOT IN
ALL CASES, ESPECIALLY NOW WE
KNOW THAT THAT'S NOT THE CASE.
BUT FOR IN THE PAST, THE REASON
KIDS ARE ADDICTED IS BECAUSE
EITHER THEY HAVE PARENTS THAT
ARE ADDICTED OR, YOU KNOW, THEY
HAVE, FAMILY SITUATIONS WHERE
THEY ARE ADDICTED. AND TO YOUR
POINT, THE FOSTER CARE, THE
FOSTER KIDS ARE DIFFERENT, AND I
APPRECIATE THAT, YOU KNOW, IT'S
NOT BECAUSE YOU'RE ALIGNING IT,
BUT BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE FOSTER KIDS HAVE A WHOLE
DIFFERENT SET OF ISSUES. AND,
YOU KNOW, I CAN I DON'T HAVE
DATA IN FRONT OF ME, BUT I CAN
TELL YOU JUST ANECDOTALLY THAT
THAT FOSTER CARE KIDS HAVE WAY
MORE ISSUES THAN QUOTE UNQUOTE,
NORMAL KIDS. AND SO FOR ME, IT'S
A MATTER OF TRYING TO GIVE THEM
OPTIONS TO BE ABLE TO, TO SEEK
TREATMENT, SOME OF THESE KIDS
CAN BE ON THE STREET, YOU KNOW,
WE KNOW THAT SOME FOSTER KIDS
ARE ON THE STREETS, AND EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE IN THE SYSTEM,
THEY'RE NOT NECESSARILY IN A
HOUSE. SO THIS IS THE ATTEMPT TO
BE ABLE TO AT LEAST PROVIDE SOME
KIND OF, TREATMENT FOR THEM,
ASIDE FROM THE REGULAR KIDS.
THANK YOU. I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
ANYTHING FOR YOU. I THINK SHE
ANSWERED IT SUFFICIENTLY.
CORRECT, SIR. BEG PARDON? SHE
ANSWERED THE QUESTION. OKAY WITH
THAT, LOOKING FOR A MOTION,
SENATOR ALLEN'S. AND SO YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU. YOU KNOW, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. I HOPE THAT I DID ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS. IF YOU REQUIRE
SOME MORE DATA, WE WOULD SEND
THAT TO YOU. THANK YOU. GREAT
LET'S CALL THE ROLL THIS THIS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 35 AB 866. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS UMBERG WILK
I WILK I ALLEN ALLEN I ASHBY.
CABALLERO CABALLERO I DURAZO
RUSSELL I LAYERED NILO NILO I
ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB 6 TO
0. THANK YOU 6 TO 0 WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD ON.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN IS
PRESENTING FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OF LONDON. OH, OKAY. BECAUSE I
BECAUSE HE WAS. ALL RIGHT. OKAY.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM 30 3AB 2202. IT'S
AUTHORED BY, I GUESS, SPEAKER
PRO TEM EMERITUS RENDON. BUT
BEING PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLYMAN
BERMAN AND YOU LOOK YOU LOOK
PRETTY CHIPPER TODAY. SO GOOD
FOR YOU AND WITH HIM AND WITH
THAT, YOU MAY OPEN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. IT'S GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN, SENATOR WILK. CHAIR
WILK, I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF SPEAKER EMERITUS ANTHONY
RENDON TO PRESENT AB 2202 AB
2202 WOULD REQUIRE THAT SHORT
TERM VACATION RENTALS DISCLOSE
ANY REQUESTED CLEANING
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE TO
CONSUMERS PRIOR TO BOOKING. IT
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THAT ANY FEES
OR PENALTIES CONSUMERS MIGHT
FACE FOR FAILING TO COMPLETE
THESE TASKS BE DISCLOSED IN
ADVANCE. THANKS TO THE GOOD WORK
OF THIS LEGISLATURE, CALIFORNIA
HAS REQUIRED THAT ANY TAXES OR
FEES CONSUMERS MUST PAY AT
VACATION RENTALS BE OUTLINED
DURING THE BOOKING PROCESS. BUT
CLEANING TASKS, MEANING THE
CHORES THAT SHORT TERM VACATION
RENTAL OWNERS ASK GUESTS TO DO
BEFORE THEY CHECK OUT REMAIN
UNCLEAR AND UNREGULATED. THESE
CLEANING DUTIES, WHICH MAY
INCLUDE STRIPPING SHEETS,
STARTING LAUNDRY, OR VACUUMING,
CAN BE ONEROUS AND UNEXPECTED.
THESE CHORES ARE ALSO OFTEN ON
TOP OF SUBSTANTIAL CLEANING
FEES, AND IF YOU EVER LOOK AT
THE CLEANING FEES ARE
ASTRONOMICAL, THAT CONSUMERS PAY
TO STAY AT THESE PROPERTIES.
CALIFORNIA'S DESERVE MORE
CLARITY ABOUT WHAT CHORES THEY
ARE BEING ASKED TO DO DURING
THEIR STAY AT SHORT TERM
VACATION RENTALS. THEY SHOULD
ALSO BE AWARE IN ADVANCE OF WHAT
PENALTIES THEY MIGHT FACE IF
THEY'RE UNABLE TO COMPLETE THESE
TASKS BEFORE THEY LEAVE, AND
HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL IS ROBERT HARRELL,
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SIR.
WELCOME AND YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES, SIR. I WON'T NEED TWO
MINUTES. EVEN BETTER. MR. VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ROBERT
HARRELL, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CONSUMER FOR CALIFORNIA, THE
PINCH HITTING AUTHOR IS BEING
HUMBLE BECAUSE THIS IS ACTUALLY
BUILDING ON HIS BILL. AB 537 OF
LAST YEAR, WHICH CFC SPONSORED.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU, IN
ADDITION TO SOMETIMES OUTRAGEOUS
CLEANING FEES TO STAY AT A VRBO
OR AN AIRBNB, WHICH A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE GETTING FRUSTRATED BY
, THEY ALSO HAVE TO BASICALLY
CLEAN THE PLACE TO A DEGREE THAT
BEGINS TO APPROXIMATE WHAT A
PROFESSIONAL CLEANER WOULD DO.
DOUBLING THAT FRUSTRATION. AND
THIS JUST LETS YOU KNOW UP FRONT
THE TASK THAT YOU NEED TO
ACCOMPLISH. I'VE HEARD I WOULD
NEVER PRETEND TO SPEAK FOR THE
SPEAKER EMERITUS, BUT I'VE HEARD
THE STORY OFTEN ENOUGH. HE AND I
THINK HIS MEMBERS OF HIS FAMILY
HAD A VACATION RENTAL AND FOUND
KIND OF THE DAY THAT THEY WERE
CHECKING OUT THIS MASSIVE BINDER
WITH THESE VERY SPECIFIC
INSTRUCTIONS OF WHAT HAD TO BE
DONE, IN ADDITION TO A SIZABLE
CLEANING FEE THAT THEY ALREADY
HAD TO PAY FOR THE RENTAL. THAT
I THINK EPITOMIZES THE PROBLEM
HERE. PEOPLE SHOULD KNOW UP
FRONT, AND LET'S ALSO AVOID THIS
GAME BETWEEN THE PLATFORM AND
THE INDIVIDUAL HOST ABOUT. NO,
YOU SHOULD TELL THEM NO. YOU
SHOULD TELL THEM THEY BOTH HAVE
RESPONSIBILITY. BUT I THINK
ULTIMATELY THE PLATFORM SHOULD
BE RESPONSIBLE TO MAKE SURE
THAT, YOU KNOW, AS A CONSUMER,
BEFORE YOU GET IN, HERE'S WHAT
I'M GOING TO NEED TO DO. HERE'S
WHAT IT'S GOING TO COST. WE
THINK THAT'S COMMON SENSE
FAIRNESS. AND WE WOULD URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ME.
TWO WITNESSES. OPPOSITION THÀNH.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MR. CHAIR. VICE
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS ALYSSA STINSON. I'M THE
SENIOR GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
MANAGER FOR EXPEDIA GROUP IN
CALIFORNIA. EXPEDIA GROUP IS A
FAMILY OF TRAVEL BRANDS,
INCLUDING EXPEDIA.COM,
HOTELS.COM AND VACATION RENTAL
LEADER VRBO. WE ARE HERE TODAY
TO RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB 2202
UNLESS AMENDED, TO ADDRESS OUR
CONCERNS. WE'VE HAD SEVERAL
POSITIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHOR'S OFFICE OVER THE LAST
FEW MONTHS, BUT HAVE THUS FAR
NOT BEEN ABLE TO REACH A
COMPLETE RESOLUTION. OUR PRIMARY
GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT THERE IS
CLEAR DELINEATION BETWEEN THE
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR HOSTS AND
THOSE OF PLATFORMS, MUCH LIKE
LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT REGULATE
SHORT TERM RENTALS, Dð WE
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO INCREASE
CONSUMER TRANSPARENCY IN THE
BOOKING PROCESS AND
UNDERSTANDING THE CONCERNS FROM
THE AUTHOR REGARDING SHORT TERM
RENTAL CLEANING TASKS AND THE
CHECKOUT PROCESSES. THAT SAID,
THE CLEANING TASKS AND POLICIES,
AND ANY ASSOCIATED FEES FOR
SHORT TERM RENTAL ARE DETERMINED
BY EACH INDIVIDUAL HOST, NOT THE
PLATFORMS. HOSTS DO NOT
UNIVERSALLY PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION TO PLATFORMS, AND
THE CURRENT BILL WOULD MAKE
HOSTS AND PLATFORMS JOINTLY
LIABLE FOR NOT DISCLOSING THE
INFORMATION. IN CLOSING, WE ARE
NOT HERE TO DIMINISH THE ISSUE
THAT SPEAKER EMERITUS
EXPERIENCED WITH HIS FAMILY,
THAT THE COMMITTEE SHOULD HAVE
RECEIVED A LIST OF THE ISSUES
THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
CONSIDERED BY THE AUTHOR BEFORE
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD AND ARE
HAPPY TO DISCUSS THEM. IF,
INTERESTED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
OTHERS. IN OPPOSITION TO AB
2202, MR. CHAIR MEMBERS BEVERLY
YOU, ON BEHALF OF BOOKING
HOLDINGS, WE WOULD ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
EXPEDIA. WE HAVE OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION. LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AUTHOR'S OFFICE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CAMILLE WAGNER
WITH AIRBNB. ALSO,
UNFORTUNATELY, IN AN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION. BUT
LOOKING FORWARD TO RESOLUTION.
THANKS. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NO ONE ELSE APPROACHED THE
MICROPHONE. LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS. SENATOR BARRASSO MOVES
THE BILL. ALL RIGHT. DID WHAT?
Ó. ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BERMAN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ON BEHALF OF SPEAKER EMERITUS
FRIEND, AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE? THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER 33 AB 2202. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMMC UMBERG I
WILK I WILK I ALLEN. ALLEN I
ASHBY. CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
RUSSO. RUSSELL I LAIRD. NILO
NILO I. ROTH. ROTH I STERN.
WAHAB. 7 TO 0 WITH MEMBERS
MISSING. ALL RIGHT, SEVEN ZERO.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
WE HAVE LET'S DO DO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. BUT BUT AFTER THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO,
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WARD WEBER AND
WICKS. OKAY MADAM SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR HAS BEEN MOVED
BY SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. UMBERG I
UMBERG I WILK I WILK I ALLEN
ALLEN I ASHBY CABALLERO. CONSENT
CALENDAR. CABALLERO I DURAZZO.
DURAZZO. I LAIRD. NILO NILO I
ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB. YOU
HAVE 7 TO 0 ON CONSENT. ALL
RIGHT. SEVEN ZERO. WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL. ALL RIGHT. WE'RE
WAITING FOR AUTHORS. AND WHILE
WE'RE WAITING FOR AUTHORS, WHY
DON'T WE GO THROUGH AS BEST WE
CAN THE RULE, THE ROLL, SO,
MADAM SECRETARY, WE'VE GOT LOTS
OF BILLS TO GO OVER, SO WHY
DON'T WE. WHY DON'T WE DO THAT
ONE TIME? OKAY STARTING AT THE
TOP FILE, ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB
1905 NEEDS A MOTION. SO MOVED.
OKAY THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS UMMC I
WILK I WILK I ALLEN ALLEN I
ASHBY CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
RUSSELL RUSSELL I LAIRD. NILO
NILO I ROTH ROTH I STERN. WAHAB
7 TO 0 SEVEN ZERO. PUT THAT ON
CALL FILE ITEM NUMBER 2AB2587.
THE MOTION IS. WE NEED A MOTION.
WE'LL MOVE. OKAY. MOVED BY
SENATOR WILK. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS ON BURKE Ã
UMBERG I WILK I WILK I ALLEN.
ALLEN I ASHBY. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. I
LAIRD. NILO ROTH. ROTH I. STERN
WAHAB. 6 TO 0 SIX ZERO. PUT THAT
ON CALL. THERE'S A MEMBER HERE.
DO YOU WANT ME TO KEEP GOING?
LET'S DO THIS. WE'RE GOING TO.
WHERE ARE WE? FILE ITEM THREE.
FILE ITEM THREE. LET'S TURN TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER, FILE
NUMBER 40, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
, YOU'RE UP.
OH I'M RUNNING FROM HEALTH.
THANK YOU. CHAIR FOR. I BELIEVE
THIS IS AB 1791. GREAT. SO SO
THANK YOU, CHAIR. AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE, I AM HERE TO
PRESENT AB 1791. I WANT TO START
BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND
ITS STAFF FOR THE AMENDMENTS. WE
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
AND ALSO THE VERY THOROUGH
ANALYSIS, THAT YOU ALL PUT OUT
ON THIS BILL WITH OVER 95
MILLION IMAGES UPLOADED TO
INSTAGRAM EVERY DAY, IT IS
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT USERS
CAN DETERMINE WHERE AN IMAGE
ORIGINATED AND IF IT WAS AI
GENERATED. BUT THIS CAN'T HAPPEN
IF SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS REMOVE
ANY DATA FROM AN IMAGE THAT
WOULD TELL USERS DIGITAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE MEDIA,
SUCH AS THE SYSTEM IT WAS
CREATED IN, OR WHEN IT WAS
CREATED. AB 1791 WOULD PROHIBIT
SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS FROM
DELETING CERTAIN DIGITAL
PROVENANCE DATA FROM DIGITAL
CONTENT. THIS BILL DEFINES BOTH
PERSONAL PROVIDENCE DATA AND
SYSTEMS PROVIDENCE DATA, AND
REQUIRES THAT SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES KEEP SYSTEM PROVIDENCE
DATA, BUT DELETE PERSONAL DATA
UNLESS A USER WANTS TO KEEP IT.
IN THE CASE THAT THE SYSTEM AND
PERSONAL PROVIDENCE DATA CANNOT
BE SEPARATED, THIS BILL REQUIRES
A SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANY TO DELETE
BOTH, BUT ATTACH A LABEL
DISCLOSING THE SYSTEM.
PROVIDENCE DATA THAT WAS
DELETED. I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THE THOUGHTFUL PROCESS AND
LOOKING, AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THIS BILL
AS IT CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT. ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? ALL RIGHT,
ANY ME? TWO WITNESSES SEEING?
NO, ME TWO WITNESSES. I SEE
FOLKS THAT ARE ANXIOUS TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SO LET'S
CALL UPON THE OPPOSITION.
APOLOGIES, DILLON HOFFMAN, ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET, WE'RE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB 1791
AS IT'S IN PRINT, ALTHOUGH DO
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION
FOR THE COMMITTEE AND FOR THE
AUTHOR, FOR THE RECENTLY
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS, THAT PUSH
OUT THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE,
THAT ALSO ALLOW USERS TO DECIDE
WHEN THEY WANT TO REMOVE THEIR
PERSONAL INFORMATION FROM
CONTENT PROVENANCE. I THINK
THOSE ARE STRONG CHANGES, WE'RE
STILL A LITTLE CONCERNED, AND
WE'LL CONTINUE TO REVIEW HOW
THIS BILL INTERACTS WITH AB
3211, WHICH IS ALSO BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY, NAMELY THE
REQUIREMENTS IN THAT BILL, ABOUT
HOW A PLATFORM WOULD REMOVE
SYSTEM PROVENANCE DATA AND
PERSONAL PROVENANCE DATA, WHEN
AB 3211 REQUIRES THAT TO BE
MAXIMALLY INDELIBLE OR VERY
DIFFICULT TO REMOVE,
FURTHERMORE, THE TECHNOLOGY TO
REDACT THIS KIND OF INFORMATION
DOESN'T EXIST CURRENTLY. I THINK
OUR COMPANIES ARE WORKING
TOWARDS DOING THAT, BUT TO RE
EMBED IT AT THIS, THAT THIS BILL
REQUIRES AS IT'S BEEN NOTED,
THESE ONLINE PLATFORMS ARE
PROCESSING HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF, OF PIECES OF CONTENT EVERY
SINGLE DAY. SO TO DO THAT
RELIABLY WILL TAKE SOME
ENGINEERING AND TIME. AND RIGHT
NOW I THINK THAT THAT MAY
DETRACT FROM OTHER INVESTMENTS,
THAT ARE, YOU KNOW, GOING
TOWARDS DEVELOPING THE RELIABLE,
TAMPER EVIDENT AND MAXIMALLY
INDELIBLE PROVENANCE TECHNOLOGY
AS REQUIRED BY THIS BILL AND
OTHERS. SO I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT WE'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHERS AS THE BILL
CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD, AND
WE'LL PROVIDE MORE SUBSTANTIVE
FEEDBACK ONCE WE'VE HAD THE
CHANCE TO DO SO. BUT THANK YOU.
MR. CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS, CARL
LONDON HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
RECORDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OF AMERICA, THESE ARE BASICALLY
THE RECORD COMPANIES THAT
PROVIDE THE BULK OF THE MUSIC
THAT WE LISTEN TO THESE DAYS ON
THE PERSONAL DATA INFORMATION
BEING STRIPPED OUT, MUSICIANS,
ARTISTS TYPICALLY WANT THEIR
INFORMATION, INCLUDING
COPYRIGHT, TO BE CLEAR TO THE
PUBLIC SO THAT THEY KNOW IT'S
THEIRS. THE BILL IS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED. DOESN'T APPEAR TO ALLOW
THAT, BUT WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S
AN AMENDMENT. IT WORKS. WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO SEEING WHAT
THAT LOOKS LIKE. A SECOND, AND
THAT LEADS TO THE NEXT POINT.
COPYRIGHT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
PIECE OF DATA FOR US. IF PEOPLE
ARE MISUSING SUCH MATERIALS, THE
ARTIST AND INDUSTRY TYPICALLY
CAN PURSUE A CAUSE OF ACTION.
THAT TYPE OF LEGAL CASE REQUIRES
IDENTIFYING INFORMATION SO WE
CAN FIGURE OUT AGAINST WHOM
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO FILE THE CASE,
THIS BILL THEN MAY WORK AGAINST
FEDERAL LAW IN THAT REGARD,
MAYBE EVEN BE PREEMPTED. IT MAY
BE UNLAWFUL TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION REMOVED. THIRD, FOR
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES, WE LIKE
DATES AND LOCATIONS TO ASSIST
OUR INDUSTRY IN FINDING FROM
WHERE LEAKS COME. MANY OF US
HAVE HEARD EXAMPLES WHERE
RECORDINGS ARE LEAKED PRIOR TO
RELEASE DATES. THAT'S NOT
PREFERABLE, FOURTH, THE BILL MAY
BE INCONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT
OF OTHERS. AS WAS MENTIONED AB
3211 AND AB 2013, WHICH SEEK THE
AIM OF TRANSPARENCY AND TRUTH,
FINALLY, I WOULD SAY THE REMOVAL
OF IDENTIFIERS MAY RUN COUNTER
TO FEDERAL AND STATE LAW FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES. CASES SUCH
AS ELECTION FRAUD, OTHER TYPES
OF FRAUD, CHILD EXPLOITATION.
JUST TO GIVE EXAMPLES, OFTEN
REQUIRE FORENSIC WORK. USING
IDENTIFIERS TO FIND THE
PERPETRATORS WERE PERPLEXED ALSO
BY THE AMENDMENT TO ALLOW A 2020
START DATE. WE THINK IT MIGHT BE
BETTER TO TRY TO PERFECT THIS
BEFORE WE PUT THIS FULLY INTO
LAW. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. LARA. ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE, IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING, LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SEE? YES
SENATOR ASHBY. WELL, FIRST OF
ALL, HOW DID YOU BEAT ME BACK UP
TO THIS GRAND CHAMBER? I WAS OUT
OF BREATH. I REALLY NEED TO STOP
GOING THROUGH THE FRONT WAY AND
START GOING THROUGH THE BACK
WAY, BECAUSE YOU GUYS ARE ALL I
WAS SUPPOSED TO BEAT HIM DOWN TO
YOUR COMMITTEE, TOO. ANYWAY,
GOOD. BILL I JUST WANTED TO ASK
YOU. YOU. I MISSED THE VERY
FIRST PART, BUT YOU TOOK SOME
AMENDS. YES OKAY. AND SO A LOT
OF THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS, WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
RECORDING INDUSTRY AND
COPYRIGHT, WE, YOU KNOW, WE'VE
DEALT WITH THAT WITH THE, WITH
THE AMENDMENTS AS WELL. OKAY.
GREAT. THANKS. THAT WAS MY
QUESTION. APPRECIATE YOU. ALL
RIGHT. OTHER QUESTIONS, SENATOR.
THANK YOU, WOULD YOU BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE CONCERNS
THAT THE CHAMBER HAS BROUGHT UP
IN SOME OF THE OPPOSITION? YEAH
SO I DIDN'T HEAR THE CHAMBER
SPECIFICALLY EXPRESS ANY
CONCERNS. HOWEVER, A LOT OF THE
OPPOSITION HAS BEEN ADDRESSED
WITH THE RECENT AMENDMENTS, AND
SO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO SEE IF THEY HAVE
ANY OTHERS. I BELIEVE THEY SAID
THEY NEEDED MORE TIME TO DIGEST
TO SEE IF THEY STILL HAVE ANY
CONCERNS. BUT THE AMENDMENTS
SPECIFICALLY ADDRESS A LOT OF
THEIR CONCERNS. OKAY. WOULD YOU
BE ABLE TO GO OVER THOSE
AMENDMENTS? SURE. SO, ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS DEALS WITH, LIKE I
SAID, THE RECORDING INDUSTRY,
THERE ARE ISSUES WITH REMOVING
COPYRIGHT AND IT'S EXPLICITLY
STATES IN THE BILL NOW THAT IF
THERE IS A CONFLICT WITH
COPYRIGHT THAT THE LATTER OR THE
COPYRIGHT LAW TAKES PRECEDENT,
AND ALL OF THIS IS ALSO IN THE
ANALYSIS AS WELL, THE OTHER
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
HAVE ADDRESSED HAS TO DO WITH,
WHAT HAPPENS IF DATA CAN'T
PERSONAL DATA VERSUS PROVIDENCE
DATA CANNOT BE, YOU KNOW,
STRIPPED OUT. WE DEALT WITH THAT
IN THE AMENDMENTS. THE OTHER
CONCERN WAS WHAT IF PEOPLE DON'T
WANT THEIR PERSONAL DATA. AND SO
WE HAVE ALSO ALLOWED FOR SOMEONE
TO IN THE BILL TO EXPLICITLY
STATE THAT THEY DON'T WANT THEIR
PERSONAL DATA REMOVED. OKAY AND
CAN YOU EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THAT, ABOUT WHAT IT MEANS
TO HAVE THEIR PERSONAL DATA
REMOVED? SPECIFICALLY? WHAT DO
YOU MEAN? YOU JUST SAID THAT
THAT LAST SENTENCE YOU SAID,
RIGHT. SO IF YOU WANT TO KEEP
THE INFORMATION ABOUT WHO, WHERE
AND WHAT, SO IF YOU'RE OUT IN
CANCUN AND YOU TAKE A PICTURE
AND YOU WANT ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION STILL ON THERE, THEN
YOU WILL BE ABLE TO STATE THAT
YOU DON'T WANT THAT STRIPPED.
OKAY. AND THEN WHAT IF THE
INDIVIDUAL FORGETS THAT THEY'VE
HAD SOMETHING RELEASED OR IT'S
BEEN A VERY LONG TIME OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT. SO THIS IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT WOULD, APPLY
RETROACTIVELY. SO IF YOU HAVE
SOMETHING UP RIGHT NOW, IT'S NOT
LIKE THEY'LL GO BACK AND START
STRIPPING THINGS. SO THIS IS
MEANT PROACTIVELY. SO IF YOU PUT
SOMETHING UP AND YOU DON'T WANT
IT STRIPPED OR YOU, YOU KNOW,
YOU WANT TO MAINTAIN THAT
INFORMATION OUT THERE, THEN YOU
WOULD HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY AT
THAT TIME TO STATE IT. ALL RIGHT
. ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. OTHER
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS, IS THERE
A MOTION? I'LL MOVE IT. SENATOR
ASHBY HAS MOVED THE BILL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER, FOR YOUR PRAGMATIC
APPROACH TO THIS. WE HAVE KICKED
OUT THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE. ONE
OF THE CHALLENGES WITH MANY OF
THESE BILLS IS WHAT IS
TECHNOLOGY ETHICALLY FEASIBLE?
AND WE DON'T ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT
MIGHT BE FEASIBLE IN THE NEXT
FEW YEARS. AND YOUR
ACCOMMODATION RECOGNIZES THAT
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE GREAT
CONFIDENCE IN CALIFORNIA'S
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY, AND COMING
UP WITH THE, WITH THE SOLUTIONS
THAT WILL IMPLEMENT THIS BILL,
BUT IF IT DOESN'T, THEN THAT'S
WHY IT'S KICKED OUT TO 2028. SO
HAVING SAID THAT, THERE'S BEEN A
MOTION BY SENATOR ASHBY, MADAM
SECRETARY. OH, I'M SORRY, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE, JUST, REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR. AYE, VOTE. BUT
ONCE AGAIN, REALLY THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL OF THE
WORK THAT THEY DID ON THIS BILL
AND THE ANALYSIS IS SPOT ON.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 40, AB
1791. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMMC, A NUMBER I
WILK NÓ WILK NÓ ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD.
NILO. NÓ. NILO NO. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE 6
TO 2. SIX. TWO. WE'LL PUT THAT
ON CALL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. OH. YOU GOT ANOTHER
BILL? OKAY YES. GO AHEAD. FILE
ITEM 41 AB 3139. SO GOOD
AFTERNOON, MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 3139, A BILL TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL VEHICLE DATA
PROTECTIONS FOR DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS, CONSUMERS
SPEND A LOT OF TIME INSIDE THEIR
VEHICLES, RUNNING ERRANDS,
COMMUTING TO WORK, OR JUST
TRAVELING. THE CAPABILITIES OF
MODERN VEHICLES HAVE ADVANCED SO
QUICKLY THAT CARS ARE NOW
SOMETIMES REFERRED TO AS
SMARTPHONES ON WHEELS, YET THEIR
INCREASED CONNECTIVITY RAISES
CONCERN ABOUT CONSUMER PRIVACY
BEING COMPROMISED. SUCH SERVICES
GRANT ACCESS TO DRIVER'S DATA
WITH LIMITED CONTROL TO
CONSUMERS AND HOW THEIR DATA MAY
BE USED. THESE PRACTICES POSE
SIGNIFICANT RISK, ESPECIALLY FOR
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
AS PERPETRATORS EXPLOIT APPS TO
REMOTELY TRACK AND CONTROL THEIR
CARS. THIS ENABLES THEM TO
LOCATE SURVIVORS AND MANIPULATE
CAR FUNCTIONS SUCH AS HONKING
THE HORN AND LOCKING THE DOORS.
A RECENT ARTICLE IN THE NEW YORK
TIMES SHED LIGHTS ON THE
STRUGGLES OF CHRISTINE DOWDLE, A
SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE.
IT HIGHLIGHTS THE CHALLENGES SHE
ENCOUNTERED WHILE ATTEMPTING TO
PREVENT HER ABUSER FROM
ACCESSING THE CONNECTED SERVICES
IN HER CAR TO TRACK HER LOCATION
. JUST THIS JANUARY, THE FEDERAL
COMMUNICATIONS COMMISSION
CHAIRWOMAN WROTE TO AN AUTO
MANUFACTURERS AS WELL AS
WIRELESS SERVICE PROVIDERS TO
SEEK THEIR HELP IN PROTECTING
DOMESTIC ABUSE SURVIVORS FROM
THE MISUSE OF CONNECTED CAR
TOOLS BY ABUSERS. SHE WROTE,
QUOTE, NO SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND ABUSE SHOULD HAVE
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN GIVING UP
THEIR CAR AND ALLOWING
THEMSELVES TO BE STALKED AND
HARMED BY THOSE WHO CAN ACCESS
ITS DATA AND CONNECTIVITY FOR
THESE END QUOTE. FOR THESE
REASONS, AB 3139 WILL REQUIRE
THE FOLLOWING. IF
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE, AN
AUTO MANUFACTURER WOULD NEED TO
UPDATE THE TECHNOLOGY IN A
VEHICLE TO INSTALL AN OPTION,
ALLOWING A CONSUMER TO
IMMEDIATELY DISABLE ALL REMOTE
TRACKING TECHNOLOGY. THE METHOD
FOR DISABLING WILL BE REQUIRED
TO BE EASY TO ACCESS AND DISABLE
WITHOUT REQUIRING A PASSWORD OR
LOGIN. ONCE DISABLED, THE
SURVIVOR WILL HAVE SEVEN DAYS TO
SUBMIT THE INFORMATION CURRENTLY
REQUIRED IN THE BILL IN ORDER
FOR THE CONNECTION TO REMAIN
SEVERED. SIMILARLY, THE
REGISTERED CAR OWNER WILL HAVE
SEVEN DAYS TO CONTACT THE AUTO
MANUFACTURER TO HAVE THE
CONNECTION RESTORED. ASSUMING
THE TECHNOLOGY WAS DISABLED FOR
A REASON OTHER THAN TO PROTECT A
SURVIVOR. THE CONNECTION WILL BE
TURNED BACK ON BY THE
MANUFACTURER. IF IT'S NOT
TECHNOLOGICALLY FEASIBLE FOR A
MANUFACTURER TO UPDATE THE
VEHICLE SYSTEM TO ALLOW IT TO BE
DISABLED BY THE CONSUMER ALONE,
THEN THE VICTIM WOULD HAVE TO
SUBMIT A SEPARATE WRITTEN
REQUEST TO THE VEHICLE
MANUFACTURER, INCLUDING THE
PROPER DOCUMENTATION, SUCH AS A
COPY OF A SIGNED AFFIDAVIT FROM
A LICENSED MEDICAL OR MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER, OR A
RESTRAINING ORDER. THE VEHICLE
MANUFACTURER WOULD THEN BE
REQUIRED TO SEPARATE THE
PERPETRATOR'S ACCESS FROM THE
REMOTE VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY. IN
ONE BUSINESS DAY, WE DID NOT
CROSS AMENDMENTS, AT THIS TIME
IN THIS COMMITTEE, BUT WE HAVE
COMMITTED TO TAKING AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL PROVIDE LIABILITY
PROTECTION FOR THE VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS WHEN COMPLYING
WITH THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL. WITH ME HERE TODAY IS
ROBERT HARRELL, EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CONSUMER FEDERATION
OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU. GO
AHEAD, SIR. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ROBERT
HARRELL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CONSUMER FAIR CALIFORNIA. WE'RE
THE SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE,
THE AUTHOR DID AN EXCELLENT JOB
OF DESCRIBING THE, TECHNICAL
ASPECTS OF HOW THIS WOULD WORK.
THIS IS AN APPROACH THAT THE
ASSEMBLY PRIVACY COMMITTEE HAS
BEEN PUTTING IN TO THIS BILL. I
KNOW THAT, SENATOR ASHBY, YOUR
BILL JUST GOT HEARD A COUPLE
HOURS AGO. I WAS IN THAT ROOM.
AND THEN ALSO, SENATOR MINH HAS
A BILL. SO WE'RE TRYING TO MELD
ALL THIS. ALTHOUGH SENATOR
ASHBY, YOUR BILL IS BROADER AND
INCLUDES OTHER SMART DEVICES, IF
YOU WILL, THE ANALYSIS DOES AN
EXCELLENT JOB OF TALKING ABOUT,
TO BE CANDID, SOME OF THE
HORRORS OF WHAT HAS OCCURRED TO
PEOPLE AND, SO WE THINK THAT AS
THIS IS BASED ON BIPARTISAN
FEDERAL LAW SIGNED BY PRESIDENT
BIDEN IN DECEMBER OF 2022 AND
BUILDING ON THAT AS THE FCC, AS
IN THE PROCESS OF IMPLEMENTING
THAT, THEY BEGAN TO ASK, WE
THINK, SOME VERY PERTINENT AND
RELEVANT QUESTIONS ABOUT
VEHICLES. AND SO THIS PICKS UP
ON THAT WORK, WE'RE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. WE THINK
IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO DO IN
THESE HORRIFYING SITUATIONS. AND
SOMETIMES TWO BUSINESS DAYS,
WHICH IS THE FEDERAL LAW
STANDARD IS NOT QUICK ENOUGH.
AND SO WE'D ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. ALL RIGHT. OTHER WITNESSES
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING
IN SUPPORT, IF YOU'RE A METOO
WITNESS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH SEEING NO ONE
OPPOSITION IF YOU'RE OPPOSED TO
AB 3139, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON, MR.
CHAIRMAN. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF SORRY, ON
BEHALF OF SORRY. THERE YOU GO.
ON BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE INNOVATION, THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE AUTOMAKERS,
WE APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPONSORS
AND AUTHORS OF THIS BILL. WE ARE
NOT OPPOSED. WE HAVE CONCERNS.
WE RECOGNIZE OUR ROLE AND
RESPONSIBILITY IN THIS SPACE.
WE'VE JUST GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE TECHNOLOGY IS DESCRIBED
RIGHT, THAT THE DOCUMENTATION IS
RIGHT. WE APPRECIATE THE
COMMITMENT ON THE LIABILITY
PROTECTION. WE LOOK AT THIS AND
GO, YOU KNOW, WE NEED THE
STATUTE TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THE
DOCUMENTS THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
US. THE PROCESS WE NEED TO
FOLLOW. AND WHEN WE AIR AND ON
THE SIDE OF PROTECTING A
SURVIVOR, WE DON'T WANT TO GET
SUED BY SOMEBODY ELSE WHO'S THE
REGISTERED OWNER OF THE CAR. AND
SO WE APPRECIATE ALL THESE
THINGS, APPRECIATE THE ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ON THIS BILL AS
WELL AS SENATOR ASHBY'S BILL. IF
YOU HEAR ANY ANXIETY IN MY
VOICE, IT'S BECAUSE WE ARE NOW
IN THE SECOND HOUSE POLICY
COMMITTEE, AND WE HAVE THREE
BILLS THAT DO THREE DIFFERENT
THINGS, ALL DEALING WITH
AUTOMOBILES. AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO THE ONGOING CONVERSATION TO
HOPEFULLY GET ALL OF THIS
SQUARED AWAY BY THE END OF
SESSION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
MR. MOFFATT. ANYONE ELSE WHO
WISHES TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
WHO'S NOT OPPOSED ALL RIGHT.
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE,
SENATOR ASHBY. YEAH, OBVIOUSLY,
I LIKE THIS BILL. WE HAVE VERY
SIMILAR BILLS, BUT HERS IS
FOCUSED ON VEHICLES, AND MINE IS
BROADER ON ALL OF APS. BUT THE
POINT IS, AND I THINK FOR BOTH
OF US IS YOU THINK ABOUT ALL
THOSE CONVENIENCES THAT THE APS
BRING TO YOUR LIFE, AND NOW
THINK ABOUT ALL THOSE APS IN
CONTROLLED BY SOMEBODY WHO'S
ABUSIVE TO YOU. COME OUT TO SEE
YOUR CAR IN A PARKING LOT AND
IT'S GONE. THEY MOVED IT. THEY
CHANGED THE TEMPERATURE
CONTROLS. THEY CAN SEE YOU
COMING AND GOING ON YOUR RING
DOOR APP ON YOUR TESLA CAMERAS.
EVERYONE WHO'S COMING TO YOUR
CAR. SO IT'S REALLY, REALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE NEED LAW.
WE'RE HERE IN JUDICIARY. WE NEED
LAW TO KEEP UP WITH TECHNOLOGY.
SO I APPRECIATE THE SORT OF SOFT
TOUCH THAT NOT REALLY
OPPOSITION, BUT CONCERNED FOLKS
HAVE WITH OUR BILLS. AND JUST TO
BE CLEAR WITH EVERYONE, BECAUSE
THE THREE BILLS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED, WE ONLY CONTROL TWO
OF THEM. BUT I MADE COMMITMENTS
TODAY TO MIRROR HER LANGUAGE,
WHICH IS SOLID FOR ME AND I
THINK THAT WILL HELP DRAW DOWN
SOME OF THE CONCERN FOR SOME OF
THE AUTO INDUSTRY. SO DON'T HOLD
THAT AGAINST HER. I'M GOING TO
MAKE THOSE CHANGES. WE'LL BE
WILL BE ALIGNED AFTER MY NEXT
COMMITTEE. ALL RIGHTY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OTHER QUESTIONS. IS
THERE A MOTION THE BILL SENATOR
WAHAB MOVES THE BILL. ALL RIGHT.
AND THEN I DO HAVE A QUESTION.
OH, OKAY. GO AHEAD, OPPOSITION
SAID AND IMMEDIATELY EFFECTIVE
MANUAL METHOD OF DISABLING
REMOTE VEHICLE TECHNOLOGY THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO ANY DRIVERS,
ALSO AVAILABLE TO ANY PASSENGER
WHO CAN REACH ACROSS THE CAR, IN
THE SEVEN DAYS, IS THERE A WAY
TO MAKE THAT QUICKER? YEAH YEAH.
NOW I, I COMPLETELY AGREE AND
THAT WAS HONESTLY ONE OF MY
CONCERNS, AND, AND GETTING TO
THE SEVEN DAY HAS BEEN A
NEGOTIATION, BUT WE'LL CONTINUE
TO SPEAK WITH, WITH EVERYONE,
INCLUDING THE SPONSORS AND THE
OPPOSITION, BECAUSE WE DON'T
WANT THIS TECHNOLOGY TURNED OFF
UNLESS WE'RE ACTUALLY DEALING
WITH SOMEONE WHO IS A VICTIM OF,
OF DOMESTIC ABUSE. AND, IF IT IS
READILY AVAILABLE FOR OTHERS AND
YOU DO RUN THAT RISK. AND SO WE
WILL CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION.
AND I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING. OKAY. AND THE
REASON WHY I ASK ALSO IS I'VE
WORKED A LOT IN THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND, MENTAL HEALTH
SPACE AND OFTEN ABUSERS WON'T
TELL THEIR VICTIM, YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE TRACKING OR HOW THEY'RE
TRACKING. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT DO NOT HAVE,
YOU KNOW, AS FRIENDS SAY, TECH
SAVVY, RIGHT? SO THEY DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT IS AVAILABLE. HOW ARE
THEY BEING MONITORED, THE
VEHICLE MAY BE PURCHASED BY THE
ABUSER, AND YET THE DRIVER IS
DRIVING IT WITHOUT REALIZING
WHAT TECHNOLOGY YOU KNOW, IS
THERE, ISN'T THERE? WHAT'S BEING
TRACKED, HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
ACCESS TO IT? HOW MANY APPS? YOU
KNOW, YOU KNOW, LET'S SAY YOU
COULD DELETE IT OFF OF A PHONE,
YOU KNOW, CAN YOU DO THAT OFF OF
A COMPUTER AND SO FORTH, SO I
JUST FEEL LIKE IN THIS SPACE,
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO DO TO,
AND IT'S NOT ALWAYS CLEAR TO THE
VICTIM. AND FOR EXAMPLE, IN
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT,
VICTIMS ARE NOT EVEN AWARE OF
EVEN SOME OF THE, YOU KNOW,
HEALTH IMPACTS WHEN THEY'RE
DEALING WITH AN ABUSER, RIGHT?
OR A CHEATER OR, YOU KNOW,
SOMEBODY'S ABUSIVE IN GENERAL,
SO I THINK THAT WE HAVE A LONG
WAY TO GO. I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS BILL. I
APPRECIATE, SENATOR ASHBY'S
BILL, AND I APPRECIATE THE
MANUFACTURERS, BUT I WOULD ALSO
LIKE FOR MORE WORK TO BE DONE IN
THIS SPACE, RATHER THAN, YOU
KNOW, MAKING IT EASIER OR LONGER
TERM FOR THE PERSON TO SAY THAT
WE'D LIKE THIS OFF. SO, SO, SO
THERE'S TWO THINGS. IF YOU ARE A
VICTIM, YOU CAN IMMEDIATELY TURN
IT OFF RIGHT. SO THE SEVEN DAY
WINDOW WOULD BE FOR THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO SEND IN THE
SUPPORTING DOCUMENTATION. SO IF
YOU'RE A VICTIM, YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WAIT SEVEN DAYS. YOU CAN
IMMEDIATELY TURN IT OFF. IF YOU
HAPPEN IF THE VEHICLE CANNOT DO
IT, IF YOU CANNOT DO IT, OR YOU
HAPPEN TO NOT BE TECH SAVVY TO
FIGURE IT OUT, THEN YOU SEND IN
THE DOCUMENTATION AND THEY HAVE
ONE BUSINESS DAY FROM THE TIME
THEY RECEIVE IT, THE SEVEN DAYS
IS IF IT WAS TURNED, IF SOMEONE
TURNED IT OFF AND IS ACTUALLY
NOT A VICTIM. BUT THE PROBLEM IS
THAT ACCIDENTS DO HAPPEN OR
THINGS LIKE THAT. BUT WHAT I'M,
YOU KNOW, STATING HERE IS THAT
ABUSERS LIE. RIGHT? AND SO EVEN
IF THEY WERE USING IT TO TRACK
OR DO ANYTHING LIKE THAT, YOU
KNOW, DOCUMENTATION TO SAY WAS
AN ACCIDENT OR LIKE WHAT? HOW IS
THAT GOING TO BE LOOKED AT?
RIGHT? SO IT'S NOT DOCUMENTATION
TO SAY THAT THIS PERSON IS
TRACKING ME BECAUSE YOU'D NEVER
KNOW THAT, RIGHT, IS TO TURN IT
OFF AND ON. WELL, NO, IT'S TO
SAY I AM A VICTIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE. I'M AN ABUSE SURVIVOR,
AND I WANT THIS TURNED OFF SO
THAT THIS INDIVIDUAL CANNOT
TRACK ME. RIGHT. IT'S NOT TO SAY
HE OR SHE HAS BEEN DOING IT IS
TO SAY I'VE BEEN ABUSED BY THIS
PERSON, AND I DON'T EVEN WANT TO
GIVE HIM OR HER THAT OPPORTUNITY
, SO EVEN IF THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
OWNS THE VEHICLE IS THE ABUSER,
RIGHT. BUT LET'S SAY THE SPOUSE
OR THE I HATE TO SAY IT LIKE
THIS GIRLFRIEND OR PARTNER IS
THE INDIVIDUAL DRIVING THE
VEHICLE, RIGHT? SO BASICALLY,
EVEN IF THEY DON'T OWN THE
VEHICLE, THEY CAN SUBMIT THIS
AND SAY, I WANT THIS TURNED OFF.
RIGHT? OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO IT
ACTUALLY DOES PROTECT THE ACTUAL
VICTIM SURVIVOR. YEAH. BUT I DO
AGREE THERE NEEDS TO BE A LOT
MORE DONE IN THIS SPACE. AND
HOPEFULLY ONCE WE KIND OF MERGE
AND FIGURE OUT HOW THESE THINGS
WILL WORK, YOU KNOW, IF IT DOES
GET TO BE SIGNED, THERE WILL BE
THE NEED FOR EDUCATION AROUND
IT. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
IT'S BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
WAHAB, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE,
YOU KNOW, PEOPLE WHO ARE VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SHOULD NOT
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THEIR ABUSER
BEING ABLE TO TRACK AND HARASS
THEM THROUGH THEIR CARS. REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK FROM THE
COMMITTEE, REALLY APPRECIATE
SENATOR ASHBY ALSO WORKING IN
THIS SPACE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING, WORKING TOGETHER WITH
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE, ALSO WANT
TO TAKE THE TIME TO THANK THE
CHAIR, BECAUSE I HEARD AT THE
BEGINNING THAT STARTING JULY
2ND, WE WILL BE GOING FROM THE
END OF THE ALPHABET TO THE
BEGINNING, SO WE DON'T HAVE TO
WAIT UNTIL THE VERY END. AND
WITH THAT, RESPECTFULLY ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON AB 3139.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, MADAM
SECRETARY, IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR WAHAB. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
41, AB 3139. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED. THE SENATE
TRANSPORTATION THÀNH UMBERG I
UMBERG I WILK I WILK I ALLEN.
ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I
CABALLERO. DURAZO DURAZO I
LAIRD. NILO. NILO I ROTH. ROTH I
STERN. I STERN I WAHAB. WAHHAB I
. 9 TO 0 NINE ZERO. PUT THAT ON
CALL. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ALSO. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. WE'RE
STILL GOING IN THE OLD. WE'RE
GOING BACK TO THE REGULAR ORDER.
NICE TRY, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WIX
THOUGH. AND ALSO TRY TO KEEP IT
THE JULY 2ND REVERSAL OF ORDER.
TRY TO KEEP IT AWAY FROM THE
FOLKS IN THE FIRST 15 LETTERS OF
THE ALPHABET, BECAUSE I'M GOING
TO BE APPEAR IN FRONT OF THEIR
COMMITTEES. SO. ALL RIGHT,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO? SO MEMBER WIX IS VÆ
1979. NO SORRY. NO, IF IT
PLEASES THE CHAIR, I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH ASSEMBLY BILL 3024.
ALL RIGHT, FILE NUMBER 39. THANK
YOU. I HAVE A, COUNCIL MEMBER
FROM MY DISTRICT WHO HAS A
FLIGHT TO MAKE, SO I APPRECIATE
IT. AND I ALSO HAVE, INSTITUTED
A REVERSE ALPHABETICAL ORDER IN
OUR COMMITTEE. SO APOLOGIES TO
SENATOR ASHBY, BUT, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE SOME OF ONE
AND SOME OF THE OTHER. GREAT TO
BE WITH YOU HERE TODAY. THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE ABLE
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 3024. I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
THE STAFF FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON
THE BILL AND STATE. I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
AMENDMENTS ACCORDING TO THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE, LAST
YEAR SAW A 38% RISE IN HATE
MOTIVATED PROPAGANDA EFFORTS,
INCLUDING HATE LITTERING IN THE
FORM OF RACIST, ANTI-SEMITIC AND
ANTI LGBTQ FLIERS PLACED
DIRECTLY ON A VICTIM'S PERSONAL
PROPERTY WITH THE INTENT TO MAKE
THEM FEAR FOR THEIR SAFETY. THIS
IS RAPIDLY BECOME THE PREFERRED
TACTIC BY HATE GROUPS BECAUSE IT
IS EFFECTIVE, IT ALLOWS FOR
INCREASED PERSONAL IMPACT AND
EXISTS IN A LEGAL GRAY AREA,
MAKING IT EXTREMELY HARD FOR LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO PROSECUTE. AS A
STATE, WE MUST RECOGNIZE THAT
THESE MATERIALS ARE NOT JUST
PIECES OF PAPER OR EXPRESSIONS
OF FREE SPEECH. THEY ARE DIRECT
THREATS PLACED ON THE PERSONAL
PROPERTY OF TARGETED COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND THEIR NEIGHBORS WITH
THE INTENT TO HARASS,
INTIMIDATE, AND DEHUMANIZE THEM.
AB 3024 THE STOP HATE LITTERING
ACT WILL MAKE NECESSARY
IMPROVEMENTS TO EXISTING LAW BY
STRENGTHENING THE RALPH CIVIL
RIGHTS ACT OF 1976 TO ENSURE
THAT VICTIMS ARE PROVIDED
ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS AGAINST
HATE LITTERING, AND CREATES NEW
LEGAL TOOLS TO HOLD OFFENDERS
ACCOUNTABLE. HATE ACTS HAVE NO
PLACE IN OUR COMMUNITIES, AND WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
TO ENSURE CALIFORNIANS ARE FREE
FROM HATE RELATED VIOLENCE IN
ALL OF ITS FORMS. WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
COME ON UP. IS OUR CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER FROM THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO, RAUL CAMPILLO AND CLIFF
BERG, ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE PARTY.
THANK YOU. FLOOR IS YOURS. GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR UMBERG
ONORABLE, COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE. MY NAME
IS RAUL CAMPILLO. I'M THE SAN
DIEGO CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
REPRESENTING DISTRICT SEVEN AND
CO-SPONSOR OF ASSEMBLY BILL
3024, THE STOP HATE LITTERING
ACT. I SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND I
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD FOR
HIS CHAMPIONING OF THIS ISSUE.
HATE LITTERING HAS BECOME THE
PREFERRED TACTIC TO MAXIMIZE
PERSONAL IMPACT AND FEAR, WHILE
ALSO ALLOWING PERPETRATORS TO
REMAIN ANONYMOUS. SINCE JUNE OF
2023, WE HAVE SEEN A HUGE SURGE
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY IN THE
DISTRIBUTION OF THREATENING
FLIERS AND IT'S ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA, BUT PARTICULARLY IN
SAN DIEGO AND MANY OF THE
NEIGHBORHOODS I REPRESENT,
INCLUDING DEL CERRO AND SAN
CARLOS, NEIGHBORING CITY OF LA
MESA, AND MANY OTHERS. I WANT TO
BE CLEAR, THESE ARE NOT JUST
PIECES OF PAPER. THESE FLIERS
ARE THREATS PLACED ON THE HOMES
OF THE CARS, THE DOOR, THE
DOORSTEPS, THE DRIVEWAYS AND
CARS OF IN MINORITY COMMUNITIES
WITH THE INTENTION TO INTIMIDATE
AND THREATEN AND SOW FEAR. AND
THEY HAVE DONE SO AS A
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVE. I
HAVE FAMILIES AND NEIGHBORS WHO
COME TO ME ASKING ME WHAT THEY
SHOULD DO, AND THE ONLY LEGAL
ADVICE I COULD PROVIDE THEM WAS
TO KEEP AND TAKE PHOTOS OF THOSE
FLIERS, PROVIDE THEM TO POLICE,
LOOK AT THEIR RING CAMERA VIDEOS
IN THE CLOUD, AND SEND THAT
INFORMATION TO POLICE IN HOPES
OF CATCHING THAT INDIVIDUAL IN
SOME OTHER CRIME. BUT AB 324 WAS
CREATED OUT OF A BELIEF THAT
THIS GOVERNMENT MUST DO
EVERYTHING IN ITS POWER TO
PROTECT EVERYONE, EVERY NEIGHBOR
AND EVERY STRANGER FROM THIS
TYPE OF INTIMIDATION AND THREATS
. AND OF COURSE, IT'S OUR FIRST
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND WELL-BEING
OF OUR CITIZENS. AND AB 1324
WILL DO JUST THAT. WE'LL PROTECT
ALL CALIFORNIANS, ESPECIALLY
THOSE WHO ARE THE TARGETS OF
THESE ACTS. AND IT'S MY
SINCEREST HOPE THAT AB 1324
CREATES DETERRENCE AND THEREFORE
PROTECTS ALL COMMUNITIES FROM
HAVING TO DEAL WITH HATE
LITTERING. BUT IN THE INSTANCE
WHERE THERE IS NOT DETERRENCE OR
INDIVIDUALS ARE IDENTIFIED AND
BROUGHT TO COURT, THERE CAN BE A
MEANINGFUL MEASURE OF JUSTICE.
THANK YOU, ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD,
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND
YOUR ENTIRE STAFF, AND FOR
DETERMINING THE BEST LEGAL ROUTE
TO ENSURE THAT VICTIMS OF THESE
ACTS ARE PROVIDED WITH LEGAL
RECOURSE. THEY DESERVE. THE
APPROVAL OF THIS ITEM WOULD
AFFIRM THE CALIFORNIA SENATE'S
COMMITMENT TO THE WELL-BEING AND
SAFETY OF OUR CONSTITUENTS BY
TAKING IMMEDIATE ACTION AND
PROTECTING THE CIVIL LIBERTIES,
AND ENACTING PROACTIVE MEASURES
THAT SAFEGUARD VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU, COUNCILMAN,
EXACTLY ON TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. CLIFF BURG HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI-DEFAMATION
LEAGUE, ADL AS AN ORGANIZATIONAL
CO-SPONSOR, WE ARE HAPPY TO BE
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
3024. FOUNDED IN 1913, IN
RESPONSE TO AN ESCALATING
CLIMATE OF ANTI-SEMITISM AND
BIGOTRY, ADL HAS NOW BECOME A
LEADING NATIONAL ANTI-HATE
ORGANIZATION. OUR WORK IS NEEDED
MORE THAN EVER TODAY, AS WE HAVE
SEEN A PRECIPITOUS RISE IN HATE
ACROSS THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ACCORDING TO THE ADL CENTER ON
EXTREMISM, THE ORGANIZATION
TRACKED A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN WHITE SUPREMACIST PROPAGANDA
EFFORTS IN 2023, WHICH INCLUDED
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THREATENING
RACIST, ANTI-SEMITIC AND
ANTI-LGBTQ MESSAGES. THIS STUDY
FOUND THAT ANTI-SEMITIC
PROPAGANDA INCREASED BY 30% IN
2023 ACROSS THE COUNTRY, MUCH OF
WHICH OCCURRED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA LAST YEAR. FLIERS
WITH HORRIFIC ANTI-SEMITIC AND
ANTI-LGBTQ MESSAGES WERE
DISTRIBUTED IN THE DARK OF
NIGHT, ATTACKING NOT ONLY THE
VALUES THAT WE HOLD AS A
COMMUNITY, BUT THREATENING THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE IN IT. WE
MUST DO ALL THAT WE CAN TO SPEAK
OUT AGAINST THIS EXTREMIST
ACTIVITY AND CONDUCT, CONDUCT
THAT SEEKS TO HAVE OUR
COMMUNITIES LIVE IN FEAR OF HATE
AND POTENTIAL VIOLENCE. AB 3024
WILL MAKE NECESSARY IMPROVEMENTS
TO EXISTING LAW BY STRENGTHENING
THE RALPH CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF
1976 TO ENSURE VICTIMS ARE
PROVIDED ADEQUATE PROTECTIONS
AGAINST THESE NEW TACTICS. WHILE
CREATING NEW LEGAL TOOLS TO
DETER TERRORIZING ACTIVITY AND
HOLD OFFENDERS ACCOUNTABLE. WE
ARE ONCE AGAIN GRATEFUL TO WORK
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD TO
ENSURE THAT OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
WELCOMING AND SAFE PLACE FOR
EVERYONE. THANK YOU. HERE ALSO
TODAY, ON BEHALF OF JPAC, THE
JEWISH PUBLIC AFFAIRS COMMITTEE
REPRESENTING OVER 30 JEWISH
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF MR.
WARD'S BILL. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. THANK YOU, MR. BURG. ALL
RIGHT. OTHERS IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE, NAME,
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS,
MOIRA TOPP HERE ON BEHALF OF SAN
DIEGO MAYOR TODD GLORIA. SAN
DIEGO'S HERE IN FORCE TODAY.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
SUPPORT THIS AFTERNOON. THANK
YOU. HI. JUSTIN BOWERS, CLEAN
EARTH FOR KIDS ORG STRONGLY
SUPPORT. IN ADDITION NORTH
COUNTY EQUITY AND JUSTICE FACTS
ECO SUSTAINABILITY PEACE AND CA
AND ACTIVIST SAN DIEGO ALSO
STRONGLY SUPPORT. THANK YOU
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE. OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION TO THE AB
3024, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. GOOD AFTERNOON,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY
NAME IS CYNTHIA VALENCIA. I AM A
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE WITH THE
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION, WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AND AUTHOR FOR WORKING ON
AMENDMENTS TO NARROW THE BILL
AND ADDRESS THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONCERNS WE RAISED. WHILE WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S LAUDABLE
GOAL TO ADDRESS THE INCIDENCE
THAT THE BILL TARGETS, WE ARE
SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION ON THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF OUR CONTINUED
CONCERNS WITH FORESEEABLE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
UTILIZING SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
CIVIL PENALTIES TO PUNISH PEOPLE
FOR THEIR SPEECH. WE ARE ALSO
CONCERNED WITH THE DEFINITIONS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE
BEING APPLIED TO THE INCIDENTS
IN THIS BILL, AND BEING USED IN
THE CALIFORNIA CIVIL CODE. AB
3024 WILL EXPAND DEFINITION OF
INTIMIDATION BY THREAT OF
VIOLENCE, WHICH IS USED IN THE
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE, SECTION
11 411. TERRORIZING THE OWNER OR
RESIDENT OF A PRIVATE PROPERTY
WITH THE DISTRIBUTION OF
MATERIALS. SO THE PENAL CODE
THAT IS BEING REFERENCED, WITH
INTIMIDATION BY THREAT OF
VIOLENCE THAT IS BEING USED,
WHAT THAT IS REFERENCING IS
PLACING SWASTIKAS, BURNING
CROSSES OR HANGING NOOSES ON
SOMEONE'S PRIVATE PROPERTY. IT
IS WELL SETTLED THAT TRUE
THREATS ARE NOT PROTECTED BY THE
FIRST AMENDMENT. BURNING A CROSS
ON SOMEONE'S PROPERTY. PRIVATE
PROPERTY FITS WITHIN THAT TRUE
THREAT, EXCEPTION OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT, BECAUSE THIS ACTION
SENDS AN UNMISTAKABLE MESSAGE OF
IMPENDING VIOLENCE DIRECTED AT
THAT PROPERTY OWNER, AB 3024
USES THE USES TERRORIZE FOR THE
ACT OF PLACING A FLIER ON
SOMEONE'S CAR WINDSHIELD, OR ON
SOMEONE'S DOORSTEP, EVEN IF THE
FLIER CONTAINS LANGUAGE THAT IS
EXTREMELY HATEFUL, THAT ACT
TYPICALLY DOES NOT CARRY THE
SAME TYPE OF HISTORICAL
SYMBOLISM, OR INSTILL FEAR THAT
BURNING A CROSS ON SOMEONE'S
PROPERTY. THE GOVERNMENT MAY NOT
ONLY PROHIBIT SUCH FLIERS THAT
COMMUNICATE A TRUE THREAT AS A
AS OBJECTIONABLE AS IT IS, THEY
ARE PROTECTED BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT. THIS BILL INVITES
DISCRIMINATORY CIVIL ACTIONS TO
BE WIELDED AS A TOOL TO PUNISH
THOSE THAT DISTRIBUTE MATERIALS
THAT EXPRESS DISFAVORED VIEWS OR
VIEWS THAT PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS DISAGREE WITH, YET DO NOT
TARGET OR INTEND TO PLACE ANY
INDIVIDUAL FEAR FOR FEAR OF
BODILY HARM. FOR THESE REASONS,
WE ASK THAT YOU VOTE NO ON AB
3024. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU. ANYBODY ELSE IN THE
ROOM IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL,
SEEING NONE PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS,
CONCERNS. I HAVE A QUESTION ALL
THE WAY DOWN THERE AT THE END,
SENATOR OSO, THANK YOU. QUESTION
TO THE AUTHOR. IF YOU COULD
RESPOND TO THE ACLU'S, ISSUES, I
KNOW THAT YOU CARE VERY MUCH
ABOUT OUR CIVIL RIGHTS, BUT HOW
DO YOU RESPOND TO THEIR
OBJECTION? OF COURSE. SO, THE
BILL IS, YOU KNOW, YOU CAN SEE
FOR YOURSELF IS SILENT AS FAR AS
THE CONTENT OF THE SPEECH AND
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO REALLY
MAKE SURE WE'RE REFLECTING UNDER
THE RALPH CIVIL RIGHTS ACT IS
THE ACTION HERE. IT'S THE
CONDUCT WHICH WE CAN, BE ALLOWED
TO BE THE SUBJECT OF THE WORK
THAT WE'RE DOING HERE. YOU NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT IF A CIVIL IF
IN THESE SITUATIONS THAT WE ARE
SEEING GROWING OUT IN OUR
COMMUNITY, YOU WERE HAVING AREAS
THAT MIGHT HAVE HIGHER THAN
USUAL DENSITIES OF JEWISH
HOUSEHOLDS, HIGHER THAN USUAL
DENSITIES OF LGBT HOUSEHOLDS,
PARTICULARLY FIRED OR THREATENED
, WITH THE INTIMIDATION THAT
THAT THAT COMES WITH THE FIRING
THAT IS GOING ON THEIR PERSONAL
PROPERTY. AND SO IF YOU CAN HAVE
OBJECTIVE AND SUBJECTIVE,
ASSURANCE, THAT AN INDIVIDUAL IS
FEELING THREATENED REGARDLESS OF
SOME OF THE CONTENT, THIS IS NOT
A NEW, PENALTY. THIS IS AN
EXISTING PENALTY THAT WE ARE
TRYING TO CLARIFY UNDER THE
RALPH CIVIL RIGHTS ACT. WOULD
ALSO BE AVAILABLE WHEN THE
CONDITIONS ARE MET, AS, AND
DURING AN ACTION OF HATE
LITTERING AS WE'RE DEFINING. SO
THAT'S A DISTINCTION. IT'S NOT
THE CONTENT, IT'S NOT THE
SPEECH. IT IS THE ACT OF WHAT
SOMEBODY IS DOING AND THE
PATTERN OF WHAT THEY ARE DOING
UPON THE POPULATION IN WHICH
THEY'RE DOING IT. RIGHT. EXCEPT
THAT THE CONDUCT IS PUTTING THE
LEAFLET ON THE CAR OR THE
LEAFLET IN THE DRIVEWAY, OR IS
THAT WHAT IS ON SOMEBODY'S
PERSONAL PROPERTY, JUST LIKE WE
HAD PAST? AND I WILL MAKE
REFERENCE TO ACTUALLY AGREEING
WITH THE OPPOSITION. THERE WORK
THAT, YOU KNOW, WAS TRYING TO
DISPLAY A SWASTIKA, A BURNING
CROSS, SOMETHING ELSE THAT WAS A
SYMBOL OF HATE, WE BELIEVE THAT
THIS ALSO RISES TO THAT LEVEL OF
THREAT BECAUSE WHAT THESE FLIERS
DO IS IT TELLS THE INHABITANTS
OR THE OWNER OF THAT PROPERTY
THAT WE KNOW WHERE YOU LIVE, WE
KNOW WHO'S IN THIS NEIGHBORHOOD,
AND WE ARE HERE AND WE ARE IN
YOUR FACE, AND YOU SHOULD FEEL
THREATENED BY US. YEAH, I, I DO
STILL HAVE A, A QUESTION ABOUT
THAT. I WILL SUPPORT TODAY, BUT
I'M THERE'S A LEVEL OF
DISCOMFORT YOU KNOW, AND NOT
BECAUSE I SUPPORT THE CONTENT OF
HATE, WHICH ALTOGETHER COULD
MAYBE COULD LEAD TO FEELING
SOMEONE FEELING THREATENED, IT'S
JUST, YOU KNOW, IN OUR HISTORY,
IN THIS COUNTRY, THE USES OF OUR
CIVIL RIGHTS HAVE BEEN ABUSED BY
PEOPLE. AND SO YOU JUST WANT TO
WATCH OUT FOR THAT, I GUESS, IS
MY CONCERN. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
AND I'D ADD TO AGAIN, I THINK
BECAUSE OF THE, REFERENCE THAT
WE HAVE HERE, NOT BECAUSE, I
PARTICULARLY WANTED TO REACH
INTO THE PENAL CODE, BUT BECAUSE
THERE WAS AN APT DEFINITION
THERE THAT YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE IS THE INTENT TO
TERRORIZE. AND SO IF A CIVIL
LOCAL PROSECUTOR IS ABLE TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THAT IS AND
PROVE THAT THAT IS MADE, THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO ASSESS A CIVIL
PENALTY. ALL RIGHT. VERY GOOD.
SENATOR ASHBY. YEAH, I JUST
WANTED TO SAY A COUPLE OF
THINGS. FIRST OF ALL, I
APPRECIATE THE CONTENT
NEUTRALITY OF YOUR APPROACH AND
THE OBVIOUS. LEAN IN TO TIME,
PLACE AND MANNER APPROPRIATELY
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF BOTH
LOCAL GOVERNANCE AND, OF COURSE,
THE STATE AND, AND ALSO THE
INTENT COMPONENT THAT YOU HAVE
INCLUDED. SO I THINK THAT'S NICE
WORK. I ALSO WANTED TO JUST SAY
MY APPRECIATION TO THE COUNCIL
MEMBER FOR COMING UP. MANY OF US
SERVED ON CITY COUNCILS BEFORE
BEING HERE, AND I HAD VERY
SIMILAR THINGS HAPPEN. MINE WAS
TARGETING LGBTQ COMMUNITY
MEMBERS. I'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE IN THIS, COMMITTEE, YOU
KNOW, A WHOLE GROUP OF LGBTQ
LEADERS GREW OUT OF THAT
HORRIBLE INCIDENT AND ENDED UP
STARTING A LOT OF GREAT THINGS
HAPPENING IN THE COMMUNITY. BUT
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY. AND
PEOPLE OUGHT TO BE SAFE IN THEIR
HOMES AND IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS
AND IN THEIR COMMUNITIES FROM
THIS KIND OF ACTION, OVERT
ACTION OF HATE. AND I DON'T
THINK IT'S ASKING TOO MUCH FOR
US TO TAKE A POSITION TO DO SO
TO PROTECT THEM AND TO GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNANCE THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE TO PROTECT THEIR
NEIGHBORS. SO THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THE TRIP. THANK YOU. AM I
GOING TO TAKE THAT AS A MOTION?
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS? IF NOT, YOU MAY CLOSE.
WELL THANK YOU SENATORS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TO CONSIDER
THIS BILL AS WE ARE SEEING ACTS
OF HATE ON THE RISE IN MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES. WE'RE TRYING TO
THINK ABOUT NEW TOOLS TO BE ABLE
TO RESPOND TO THAT. AND WORKING
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT, WHO
HAS BEEN A LITTLE BIT STUCK ON
ON HOW TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THESE, YOU KNOW,
EVOLVING ACTIONS THAT THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE TAKING TO INCITE
HATE, INCITE TERROR INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES. I APPRECIATE A LOT
OF INDIVIDUALS THAT PUT SOME
SMART THOUGHT IN TO BE ABLE TO
HOW TO ADDRESS THIS USING AN
OFFSHOOT OF EXISTING LAW, SO
WITH THAT, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. ALL RIGHT. LET'S CALL THE
ROLL. ALL RIGHT. THIS IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER 39. AB 3024 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED. BURG WILK
NÓ WILK NÓ. ALLEN ALLEN I ASHBY.
ASHBY. I CABALLERO. DURAZO.
DURAZO I LAIRD. NILO. NÓ. NILO
NÓ. ROTH. ROTH I STERN, STERN I
WAHAB. 5 TO 2. SO FOUR MEMBERS
MISSING. ALL RIGHT. AND WE'LL
LEAVE THAT. AND WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN. THANK YOU, SENATOR
MEMBERS, TO ADD ON. AND NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM 38 AB
1979.
THANK YOU. SENATORS. I'M ALSO
HERE TO PRESENT AB 1979, THE
DOXING VICTIMS RECOURSE ACT. THE
BILL PROVIDES RELIEF AND SUPPORT
FOR VICTIMS WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED
AS A RESULT OF BEING DOXED BY
ALLOWING THEM TO PURSUE CIVIL
RESTITUTION FOR THE HARMS THEY
ENDURED. DOXING IS A HARASSMENT
TACTIC THAT OCCURS WHEN A PERSON
RELEASES ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL'S
PRIVATE, PERSONALLY IDENTIFYING
INFORMATION WITHOUT THEIR
CONSENT, WITH THE INTENT TO
CAUSE THAT PERSON HARM. WHILE
DOXING IS ALREADY A CRIME UNDER
CALIFORNIA PENAL CODE,
PROTECTIONS AND RECOURSE ARE
ABSENT IN THE CIVIL CODE, THIS
BILL WILL CORRECT THIS ABSENCE
OF SUPPORT BY PROVIDING A
DOXXING VICTIM AN AVENUE TO BE
MADE WHOLE VIA RESTITUTION FOR
THE HARMS THEY ENDURED, AS WELL
AS PROVIDE ANOTHER AVENUE TO
DETER PERPETRATORS FROM
CONTINUING TO ORGANIZE ONLINE
HARASSMENT CAMPAIGNS AGAINST
THEIR VICTIMS. WITH HATE BASED
THREATS AND ATTACKS INCREASING
AND EVOLVING ALONGSIDE ADVANCES
IN TECHNOLOGY, SUCH AS THROUGH
THE EMERGENCE OF NEW SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS, THE RISK OF
MALICIOUS ACTS SUCH AS DOXING
ARE HEIGHTENED. AB 1979 PROVIDES
A DOXING VICTIM AN AVENUE TO BE
MADE WHOLE VIA RESTITUTION FOR
THE HARMS THEY ENDURED DUE TO
THE ACTIONS OF THE OFFENDER.
WHILE THUS ALLOWING THE VICTIMS
TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK ON TRACK
WITH ME TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF
THIS BILL ARE OUR CO-SPONSORS,
CLIFF BERG, ON BEHALF OF THE
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE, AND
JONATHAN CLAY, ON BEHALF OF
TRANS FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES
AND TRANS YOUTH LIBERATION. ALL
RIGHT, MR. BERG, YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIRMAN. CLIFF BERG HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ADL,
ANTI-DEFAMATION LEAGUE. AS WE
KNOW, OUR STATE LAWS HAVE NOT
KEPT UP WITH THE HATE AND
HARASSMENT THAT USERS EXPERIENCE
ONLINE. THE CONSEQUENCES FOR
SUCH OFFENSES MUST TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION THE SERIOUS AND
LASTING EFFECTS OF ONLINE HATE
AND HARASSMENT. ONE OF THE MOST
COMMON TACTICS OF ONLINE
HARASSMENT IS DOXING, MEANING
PUBLICLY SHARING AN INDIVIDUAL'S
PERSONAL INFORMATION WITH THE
INTENT THAT THE INFORMATION BE
USED AGAINST THE TARGET FOR
UNLAWFUL PURPOSES. THE GROWTH OF
ONLINE HATE AND HARASSMENT
TARGETING MARGINALIZED GROUPS IS
A GROWING TREND THAT DESERVES
ACTION BY POLICYMAKERS,
ACCORDING TO A 2024 ADL REPORT
ON ONLINE HATE AND HARASSMENT,
22% OF AMERICANS HAVE
EXPERIENCED SEVERE HARASSMENT
ONLINE IN THE PAST 12 MONTHS OF
INDIVIDUALS SURVEYED WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED ANY TYPE OF ONLINE
HATE, TRANSGENDER PEOPLE WERE
MOST LIKELY TO BE HARASSED IN
THE PAST 12 MONTHS FOR THEIR
GENDER IDENTITY. LGBTQ PEOPLE
FOR THEIR PHYSICAL APPEARANCE,
BLACK AFRICAN AMERICAN AND ASIAN
AMERICANS FOR THEIR RACE AND
ETHNICITY, AND MUSLIMS FOR THEIR
RELIGION. THESE ARE NOT JUST
NUMBERS, BUT REAL PEOPLE WHO ARE
TARGETED EVERY DAY. CALIFORNIA
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
STRONG, CONCRETE ACTION IN
ADDRESSING THE RISING THREAT OF
DOXING BY PASSING AB 1979,
DOXING MUST BE CODIFIED INTO
CALIFORNIA STATE LAW SO WE CAN
PROTECT TARGETS AND HOLD
PERPETRATORS ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR MALICIOUS AND RECKLESS
ACTIONS. THIS BILL IS A GOOD
FIRST STEP IN ADDRESSING ONLINE
HATE AND PROTECTING MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES, BRINGING FORWARD
LANGUAGE THAT ENSURES THAT THE
BILL WOULD NOT ONLY ADDRESS THE
THREAT OF DOXING, BUT ALSO
PROTECTS FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND LOOK FORWARD TO ANY
QUESTIONS HERE. ALSO, ON BEHALF
OF JPAC, THE JEWISH PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE, 30 MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS AND SUPPORT OF
THIS LEGISLATION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR. WELCOME. TWO
MINUTES. BREAKING UP THERE, I'LL
TRY TO KEEP IT UNDER THAT, GOOD
AFTERNOON, CHAIR MEMBERS. JOHN
WILL STAY HERE ON BEHALF OF
TRANS FAMILY SUPPORT SERVICES
AND TRANS YOUTH LIBERATION.
PROUD TO BE CO-SPONSOR THE BILL.
AS HIGHLIGHTED BY THE AUTHOR,
A.B. 1979, WHICH WOULD CREATE A
CIVIL PATHWAY FOR SEEKING
REMEDIES TO CASES OF DOXING AND
ATTEMPT TO PUT A FRAMEWORK IN
PLACE THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
DISINCENTIVIZE FUTURE DOXING
CASES. SITTING BEFORE YOU TODAY,
YOU'LL SEE MANY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT REPRESENT MARGINALIZED
GROUPS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
DOXING EVENTS, AS HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE BILL ANALYSIS. YET AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS, YOU KNOW, THE
DOCTRINE CAN OCCUR TO ANYONE,
INCLUDING ELECTED OFFICIALS,
THEIR STAFFS, FAMILIES AND
SOMEONE HAD THEY DID. LET'S TRY
THAT. HOW OLD DOES THE BOND ROLE
DO THAT? WORKING IT'S NOT
SPEAKER. IT'S NOT PROJECTING.
SURE THE CHAIR IS NOT HERE, SO
I'M JUST TAKING FOCUS. THE
PROBLEMS OF BEING TALL WITH A
LOW MIC, IT MAKES. OKAY. IS THIS
WORKING NOW? THERE. THERE WE GO.
NO, I MEAN, IF YOU GUYS COULD
HEAR WHAT I WAS SAYING. DON'T
NEED TO. OKAY. ALL RIGHT, TAKE
TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON. CHAIR.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. JOHN CLAY
HERE ON BEHALF OF TRANS FAMILY
SUPPORT SERVICES AND TRANS YOUTH
LIBERATION, PROUD CO-SPONSORS OF
AB 1979. AS HIGHLIGHTED BY THE
AUTHOR, AB 1979 WOULD CREATE A
CIVIL PATHWAY FOR SEEKING
REMEDIES TO CASES OF DOXING AND
ATTEMPTS TO PUT A FRAMEWORK IN
PLACE THAT WILL HOPEFULLY
DISINCENTIVIZE FUTURE DOXING
CASES. SITTING BEFORE YOU TODAY,
YOU WILL SEE MANY ORGANIZATIONS
THAT REPRESENT MARGINALIZED
GROUPS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
DOXING EVENTS, AS HIGHLIGHTED IN
THE BILL ANALYSIS. YET, AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS, YOU ALSO KNOW
THAT DOXING CAN OCCUR TO ANYONE,
INCLUDING ELECTED OFFICIALS,
THEIR STAFFS, FAMILIES. WHEN
SOMEONE EJECTS TO A POSITION OR
STATEMENT. I MYSELF HAVE HAD TO
TAKE PRECAUTIONS TO PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF MY FAMILY. WHEN I'VE
WORKED ON CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE, THIS
SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE, BUT IT'S
UNFORTUNATELY THE STATE OF
AFFAIRS THAT WE ALL EXIST IN
CURRENT LAW, ALREADY ESTABLISHED
A MISDEMEANOR FOR DOXING AN AB
1979 DOES NOT MODIFY EXISTING
RIGHTS, IMMUNITIES OR REMEDIES
THAT CURRENT LAW PROVIDES. THESE
DOXING CASES CAN BE AS TRAUMATIC
AS A PHYSICAL ASSAULT, YET
GETTING CRIMINAL PROSECUTION IS
DIFFICULT. THE LEGISLATURE IS
AWARE OF HOW IMPACTED LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ARE, AND WORKLOADS AND
PROSECUTING ALL MISDEMEANORS IS
NOT A POSSIBILITY. AB 1979
CREATES A PRIVATE RIGHT OF
ACTION SO THAT THESE CASES CAN
BE PURSUED THROUGH THE CIVIL
PROCESSES, BEING ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY PURSUE RELIEF
THROUGH THE COURTS IS KEY TO
HELPING DISSUADE PEOPLE FROM
DOXING OTHERS. FINALLY, IN
REPRESENTING ENTITIES THAT
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF TRANS
YOUTH AND THEIR FAMILIES, WE SEE
FIRSTHAND HOW IMPACTFUL THESE
DOXING CASES CAN BE ON YOUTH AND
THEIR FAMILIES. OUR OWN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS HAD TO DEAL
WITH DOXING AND THE IMPACTS OF
OUR OWN FAMILY. AB 1979 PROVIDES
THE NECESSARY TOOLS FOR PEOPLE
IMPACTED BY DOXING TO BE ABLE TO
PROACTIVELY TAKE THEIR LIVES
BACK AND SEEK JUSTICE ON THOSE
WHO HAVE INVASIVELY SOUGHT TO
DISRUPT THEIR LIVES. ASK FOR
YOUR I VOTE, AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GREAT. THANK YOU. ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT?
WHAT? WE'RE JUST. I GOT IT, I
GUESS ME TWO WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
DO HERE TO GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON, VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, ROSS BUCKLEY, ON BEHALF
OF THE SACRAMENTO CITY MAYOR
DARRELL STEINBERG, IN SUPPORT,
SIR. AND CRAIG PULSIPHER ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SIR. OKAY.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE ANY ANYONE
HERE IN OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE.
LET'S PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. QUESTIONS, COMMENTS?
ANY CONCERNS? IF NONE. LOVE TO
HAVE SOME. SENATOR ALLEN, THANK
YOU. SO SENATOR ALLEN MADE THE
MOTION. ASSEMBLYMAN, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU. SENATORS, I
KNOW THE HEARING HAS BEEN LONG
TODAY, BUT APPRECIATE YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS. DOXING IS A
SEVERE CRIME THAT IS ALREADY
DEFINED IN THE CRIMINAL CODE,
BUT THERE IS NO ABILITY FOR
VICTIMS TO ACTUALLY BE ABLE TO
RECEIVE ANY KIND OF RECOURSE.
THEY ARE HARMED PHYSICALLY,
MENTALLY, EMOTIONALLY. AND SO
FOR ALL THE OTHER REASONS, SOME
OF WHICH WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
ADDRESS CIVILLY FOR OTHER CRIMES
INFLICTED UPON THOSE SAME
VICTIMS, WE WANT TO EXTEND THE
SAME OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
DO SO WHEN THEY ARE A VICTIM OF
DOXING AS DEFINED WITHOUT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU SIR. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 38 AB 1979.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG WILK I
WILK I ALLEN. ALLEN I ASHBY.
ASHBY I CABALLERO. DURAZO DURAZO
I LAIRD. NHIÀU ROTH. ROTH I.
STERN. WAHAB. 5 TO 0 FIVE ZERO.
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. FILE ITEM 36 AB 2224.
FILE ITEM 36, AB 2224, THANK
YOU, MR. CHAIR. SANTIAGO THANK
YOU, MR. THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. I
FIRST LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS. I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S HARD
WORK AND THE MEMBERSHIP'S
INTEREST, I'LL KEEP IT SIMPLE.
THE SPECIAL IMMIGRATION JUVENILE
STATUS, HAD PROVIDES LIMITED
IMMIGRATION RELIEF FOR
VULNERABLE UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN
AND YOUNG PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
ABUSED, NEGLECTED OR ABANDONED.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE PROCESS TAKES
TOO LONG. THIS BILL SEEMS TO
WILL SIMPLIFY IT SO THAT THEY
GET GET GET THEIR QUARTERS SO
THEY CAN GO BEFORE THE FEDERAL
COURTS, AGAIN, ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENTS,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND APPRECIATE YOUR TIME. GREAT
DO YOU HAVE ANY PRIMARY
WITNESSES? NO OKAY. IS THERE ARE
NO PRIMARY WITNESSES ANY ANY ANY
METOO SUPPORTERS IN THE ROOM
SEEING NONE. ANYBODY HERE IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE. PULL IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE. NO
QUESTIONS. NO COMMENTS. I'D LOVE
TO HAVE A MOTION THEN. SENATOR
ALLEN, THANK YOU. SENATOR ALLEN
HAS MOVED THE BILL. WITH THAT,
YOU MAY CLOSE, RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU. SIR IF
YOU COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 36 AB
2224. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
NUMBER WILK. A WILK I ALLEN.
ALLEN I ASHBY. ASHBY I.
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. I
LAIRD. NILO I NILO I. ROTH. ROTH
I. STERN. WAHAB 6 TO 0. 6 TO 0.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN. ALL
RIGHT. VERY PATIENT. AUTHOR.
HERE, DO YOU HAVE ANY PARTICULAR
ORDER YOU WANT TO GO IN OR. I'M
HAPPY TO GO IN AND FILE ITEM AND
WE'LL GO FILE TO FILE ITEM. SO
WE'LL START WITH FILE ITEM 40
2AB 2693. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, OKAY.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT A B 2693 THE
CHILD SEXUAL ASSAULT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS BILL. MY WORK IN
THIS LEGISLATURE, IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IS PRIMARILY DRIVEN
BY BEING A MOM, A MOM OF TWO
YOUNG GIRLS. AND I REALLY VIEW
OUR JOB AS LAWMAKERS IS TO KEEP
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFE,
PARTICULARLY OUR MOST
VULNERABLE, WHICH ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN THE TOUGH ON CRIME.
CALIFORNIA LOCKED UP MORE THAN
130,000 CHILDREN IN JAILS AND
COUNTY JUVENILE DETENTION
CENTERS. TOO MANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS HAVE COME FORWARD AS
ADULTS TO SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES OF SEXUAL ASSAULT
PERPETRATED BY EMPLOYEES OF
THESE JUVENILE CAMPS, A B 2693
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
THROUGHOUT THE ASSEMBLY PROCESS.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW A ONE YEAR
OPENING OF THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR SURVIVORS OF THE
LAST FOR DECADES TO COME FORWARD
AND REPORT THEIR ABUSE IN 2022,
PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNED INTO LAW
THE ELIMINATING LIMITS TO
JUSTICE FOR CHILD SEXUAL ABUSE
VICTIM ACT, REMOVING THE STATUTE
OF LIMITATIONS FOR THESE CASES
IN FEDERAL COURTS. ALTHOUGH WE
CANNOT UNDO THEIR PAST
EXPERIENCES, WE CAN GIVE THESE
SURVIVORS 365 DAYS TO GET THE
JUSTICE THEY DESERVE. TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT TODAY IS AKEELA
JEFFERSON, WHO IS A SURVIVOR OF
THIS BREACH OF TRUST AND BROKEN
PROMISES FROM THESE
REHABILITATION CENTERS. AND WHEN
THE TIME IS RIGHT, I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. WELCOME. THANK
YOU. HI, EVERYBODY. HI. MY NAME
IS AKEELA JEFFERSON. I LIVE IN
VICTORVILLE. YEAH. LET'S TURN IT
ON AND THEN TALK INTO THE MIC.
IT'S ON OKAY. PERFECT. ALL RIGHT
. HI EVERYBODY. MY NAME IS
AKEELA JEFFERSON. I LIVE IN
VICTORVILLE, CALIFORNIA. I AM
CURRENTLY WORKING AT A
NONPROFIT. AT A NONPROFIT
ADVOCATES FOR PEACE AND
OPPORTUNITY OUT OF LOS ANGELES,
CALIFORNIA, I I'M SORRY. RIGHT
NOW. RIGHT NOW. AND I WORK AND I
HELP GIRLS. THAT'S IN GANGS WITH
SEXUAL ABUSE AND GANGS, I WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
OF THE STATE ASSEMBLY FOR
PASSING THIS BILL WITH NO NO
DISSENTING VOTES, MY PARENTS
ABANDONED ME AS A CHILD. THEY
WERE TEENAGERS AS WELL. I'M
LEAVING MY GRANDMOTHER TO RAISE
ME. AS A TEENAGER. I BEGAN
SKIPPING SCHOOL TO, STEALING
CLOTHES AND THINGS LIKE THAT. I
LANDED IN CAMP SCOTT. CAMP SCOTT
WAS BUILT AS A BOOT CAMP TO
REHABILITATE US, I DON'T KNOW. I
GUESS THE TEACHERS TO BE. I
DON'T KNOW, UPSTANDING CITIZENS,
MILITARY DISCIPLINE, AN
EDUCATION AND TOUGH LOVE, I
DIDN'T FIND MUCH LOVE AT CAMP
SCOTT. INSTEAD, I FOUND YEARS OF
SEXUAL ABUSE AT THE HANDS OF A
DEPUTY PROBATION OFFICER. IT
BEGAN AT THE AGE OF 16, WHEN I
WAS SERVING A FOUR MONTH
SENTENCE FOR TRUANCY. HE
THREATENED ME THAT IF I TOLD
ANYONE, I WOULD SUFFER
CONSEQUENCES. I BELIEVED HIM. HE
WAS AN ADULT. I WAS A WARD OF
THE COURT, HE WAS COMPLETELY IN
CHARGE OF MY LIFE AT THAT TIME,
I WAS ABLE TO DEAL WITH MY
EMOTIONAL TRAUMA AND SEEK LEGAL
ASSISTANCE BEFORE THE WINDOW OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS CLOSED IN JANUARY.
MORE THAN 2500 PEOPLE HAVE
STEPPED FORWARD SINCE THEN, WITH
CREDIBLE CLAIMS OF ABUSE. OTHERS
WILL BE DENIED THAT OPPORTUNITY
UNLESS YOU ACT TODAY, AB 2693
WILL OPEN A WINDOW FOR
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO GIVE VICTIMS
OF JUVENILE PROBATION, SEXUAL
ASSAULT THEIR DAY IN COURT TO
FACE THEIR ABUSERS AND THE
PEOPLE WHO, LIKE ENABLED THEM,
CAN YOU PLEASE GIVE IT YOUR
APPROVAL TODAY? AND THANKS,
WICKS. THANK YOU. I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT. I
KNOW THAT THAT WAS NOT EASY AND
IT BREAKS CAMP. SCOTT IS LIKE 15
MINUTES FROM MY HOUSE, AND I'VE
BEEN THERE MANY A TIME, AND I'M
JUST SO SORRY THAT HAPPENED. AND
YOU ALSO MY CONSTITUENT, BECAUSE
I REPRESENT VICTORVILLE. SO
THANK YOU FOR COMING AND TAKING
A BAD SITUATION AND MAKING IT
BETTER FOR OTHERS. SO VERY, VERY
PROUD OF YOU, ANYBODY ELSE HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT? THANK YOU,
MR. CHAIR. MEMBERS. DYLAN
KOEPKE, ON BEHALF OF THE CHILD
ABUSE PREVENTION CENTER AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. REBECCA
MARCUS, CONVEYING SUPPORT FOR
THE CONSUMERS ATTORNEYS OF
CALIFORNIA SMART JUSTICE AND
INITIATE JUSTICE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DYLAN
ELLIOT, ON BEHALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU, SIR.
ANTHONY DEMARTINO, ON BEHALF OF
CRIME SURVIVORS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANYONE HERE IN OPPOSITION IN.
MAY. COME ON UP. TAKE A SEAT,
GET COMFORTABLE. AND YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. YEAH I KNOW I HAVE
THE MOST ENVIABLE JOB TODAY, MY
NAME IS ANDY BIRNBAUM, AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES. AND HOLY SMOKES,
THAT WOMAN WAS BRAVE, INDEED,
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IS, IS
VERY LATE IN GETTING OUR
OPPOSITION, AND WE APPRECIATE
THAT. IT WAS NOT AN EASY
DECISION FOR THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. AND, IN FACT, THE
OPPOSITION IS REALLY ROOTED IN
THE LIABILITY AND THE COSTS THAT
WE ARE FACING AS A COUNTY,
CERTAINLY NOT ON THE POLICY AND
THE NEED TO PROVIDE REDRESS TO
CHILDREN WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED
WHILE THEY WERE IN THE CARE OF
THE COUNTY. WE ALSO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY
THAT, A GREAT DEAL OF THE
COMPENSATION MIGHT BE GOING TO
LEGAL COUNSEL RATHER THAN
DIRECTLY TO THE VICTIMS, AT
LEAST THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE BEEN
TOLD. AND SO OUR BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS HAS GREAT CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT. WE'RE CURRENTLY
ANTICIPATING THE FISCAL
LIABILITY FROM RELATED RELATED
PASSED LEGISLATION TO BE IN THE
MULTI BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. AND
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
BALANCE REDRESSING HARMS THAT
OCCURRED AND CONTINUING TO SERVE
THE 10 MILLION PEOPLE WHO WE
SERVE AND LIVE IN OUR COUNTY, WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BILL WOULD JUST
FURTHER COMPOUND THOSE ISSUES
WITHOUT US HAVING A SOLUTION. SO
RATHER THAN SIMPLY OPPOSING THE
BILL AND NOT HAVING SOLUTIONS,
WE WOULD RELISH THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TALK ABOUT MATTERS THAT COULD
MAKE IT SO THAT THE COUNTY CAN
ACCOMPLISH ALL OF THE GOALS,
ADDRESS THE HARMS, AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE WHO RELY ON US FOR
CURRENT SERVICES. WELL, THAT'S
WHO YOU TALKED TO. SO HOPEFULLY
YOU GUYS CAN HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE PULL IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR ALLEN, WELL,
I WANT TO THANK ALL THE FOLKS
WHO CAME IN TO SPEAK ON THIS,
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, AN
ISSUE THAT WE'VE SEEN SEVERAL
TIMES BEFORE, THIS COMMITTEE
AND, AND, YOU KNOW, PART OF THE
CHALLENGE HERE ALWAYS IS THAT
THERE ARE THESE INCREDIBLY,
TRAGIC AND TERRIBLE CASES, AND
THEN ON THE OTHER HAND, YOU'VE
GOT THE, YOU KNOW, THE PUBLIC
ENTITIES SUCH AS THE ONE THAT
WAS REPRESENTED HERE THAT ARE
REALLY STRUGGLING UNDER THE
WEIGHT OF ALL OF THESE NEW
LAWSUITS THAT HAVE COME FORWARD.
AND, I MEAN, THERE ARE SEVERAL
CASES OF IN MY OWN DISTRICT
WHERE, CITIES ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING, BECAUSE OF SEVERAL,
OF THESE SUITS SUCH THAT THEY'RE
NOT ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD ON ALL
SORTS OF PUBLIC PROJECTS,
BECAUSE THE LIABILITY IS SO
ENORMOUS. SO I, I'M, I WILL
SUPPORT THE BILL, BUT I REALLY
DO ASK THE AUTHOR TO ENGAGE WITH
THESE REPRESENTATIVES OF PUBLIC
ENTITIES. I MEAN, THESE ARE
FOLKS WHO ARE TASKED WITH THE
JOB OF SERVING OUR CONSTITUENTS
AND PROVIDING GOOD SERVICES ON A
WIDE VARIETY OF TOPICS AND
ISSUES. AND, YOU KNOW, WE'RE ALL
CUTTING BACK ON LOCAL GOVERNMENT
RIGHT NOW BECAUSE OF THE
SITUATION IN THE BUDGET. YOU
KNOW, HOW DO WE FIGURE OUT A
PATH MOVING FORWARD THAT WILL
PROVIDE, YOU KNOW, COMPENSATION
AND JUSTICE FOR THE VICTIMS,
WHILE ALSO ENSURING THAT OUR
PUBLIC ENTITIES ARE ABLE TO,
CARRY OUT THE WORK THAT WE
TASKED THEM WITH. AND THAT'S,
THAT'S THE DIFFICULT BALANCE
HERE, AND I JUST WANT TO I GUESS
I WANT TO I KNOW IT'S LATE
OPPOSITION, BUT I'D LOVE TO HEAR
THE AUTHOR'S THOUGHTS ON HOW TO
STRIKE THAT BALANCE ADEQUATELY.
SURE. SO WE GOT THE LETTER
TODAY, SO I HAVEN'T EVEN SEEN IT
YET BECAUSE I WAS CHAIRING
ANOTHER COMMITTEE AND HAD OTHER
BILLS UP, SO I HAVEN'T READ THE
LETTER YET, OBVIOUSLY I'LL, AS I
ALWAYS DO, I WILL SIT DOWN WITH
OPPOSITION AND TRY TO FIGURE OUT
TO SEE IF THERE'S A PATH. BUT
WHAT IS CRITICAL TO ME IS THAT
THE SURVIVORS OF THESE, TERRIBLE
CRIMES ARE MADE AS HOLES WE CAN
POSSIBLY MAKE THEM, AND SO I
WILL DO SO WITH THAT LENS OF
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND IF THERE'S
A PATH FORWARD. AND I'M OF
COURSE, WILL SIT DOWN AGAIN. THE
LETTER WAS SENT TODAY, SO I
HAVEN'T HAD THE TIME TO REVIEW
IT. YEAH. AND I THINK I THINK
PART OF WHAT ENDS UP HAPPENING
IS THAT A LOT OF ENTITIES,
INCLUDING BOARDS, I MEAN, THIS
IS A BOARD OF ELECTED OFFICIALS
WHO, YOU KNOW, ARE INCREDIBLY
SYMPATHETIC TO THE BROAD CAUSE
THAT YOU'RE PRESENTING TODAY,
MAKING VICTIMS WHOLE. AND I'M
SURE IT WAS A VERY DIFFICULT
DECISION FOR THE BOARD TO OPPOSE
THIS. I MEAN, THEY'RE ALL
ELECTED OFFICIALS WHO DON'T WANT
TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH, YOU KNOW,
BAD ACTS SUCH AS THE ONES THAT,
YOU KNOW, SEEM TO HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED, AT CAMP, AT CAMP
SCOTT AND, AND ELSEWHERE. SO,
BUT NEVERTHELESS, I MEAN,
THEY'RE SITTING THERE REALLY
STRUGGLING WITH, WITH BALANCING
BUDGETS. AND OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW, AT THE END OF THE DAY,
COUNTIES LIKE LA, THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THEIR MONEY IS
SOCIAL SERVICES, HELPING LOW
INCOME FOLKS, INDIGENT FOLKS.
AND, SO THERE'S A JUSTICE AND
EQUITY COMPONENT TO THEIR
BUDGET. SO ANYWAY, I, YOU KNOW,
I KNOW YOU'RE A THOUGHTFUL
MEMBER AND, YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
INCREDIBLY DIFFICULT ISSUES TO
BALANCE. AND, BUT I CERTAINLY DO
ENCOURAGE THAT CONVERSATION, AND
I HOPE WE CAN FIND A GOOD PLACE
TO LAND. I WILL DEFINITELY HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS. AND I KNOW
IT'S NOT AN EASY DECISION FOR
THEM AS WELL TO COME FORWARD IN
OPPOSITION WITH SOMETHING LIKE
THIS. BUT, THE FACT THAT REMAINS
THAT THERE WERE A BUNCH OF YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO WERE WHO WERE
VICTIMIZED, AND WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE RECTIFY THAT
AT THE HANDS OF THE COUNTY. YOU
KNOW, CAN I JUST ASK YOU ONE
QUESTION? BECAUSE I KNOW WE. SO
IS THIS A CASE OF PEOPLE THAT
JUST HADN'T HAD THE TIME TO THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS CLOSED?
AND SO THERE'S FOLKS THAT HAVE
SINCE COME FORWARD AND ALSO
WITH, WITH SEXUAL ABUSE OF
MINORS IN PARTICULAR FOR, FOR
MANY OF THE VICTIMS, IT'S A
STRUGGLE TO COME FORWARD. AND I
THINK FOR A LOT OF THEM, IT
TAKES TIME TO SORT OF FIGURE
THAT OUT, SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY HAVE HAVE THAT
TIME, AND AGAIN OPENING THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR ONE
YEAR. SO THERE'S, YOU KNOW,
PARAMETERS AROUND THAT, WHICH
I'VE DONE OTHER BILLS OF SIMILAR
NATURE WHERE WE OPEN UP THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
SIMILAR SPECIFIC ISSUES,
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE CHILD
SEXUAL ABUSE IN PARTICULAR IS
INCREDIBLY TRAUMATIC FOR FOLKS,
GIVES THEM THE TIME TO BE ABLE
TO FIND THE COURAGE. AND ONE OF
THE INTERESTING CHALLENGES OF
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF REASONS WHY IT
EXISTS. BUT BY OPENING IT FOR A
SHORT WINDOW, YOU BASICALLY
CREATE THIS MASSIVE LIABILITY
FOR CURRENT BUDGETS. FOR SOME
ACTS THAT TOOK PLACE A LONG TIME
AGO, AND WHEREAS, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, IT'S INTERESTING BECAUSE
IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE A STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS AT ALL, THAT
LIABILITY WOULD LAST OVER A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME. BUT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS GOT SOCKED WITH THIS
HUGE LIABILITY FOR, YOU KNOW, AT
ONCE, AND SO YOU KNOW, THE
CURRENT BUDGETS ARE BEING
IMPACTED, CURRENT SERVICES AND
PROGRAMS ARE BEING IMPACTED,
IMPACTED WHEN PROGRAMS WEREN'T
FIVE YEARS AGO AND WON'T WON'T
BE FIVE YEARS FROM NOW. I MEAN,
I GUESS THEY'LL BE IMPACTED BY
THE LOSS. BUT IT'S AN
INTERESTING THERE ARE SOME
DOWNSIDES TO THE SHORT WINDOWS
BECAUSE IT FORCES ALL OF THAT,
ALL THOSE LAWSUITS TO COME
FORWARD WITHIN A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME. AND THEN ALL THIS
RESULTING LIABILITY THAT HAS
REALLY, MADE THE WORK OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING. I'M SURE YOU'VE ALL
HEARD FROM, YOUR, YOUR CITIES
AND COUNTIES ON THIS TOPIC. SO,
YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
RIGHT BALANCE TO STRIKE HERE IS
ON THAT QUESTION. BUT YEAH, I,
WELL, I LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING
THEIR LETTER AND READING IT AND
TAKING THE TIME TO, TO WORK WITH
THEM. I GIVE YOU MY WORD, I WILL
DEFINITELY MEET WITH OPPOSITION
AND SEE IF THERE'S WAYS WE CAN
LAND THIS IN A WAY THAT, DOESN'T
CRIPPLE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WHILE STILL ALLOWS FOR THE
SURVIVORS OF THESE CRIMES TO BE
MADE WHOLE. THANK YOU. BEFORE WE
GO TO SENATOR ASHBY, YOU,
SENATOR STERN AND MYSELF WENT TO
CAMP SCOTT. YOU SURE DID. WITH
TIM ROBBINS TO SEE THE
GRADUATING CLASS OF THE ACTORS
GANG, INCREDIBLY MOVING DAY. AND
ONE OF THE THINGS I WAS MOST
UPSET ABOUT IS WHEN THOSE GIRLS
WERE SHARING. THEY WERE THERE.
THEY THEY EARNED THE RIGHT TO BE
THERE. BUT LET'S BE HONEST,
TRAUMA WAS REALLY THE DRIVING
FORCE THAT THAT HAD IT HAPPENED.
YEAH AND THEN WE'RE THERE AND
I'M THINKING TO MYSELF, THIS IS
PROBABLY THE SAFEST PLACE THAT
THESE GIRLS COULD BE BECAUSE
THEN THEY'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
WHERE THAT UNCLE WAS OR
WHATEVER. AND THEN YOU HEAR A
STORY LIKE THAT AND THEY'RE
THEY'RE SAFE NOWHERE. AND
SOMEBODY NEEDS TO BE RESPONSIBLE
FOR, YOU KNOW, WHAT TRANSPIRED.
SO I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU
SAY. AND AGAIN, WE'VE GOT A
GREAT AUTHOR HERE. BUT PEOPLE
NEED TO BE COMPENSATED FOR
THINGS OF THAT NATURE WITH THAT.
SENATOR ASHBY, YOU'RE UP. YEAH.
NORMALLY I MEAN, BUDGETS ARE A
COLD, HARSH REALITY WE ALL HAVE
TO DEAL WITH EVERY DAY IN THESE
OFFICES. AND NORMALLY IT WOULD
BE VERY PERSUASIVE TO ME. ALSO,
NORMALLY, A LETTER FROM LOS
ANGELES COUNTY, ALL FEMALE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS. WE ALL HAVE
FRIENDS ON THAT BODY. WOULD BE
VERY PERSUASIVE TO ME TODAY. IT
IS NOT. NOT EVEN CLOSE, ONE
YEAR. THAT'S ALL SHE'S ASKING
FOR ON THIS BILL. SHE'S THERE
ARE OTHER STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
BILLS ALL AROUND THIS TOPIC
AROUND VICTIMS, PARTICULARLY A
LOT OF FEMALE VICTIMS. AND SOME
OF THEM ARE REALLY LONG AND SOME
OF THEM WILL REALLY BE DIFFICULT
FOR THESE BODIES TO ADDRESS.
THIS ONE YEAR IS ALL
ASSEMBLYWOMAN WICKS IS ASKING
FOR. AND, YOU KNOW, THESE YOUTH
THAT ARE COMING OUT OF THESE
PROGRAMS, THEY DON'T WALK OUT OF
THE PROGRAM AND SUDDENLY WALK
INTO A BUNCH OF CARING ADULTS
WHO ARE GOING TO HELP THEM SOLVE
ALL OF THEIR LIFE'S PROBLEMS. IF
THAT EXISTED, THEY WOULDN'T HAVE
BEEN THERE TO BEGIN WITH. IT'S
JUST A FURTHER VICTIMIZATION.
AND I REALLY APPRECIATE IT. THE
SPEAKER WHO CAME TODAY. BUT I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
WE AS A GOVERNMENT ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT SOMETIMES WE DON'T GET IT
RIGHT. AND IN THIS INSTANCE, WE
DID NOT. AND WE HAVE CREATED A
SYSTEM THAT HAS HURT SOME YOUNG
GIRLS. WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THAT. WE NEED TO TAKE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT WHETHER
WE WERE HERE OR NOT. TOO BAD.
THESE SEATS WERE FILLED BY
SOMEBODY AND WE'RE HERE NOW. SO
TODAY WE SAY YES TO BEING
RESPONSIBLE. OR AT LEAST I DO.
I'LL MAKE THE MOTION WHEN IT'S
TIME. ALL RIGHT. SENATOR DURAZO.
THANK YOU. YOU KNOW WHAT'S, WHAT
WE'RE ALL STRUGGLING WITH HERE
IS THAT THIS HAPPENS OVER AND
OVER, AND IT DOESN'T HAPPEN OVER
AND OVER TO AN INDIVIDUAL HERE
OR AN INDIVIDUAL THERE. IT IS
HAPPENING IN MASS. YOU KNOW, THE
BOY SCOUTS ALLEGATIONS, THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH, YOU KNOW, I
MEAN, WE COULD JUST GO ON AND ON
ORGANIZATIONS AND GOVERNMENT
THAT ARE NOT TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY. AND THERE'S
SOMETHING DEEPLY WRONG, BECAUSE
THEN WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
AFTERMATH. WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
FUNDING FOR SERVICES BEING CUT
BECAUSE OF THE ACTIONS OF
OTHERS. AND IT'S REALLY
SOMEWHERE WE ALL HAVE TO FIGURE
THAT OUT, BECAUSE I THINK THE
PRIMARY REASON THIS GOES ON AND
ON AND ON AND ON, PEOPLE, EITHER
THE VICTIMS AND OR PEOPLE AROUND
THE VICTIMS, ARE AFRAID TO
REPORT THE ACTION. THEY'RE
AFRAID THEY COULD LOSE THEIR JOB
. THEY ARE AFRAID THERE WILL BE
REPERCUSSIONS, RETALIATIONS AND
ALL THIS. AND SO THEY LET IT GO
ON AND ON AND ON. AND WE'RE NOT
REALLY DEALING WITH THAT. I
DON'T KNOW HOW TO DEAL WITH
THAT. BUT THERE'S A CULTURE
PROBLEM IN THIS COUNTRY WHEN
THAT CAN HAPPEN SO MANY TIMES
OVER, OVER DECADES. AND STILL IT
HAPPENS, AND ESPECIALLY TO OUR
MOST VULNERABLE, IT'S A REAL
ILLNESS. IT'S SICK. AND, I CAN'T
LET THAT OUT. YEAH. YOU KNOW,
THE, DAMAGE THAT THEY DONE
THROUGH AND THE TRYING TO MAKE
THESE, THE PEOPLE WHOLE, CAN'T
LET THAT BE STOPPED BY THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE TO NOW PAY OUT. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS?
SEEING NONE. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SENATOR ASHBY AND YOU MAY
CLOSE. I THINK AKEELAH'S WORD
SPOKE BEST ON THIS ISSUE AND
THIS DEBATE. I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM FOLKS ON THE DAIS.
I'M VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. EVERY YEAR I CARRY
SOMETHING IN THE SPACE OF A
SEXUAL ASSAULT, IT'S, I THINK,
DEEPLY IMPORTANT. I THINK WE DO
HAVE A SOCIETY THAT IS CORRUPTED
IN MANY WAYS, AND IT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS LEADERS, AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS, TO KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE AND TO MAKE
THEM WHOLE AS MUCH AS WE CAN. SO
WITH THAT, I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. GREAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IF WE COULD
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER 42 AB 2693. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS UMBERG A UMBERG I
WILK A WILK I ALLEN ALLEN I
ASHBY. ASHBY I CABALLERO. DURAZO
DURAZO I LAIRD. NILO NILO I
ROTH. ROTH I STERN. WAHAB. FILE
ITEM 42 AB 2693. WAHAB I JUST TO
DOUBLE CHECK OUR VOTES ON MY
BILL OH 8 TO 0. SENATOR 8 TO 0
8080. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. I THINK
THAT CONCLUDES THE HEARING. OH,
NO. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. ONE MORE.
ALL RIGHT. BACK AND VOTE. RIGHT?
RIGHT. OKAY, AB 3211 I THINK IS
NEXT ON THE DOCKET STANDING
BETWEEN YOU ALL AND DINNER. IS
THAT WHAT'S HAPPENING? GREAT.
30. YES WELL, AND I WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR FOR HONORING HIS
COMMITMENT TO FLIP THE ORDER, IN
THE UPCOMING HEARINGS, BECAUSE I
HAD HIM ON THE RECORD LAST YEAR.
WELL, THE AYES. OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
OKAY WITH THAT, MR. CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS, I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB 3211, THE CALIFORNIA
PROVENANCE AUTHENTICITY AND
WATERMARKING STANDARDS ACT.
FIRST, I GIVE MY THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. VERY HARD WORK.
SOME OF THE HARDEST WORKING
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE BUILDING,
APPRECIATE THEIR EFFORTS TO WORK
WITH OUR OFFICE. AND I'D LIKE TO
CONFIRM THAT I'M GOING TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY
AND APPRECIATE, MR. UMBERG, YOUR
HELP IN GETTING THIS BILL INTO A
BETTER PLACE AND YOUR REFEREEING
ON ALL THE I STUFF THAT'S
HAPPENING OUT THERE. SO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP. FACED
WITH A NEWLY CHAOTIC MEDIA
LANDSCAPE MADE UP OF GENERATIVE
AI AND SUBSTANTIALLY MODIFIED
CONTENT ALONGSIDE HUMAN
GENERATED REAL PHOTOGRAPHS,
VIDEOS AND AUDIO, IT'S BECOME
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO KNOW
WHAT TO TRUST. UNDRESSING APPS
ARE RAMPANT. THEY ALLOW A USER
TO PAY $1 AND SPEND LESS THAN 20
MINUTES TO CREATE VERY
CONVINCING, DEEP FAKES THAT ARE
NON-CONSENSUAL IMAGERY. WOMEN
AND GIRLS ARE PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE TO THIS AND HAVE
EXPERIENCED HARMS IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND BEYOND. SO WE AS
POLICYMAKERS NEED TO ENSURE THAT
THE THAT MEDIA CONSUMERS ARE
BETTER ABLE TO DISCERN WHAT IS
REAL FROM WHAT IS FAKE. AB 3211
PRESENTS THREE WAYS TO DO THIS
ONE. IT REQUIRES ALL CONTENT
FROM CHEN II TO BE LABELED AS
SYNTHETIC. TWO IT REQUIRES ALL
CONTENT FROM RECORDED DEVICES TO
BE LABELED AS NON SYNTHETIC AND
THIRD, IT REQUIRES ALL ONLINE
PLATFORMS TO DISPLAY THESE
LABELS. SOME OF THE TECH
INDUSTRY SAYS IT'S TOO EARLY FOR
MANDATING TRANSPARENCY, DURABLE
CREDENTIALS, AND PROVENANCE
DATA. BUT LET ME ASSURE YOU, AND
IT IS NOT JUST MY OPINION, IT'S
THOSE IN THE TECH INDUSTRY, WE
BELIEVE THE TECHNOLOGY IS
AVAILABLE AND WE'LL BE HEARING
SOME TESTIMONY TOWARDS THAT END
TODAY. CALIFORNIA BASED STARTUPS
ARE MAKING THESE TECHNOLOGIES
AS, DIGIMARC A WORLD LEADER IN
FINANCIAL AND DATA SECURITY, IS
ALREADY PROVIDING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND LARGE LANGUAGE
DEVELOPERS LIKE OPENAI AND
GOOGLE ARE BETA TESTING THESE
TECHNOLOGIES WITH GENERAL USERS.
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE DON'T
LET ANOTHER TECHNOLOGY RUN
RAMPANT THAT HAS POTENTIAL TO
IMPACT OUR CHILDREN. ALSO,
THERE'S OBVIOUS NEEDS FOR THIS
WITH REGARD TO ELECTIONS AND
ELECTIONS PROTECTIONS AROUND THE
IDEA OF WHEN OUR IMAGES ARE OUT
THERE AND WE'RE WE'RE TALKING AS
ELECTED OFFICIALS, WE'RE RUNNING
FOR OFFICE, THAT THOSE ARE, IN
FACT, US SAYING THOSE WORDS. SO
WE NEED SOME GUARDRAILS, WE'VE
ALSO LOOKED VERY CLOSELY AT THE
EU REGULATIONS AND OTHER
POLICIES THAT ARE OUT THERE. WE
REALLY WANT CONFORMITY. WE'VE
TALKED AT LENGTH TO INDUSTRY. WE
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS. THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING TO ME IS THAT WE
ACTUALLY CRAFT A BILL THAT CAN
BE IMPLEMENTED. WHAT'S THE POINT
IN DOING SOMETHING IF IT'S NOT
POSSIBLE TO BE IMPLEMENTED? SO
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS, VERY GOOD
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF THE
INDUSTRY'S BIGGEST LEADERS, IN
THE TECH SPACE AND WILL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT, WITH ME TO SUPPORT,
SORRY WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT TODAY ARE DAVID HARRIS,
PROFESSOR WITH THE HAAS SCHOOL
OF BUSINESS AT UC BERKELEY, AND
KEN SEGAL, EVP, CHIEF PRODUCT
OFFICER WITH DIGITAL. MARK
ALRIGHTY. THANK YOU. THE FLOOR
IS YOURS, CHAIR UMBERG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. IT'S
AN HONOR TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK
WITH YOU TODAY, AND TO CONVEY MY
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB 3211, THE
CALIFORNIA PROVENANCE,
AUTHENTICITY AND WATERMARKING
STANDARDS. MY NAME IS DAVID
HARRIS, AND I'M HERE TODAY IN MY
CAPACITY AS SENIOR POLICY
ADVISOR TO CITED THE CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE FOR TECHNOLOGY AND
DEMOCRACY, CITED AS THE NEWEST
INITIATIVE OF CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE. AND IT'S SEEKING TO
SEEKING STATE LEVEL SOLUTIONS TO
THE THREATS OF DISINFORMATION,
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE,
DEEPFAKES AND OTHER EMERGING
TECHNOLOGIES AND THE THREATS
THAT THEY POSE TO OUR ELECTIONS.
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR AB 3211,
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE WATERMARKING
AND PROVENANCE DATA FOR CONTENTS
CREATED FOR CONTENT CREATED BY
GENERATIVE AI SYSTEMS. AI IS A
POWERFUL TOOL THAT CAN BRING
GREAT BENEFITS TO PEOPLE, BUT IT
ALSO, IF NOT GOVERN JUDICIOUSLY,
HAS THE POWER TO CAUSE GREAT
HARM. THIS IS WHY SO MANY AI
COMPANIES CEOS HAVE THEMSELVES
CALLED FOR MORE REGULATION OF AI
. YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THE
HARMS THAT CAN BE CAUSED BY AI
GENERATED NON-CONSENSUAL
INTIMATE IMAGERY AND CHILD
SEXUAL ABUSE MATERIAL
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGNS IN
ELECTIONS CAN ALSO BE
SUPERCHARGED BY AI. WE'RE
FAMILIAR WITH THESE CAMPAIGNS
FROM THE 2016 EFFORTS BY RUSSIA
TO INTERFERE IN OUR ELECTIONS
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA, AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
HAS ALREADY WARNED US THAT
CHINA, RUSSIA AND IRAN ARE
LIKELY TO USE GENERATIVE AI TO
TARGET OUR ELECTIONS, MICROSOFT
AND OPENAI REPORTED IN FEBRUARY
THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY CAUGHT
STATE ACTORS FROM NORTH KOREA,
IRAN, RUSSIA AND CHINA
WEAPONIZING THEIR AI SYSTEMS.
WATERMARKING IS THE BEST TOOL
AVAILABLE TO ALLOW US TO
IDENTIFY WHAT CONTENT IS
PRODUCED BY AI AND WHAT CONTENT
IS AUTHENTIC. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THAT AI COMPANIES MAKE GOOD ON
PROMISES THAT THEY'VE ALREADY
MADE TO ADD WATERMARKING TO
THEIR AI SYSTEMS. THESE PROMISES
WERE FIRST MADE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE VOLUNTARY AI COMMITTEE
CGRTS, LAST JULY, AND THEN AGAIN
AT THE MUNICH SECURITY
CONFERENCE IN THE AI ELECTIONS
ACCORD THIS FEBRUARY. THANK YOU.
IF YOU'D WRAP IT UP, PLEASE. OH,
YES. I JUST WANTED TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE'S STAFF FOR THE
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS, WHICH POINTS
OUT THAT GOOGLE HAS ALREADY
LAUNCHED WATERMARKING,
PROVENANCE AND AUTHENTICITY
SOLUTIONS THAT WOULD LIKELY BE
COMPLIANT WITH THIS BILL. SO THE
TECHNOLOGY IS HERE FOR US TODAY.
THANK YOU. CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE,
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY TO SPEAK ON THE IMPORTANT
MATTERS ADDRESSED BY AB 3211.
I'M KEN SICKLES, CHIEF PRODUCT
OFFICER OF DIGIMARC. DIGIMARC IS
THE PIONEER AND GLOBAL LEADER IN
DIGITAL WATERMARKING, DEPLOYING
AUTHENTICATION AND
IDENTIFICATION TECHNOLOGY ON A
GLOBAL SCALE. EVERYTHING FROM
CURRENCIES, MOTION PICTURES AND
OVER 90% OF BROADCAST TELEVISION
THÀNH. I'M HONORED TO BE HERE
TODAY AS WE ARE STANDING AT THE
PRECIPICE OF AN INCREDIBLE
CHANGE TO OUR INFORMATION
ECOSYSTEM, A CHANGE FUELED BY
THE ADVENT OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE AND ITS ABILITY TO
CREATE DIGITAL CONTENT AT AN
ASTRONOMICAL SCALE. AND WITH
UNPRECEDENT SPEED, AB 3211
ALLOWS FOR THE INNOVATIVE
POTENTIAL OF AI WHILE CREATING
MUCH NEEDED SAFEGUARDS FOR ITS
USE. THIS INCLUDES THE MANDATING
OF USING DIGITAL WATERMARKS ON
ALL AI GENERATED CONTENT AND
ADVOCATING FOR THE USE OF
DIGITAL WATERMARKS ON ALL
AUTHENTIC OR HUMAN MADE DIGITAL
CONTENT. I WANT TO CALL OUT THE
BILL'S PROVISION TO MAKE DIGITAL
WATERMARKS EMBEDDABLE AND
DECODABLE AT A DEVICE LEVEL.
BECAUSE THIS IS BOTH THOUGHTFUL
AND ESSENTIAL, WE BELIEVE THAT
OFFERING THE OPTION TO EMBED AND
DECODE DIGITAL WATERMARKS ON
DEVICES CRUCIAL TO CREATING A
MORE TRANSPARENT AND TRUSTWORTHY
DIGITAL ECOSYSTEM. THIS IS
BECAUSE ALL CONTENT IS CREATED
AND CONSUMED ON A DEVICE.
THEREFORE, TO ENSURE DIGITAL
CONSUMERS HAVE CLARITY ABOUT THE
DIGITAL CONTENT THEY WATCH, READ
OR LISTEN TO, WE BELIEVE THAT
ALL CONTENT AI AND HUMAN CREATED
SHOULD BE DIGITALLY WATERMARKED
AND DECODED AT THE POINT OF
CREATION AND CONSUMPTION, WHICH
IS AGAIN ON DEVICE. IF THIS
ISN'T DONE, DIGITAL
MISINFORMATION AND
DISINFORMATION STANDS TO
INCREASE BY AN ORDER OF
MAGNITUDE. THE ACTIONS TAKEN BY
THIS BODY IN THE COMING MONTHS
WILL DEFINE THE FUTURE OF OUR
DIGITAL ECONOMY AND, BY
EXTENSION, OUR WORLD. DIGIMARC
BELIEVES THAT AB 3211 TAKES AN
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
SAFEGUARDING THE BIGGEST MODERN
REVOLUTION SINCE THE ADVENT OF
THE INTERNET ITSELF, AND
PROVIDES GUARDRAILS IN WHICH THE
TECHNOLOGY CAN BE DEPLOYED
READILY AND SAFELY. ON BEHALF OF
DIGIMARC, I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR HAVING ME HERE
TODAY, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OTHERS IN SUPPORT
OF AB 3211, PLEASE APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE. WE STARTED USING
THIS ONE. COM YEAH. WE WANT
PEOPLE TO STAND SO MAKES THE
HEARING GO QUICKER RIGHT. THANK
YOU. DILLONLIAM ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT. OTHERS IN
SUPPORT SEEING NO ONE ELSE
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. LET'S
TURN TO THE OPPOSITION. IF
YOU'RE OPPOSED TO AB 3211,
PLEASE COME UP TO THE
MICROPHONE. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. MEMBERS DYLAN HOFFMAN, ON
BEHALF OF TECHNET, WE ARE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO AB 3211
STRONGLY AGREE WITH THE INTENT
OF THE AUTHOR TO CREATE GREATER
TRUST IN USER GENERATED CONTENT
ONLINE BY FOSTERING THE ADOPTION
OF CONTENT PROVENANCE
VERIFICATIONS AND WATERMARKS. WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE COMMITTEE. THE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENTS WILL CONTINUE TO
REVIEW. WE'VE PROVIDED SUGGESTED
RED LINES TO THE AUTHOR, AND
CONVERSATIONS WILL CONTINUE THIS
WEEK TO CONTINUE DISCUSSING THE
INTRICACIES OF THIS BILL. WE
STILL THINK THE BILL IN PRINT
PRESENTS A NUMBER OF ISSUES AND
REQUIRES PLATFORMS TO COMPLY
WITH SOME TECHNICALLY INFEASIBLE
AND OVERLY PRESCRIPTIVE
STANDARDS, AND I THINK I REALLY
WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT WHILE
SOME OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES ARE
AVAILABLE TODAY, THEY'RE
AVAILABLE IN VARYING FORMS. SO
SOME ARE FULLY RELEASED TO THE
PUBLIC FOR USE. SOME ARE STILL
IN BETA TESTING. SO THEY'RE ON A
LIMITED EXPERIMENT EITHER WITH
SUBJECTS OR WITH THE PUBLIC. AND
SOME ARE STILL BEING WORKED ON
INTERNALLY. AND I THINK EVEN FOR
THE ONES THAT ARE FULLY RELEASED
, THEY EXIST IN A SPECTRUM OF
RELIABILITY. MANY RESEARCHERS
ARE STILL ABLE TO BREAK EVERY
TYPE OF WATERMARK THAT IS OUT
THERE TO BE ABLE TO BOTH REMOVE
IT, BUT ALSO INSERT WATERMARKS
WHERE THERE WERE NOT PREVIOUSLY
AND SO I THINK WHILE, YOU KNOW,
I THINK IT IS GOOD TO SET A
STANDARD AND A GOAL TO PURSUE, I
THINK WE SHOULD BE CAREFUL ABOUT
ENSHRINING CERTAIN TECHNOLOGIES
IN LAW TODAY AND LIMITING THE
ASPIRATIONS OF THESE
TECHNOLOGIES AND THESE COMPANIES
TO MAYBE DESIGN SOMETHING BETTER
, MAYBE MAYBE DESIGN SOMETHING
THAT MINIMIZES SOME OF THOSE
WEAKNESSES AND EMPHASIZES THE
STRENGTHS OF THESE VARIOUS
TECHNIQUES. SO WITH THAT, YOU
KNOW, I WANT TO JUST ENCOURAGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER, THAT
RELIABILITY ISSUE THAT STILL
SORT OF HAUNTS SOME OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY. WE STILL ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
. AS HAS BEEN NOTED, OUR
COMPANIES ARE AT THE FOREFRONT
OF THIS. WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CREATING THIS TECHNOLOGY. I
THINK WE'RE JUST CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW THIS GETS ENSHRINED IN LAW
WHEN THERE ARE VARYING LEVELS OF
BOTH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
INTERNATIONAL STANDARDS THAT ARE
STILL BEING WORKED OUT, AND THAT
WE CAN STILL LEARN FROM. SO WITH
THAT, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MR. LONDON. YES, SIR. MR.
CHAIRMAN, MEMBERS, CARL LONDON,
ON BEHALF OF THE RECORDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA,
WE'RE NOT A FULL BLOWN OPPOSE.
SO I WOULD SAY CONCERNED AT THIS
POINT, WE APPRECIATE THE CALLS
FOR LABELING SYNTHETIC CONTENT
AND PROVIDING PROVENANCE
INFORMATION, BUT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
WITH RESPECT TO CREATIVE WORKS
LIKE MUSIC AND HOW THIS WOULD
INTERACT WITH THOSE SYSTEMS.
WE'VE SPOKEN WITH, MISS WILK
STAFF ABOUT OUR CONCERNS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH HER
ON THIS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
WE'LL WE'LL EARNESTLY SPEND JULY
TRYING TO DO THAT VERSUS
TRAVELING LONG DISTANCES AND
GOING TO FUN PLACES. SO WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WELL, GOOD. I'M
GLAD WE'RE DOING THAT. SO ALL
RIGHT. SOUNDS AWFUL. LARA BÀN,
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE, IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. OTHERS. ANYONE ELSE?
ALL RIGHT. SEE? OH, THERE WE GO.
SORRY ABOUT THAT. KARABUDA. ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTER AND
COMMUNICATIONS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION, RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED, ALIGNED WITH TECHNET'S
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
SEEING NO ONE ELSE APPROACHES
THE MICROPHONE, LET'S BRING IT
BACK HERE TO THE COMMITTEE. YES.
SENATOR WAHAB HAS MOVED THE
BILL, QUESTIONS? CONCERNS. I
HAVE SOME. ALL RIGHT. ANYONE
ELSE? ALL RIGHT. IT'S BEEN
MOVED. SO THANK YOU,
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WIX, FOR YOUR
FORWARD THINKING ON THIS, THIS
BILL, I ASSUME IT'S GOING TO GET
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE. IT'S
GOING TO MOVE TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. WE WOULD HAVE
ACTUALLY TAKEN LONGER IN THIS
COMMITTEE HAD IT NOT BEEN THAT
WE WANT THE BILL TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE, JUST LIKE MANY
OF THE AI BILLS, THOUGH, WE'RE
TRYING TO STRIKE A BALANCE
BETWEEN, MAKING SURE THAT WE
ENCOURAGE THE INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA, BUT THAT WE NOT
UNLEASH THE INDUSTRY ON THE
ENTIRE WORLD. AND SO WITH
RESPECT TO THIS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT BILL, I HAVE A GREAT
DEAL OF TREPIDATION BECAUSE THIS
IS ONE OF THE SEMINAL ISSUES IN
THE ENTIRE AREA OF ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. WHAT'S MARKED,
WHAT'S NOT MARKED, HOW DO WE
KNOW, AND THUS WE STILL HAVE, I
THINK, A FAIRLY LONG WAY TO GO.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU ARE
PRAGMATIC AND AMENABLE TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION,
PARTICULARLY WITH THE OPPONENTS.
SOME OF THIS IS SIMPLY NOT
FEASIBLE TODAY, BUT WE BELIEVE
IT IS GOING TO BE FEASIBLE HERE
IN THE FUTURE, SO HAVING SAID
THAT, I'M GOING TO VOTE AYE,
WITH, WITH IT WILL BE AN AYE
WITH TREPIDATION. SO I'LL TAKE
THE AYE ANYWAY, YES. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? YES. NO, I
APPRECIATE THAT. AND I THINK
THAT'S THE RIGHT APPROACH TO BE
HONEST WITH YOU. RIGHT. AND HOW
YOU'RE HOW YOU, MISTER CHAIR,
HANDLING ALL OF THESE BILLS. I
THINK WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE, PUTTING FORTH THE SORT
OF LOWEST HANGING FRUIT OF
GUARDRAILS, THE MOST NECESSARY
GUARDRAILS WITH REGARD TO THE AI
LANDSCAPE, WHILE STILL ALLOWING
FOR THE INNOVATION OAN, THAT WE
KNOW IS GOING TO HAPPEN AND THE
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA AND ALL THESE OTHER
THINGS THAT THAT ARE BENEFITS
PLUS ALL THE PRODUCTS THAT WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW YET EXIST THAT
ARE GOING TO BENEFIT SOCIETY
WHILE STILL GUARDING AGAINST
SOME OF THOSE MORE EGREGIOUS
CONCERNS THAT WE HAVE. AND
THAT'S THE, I THINK, THE NEEDLE
THAT WE'RE ALL TRYING TO THREAD
HERE THAT I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING
TO THREAD, I WAS HAPPY TO TAKE
THE AMENDMENT TO PUSH BACK THE
IMPLEMENTATION DATE, WHICH
CONFORMS WITH THE EU AS WELL,
BECAUSE AND I'LL SAY, YOU KNOW,
WE'RE TALKING TO THE EU
REGULATOR, REGULATORS REGULARLY
AS WELL, BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT FOR THE INDUSTRY
TO HAVE CONFORMITY AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE WITH THE VARIOUS BODIES
THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT ARE
ATTEMPTING TO DO THIS. SO I
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU SAID,
AND WE'RE TALKING TO A LOT OF
THE COMPANIES DIRECTLY, AS WELL
AS THE TRADE ASSOCIATIONS,
BECAUSE I DO WANT TO GET IT
RIGHT AS WELL. I'M COMMITTED TO
THAT, AND I THINK THE ONLY WAY
WE CAN DO THAT IS IF WE KEEP THE
BILL MOVING FORWARD, TO KEEP THE
CONVERSATION GOING. SO WE HAVE A
VEHICLE FOR THAT STATED PURPOSE
OF CREATING THOSE GUARDRAILS,
BUT IN AN INTENTIONAL WAY. AND I
WOULD LOVE TO CONTINUE TO USE
YOU AS A RESOURCE AND A THOUGHT
PARTNER AS WE DO THAT AND YOUR
STAFF AS WELL, WHO HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY HELPFUL AS WE MOVE
THE BILL THROUGH SO THAT
HOPEFULLY, YOU KNOW, IF IT GETS
THROUGH ALL THE WAY, GETS ON THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK. IT'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN ACTUALLY BE
IMPLEMENTED, BUT WITH SOME
FLEXIBILITY TO MAKE SPACE FOR
INNOVATION AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
SO WITH THAT, I'D RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
AND THIS IS THE LAST BILL WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR TODAY. IT IS
UNFORTUNATE THAT SOME OF THE
OTHER AUTHORS AREN'T HERE,
BECAUSE ONE OF THE THINGS WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AS BEST WE CAN IS
TO HAVE CONFORMITY DEFINITIONS.
WE HAVEN'T ACHIEVED THAT TO HAVE
TRANSPARENCY AND TO HAVE LAWS
WRITTEN IN SUCH A WAY THAT THEY
CAN BE IMPLEMENTED AND ENFORCED
IN A IN A RECOGNIZED WAY AND
CONFORMITY AS BEST WE CAN WITH
THE EUROPEAN UNION. THAT'S
RIGHT. AND THAT IS A IS A
CHALLENGE. BUT BUT TO THE EXTENT
THAT AUTHORS ARE LISTENING,
THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS WE WANT
TO DO, IS WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE
ESTABLISHING INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS HERE, AND WE WANT TO
BE IN CONFORMITY WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE EUROPEAN UNION.
ALL RIGHT. WITH THAT, IT'S BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR WAHAB. AYE.
YOU'VE CLOSED. SO, MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER 43, AB
3211. THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION NUMBER A, NUMBER I
WILK NÓ WILK. NÓ. ALLEN. ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY AYE.
CABALLERO. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE
LAIRD. NILO. NILO. NØ. ROTH
ROTH. AYE. STERN. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE 6 TO 2. SIX TWO. WE'RE GOING
TO PUT THAT ON CALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO IN JUST A MOMENT,
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL. I'M HOPING THAT THOSE WHO
ARE WITHIN EARSHOT WILL PRESENT
THEMSELVES HERE AS QUICKLY AS IS
POSSIBLE. SO WHY DON'T WE DO
THIS? LET'S. WE WILL GET
STARTED. YES. WE'VE GOT A LONG
WAY TO GO, SO LET'S LET'S GET
STARTED. LET'S START AT THE VERY
TOP. I KNOW WE'VE STARTED TO GO
THROUGH SOME OF THIS, BUT LET'S
START AT THE VERY TOP. AND IF
MEMBERS COME IN LATER, WE'LL
COME BACK AND DO IT ONE MORE
TIME. SO COUNTING DOWN TEN,
NINE, EIGHT, SEVEN, 654321. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S GO, ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. LAIRD STERN.
STERN. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 10
TO 0 ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ZERO. CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED. NOT COMING BACK. OH,
HE'S NOT COMING BACK. OKAY. FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE, AB 1905. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
LAIRD STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB AYE. 10 TO 0. TEN ZERO.
BILLS. OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB 2587. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. LAIRD. NHIÀU
STERN. A STERN. AYE WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE FOUR FIVE. 9 TO 0
NINE ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE. AB 2326. WE NEED A
MOTION. SENATOR WAHAB MOVES THE
BILL, THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE APPROPRIATION. UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG AYE. WILK. AYE WILK
AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO
AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE.
LAIRD. NHIÀU NILO. AYE. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE. STERN Ó. AYE. STERN.
AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 10 TO 0
TEN ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX AB 2046 NEEDS A
MOTION. SENATOR ASHBY MOVES.
OKAY. SENATOR ASHBY MOVES THE
BILL. THE MOTION IS Dð PASSES
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WILK NOT
VOTING. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO
AYE. DURAZZO. DURAZZO. AYE.
LAIRD NILO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
STERN. STERN AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE 8 TO 0 EIGHT ZERO. BILLS.
OUT FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
3049. WE NEED A MOTION. SENATOR
WAHAB MOVES THE BILL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
SENATE HUMAN SERVICES. UMBERG
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WILK. AYE.
WILK AYE. ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY. ASHBY AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO DURAZO.
AYE. LAIRD. NILO NILO. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN STERN.
AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 10 TO 0
TEN ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB 810. WE NEED A
MOTION. WILK MOTIONS. SENATOR
WILK MOVES THE BILL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK.
AYE ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO DURAZO.
AYE. LAIRD. NILO. NILO AYE.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN A STERN
AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 10 TO 0
TEN ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER 12 AB 2747. WE NEED A
MOTION. SENATOR STERN, SENATOR
STERN MOVES THE BILL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS. UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WILK. NÓ. WILK. NO. ALLEN
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. ASK ÁP. AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZO LAIRD. NHIÀU NO. NO.
NILO. NO. ROTH ROTH. AYE. STERN.
A STERN. AYE WAHAB. 6 TO 2. SIX
TWO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
13, AB 2193. WE NEED A MOTION
MOVED BY SENATOR STERN. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
EDUCATION. UMBERG. UMBERG. AYE.
WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY AYE.
CABALLERO DURAZO. DURAZO. AYE.
LAIRD. MELO NILO. NÓ. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE STERN. STERN. AYE.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE 8 TO 1 EIGHT
ONE. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER
16. AB 3089. WE NEED A MOTION.
MOTION MADE BY SENATOR STERN.
SENATOR STERN MOVES THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION. UMBERG AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WILK AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZO DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD. NEVO
ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN STERN.
AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 9 TO 0
NINE ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM
NUMBER 17 AB 3281. WE NEED A
MOTION. WILK MOVES. SENATOR WILK
MOVES THE BILL. THE MOTION IS Dð
PASSES. SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
UHMC A UMBERG. AYE. WILK AYE.
WILK AYE. ALLEN ALLEN. AYE.
ASHBY ASHBY. AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. DURAZO DURAZO.
AYE. LAIRD. NILO. NØ NILO. NÓ.
ROTH. ROTH. AYE STERN. HENRY.
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE 9 TO 1 NINE ONE. BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM 20 AB 3031. WE NEED A
MOTION. STERN MOVES THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS THE SENATE
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION UMBERG
UMBERG. AYE. WILK NOT VOTING.
ALLEN ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY.
AYE. CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
RUSSELL RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD
NILO. THE ITEM IS FILE ITEM 20.
AB 3031. ROTH. ROTH. AYE. STERN
STERN. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 8
TO 0 EIGHT ZERO. BILLS. OUT FILE
ITEM 22 AB 2935. THE, CHAIR NOT
YET HAVING VOTED UMBERG. Ã.
UMBERG. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
LAIRD STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. 11 TO 0 11 ZERO.
BILLS. OUT WHOA! OH! I'M SORRY.
10 TO 0 TEN ZERO. BILLS OUT,
FILE ITEM NUMBER 23, AB 2833. WE
NEED A MOTION. THE BILL, I THINK
IT WAS SENATOR DURAZO FIRST.
OKAY. SENATOR RUSSELL. OKAY FILE
ITEM 23, AB 2833. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS. UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE.
ALLEN. ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE. CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZO Dð. RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD.
NILO ROTH. ROTH. AYE STERN.
STERN. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE 9
TO 0 NINE ZERO. BILLS. OUT FILE
ITEM 25 WAS PULLED. FILE ITEM 26
AB 2388. WE NEED A MOTION. WILK
MOVES. SENATOR WILK MOVES THE
BILL. YES THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
UMBERG AYE. UMBERG AYE. WILK.
AYE. WILK. AYE. ALLEN ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZO RUSSELL. AYE. LAIRD.
NILO. AYE. NILO AYE. ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN. STERN AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. 10 TO 0 TEN ZERO.
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 27 AB 2249.
WE NEED A MOTION. SENATOR STERN
MOVES THE BILL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS, AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG UMBERG.
AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE. ALLEN
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZO DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD. NILO.
NILO. AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
STERN STERN. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE. 10 TO 0 AND ZERO. BILLS.
OUT FILE ITEM 28 AB 2493. WE
NEED A MOTION. SENATOR STERN
MOVES. SENATOR STERN MOVES THE
BILL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS
AMENDED. UHMC Ã AYZENBERG. AYE.
WILK NÓ. WILK NÓ. ALLEN ALLEN.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO CHAPARRO. AYE.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO AYE. LAIRD.
NILO. NO. HILO. NO ROTH. ROTH.
AYE. STERN. STERN AYE. WAP.
WAHAB. AYE 8 TO 2 EIGHT TWO.
BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 29 AB 2004,
CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE. ASHBY. ASK ÁP. AYE.
LAIRD. STERN. STERN AYE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. 10 TO 0 AND ZERO.
BILLS. OUT FILE ITEM 33 AB 2202.
CHAIR VOTING AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE. LAIRD. STERN A STERN AYE.
WAHAB HARB. AYE. 10 TO 0 TEN
ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 34 AB
2377. WE NEED A MOTION. STERN.
SENATOR STERN MOVES THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. UMBERG AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WILK. AYE. WILK AYE.
ALLEN ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE.
DURAZZO. DURAZZO AYE. LAIRD.
NILO. NILO AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
STERN. STERN AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE 10 TO 0 TEN ZERO. BILLS OUT.
FILE ITEM 35 AB 866. CHAIR. NOT
YET HAVING VOTED. AYE. UMBERG.
AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. LAIRD
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB WAHAB.
AYE. 10 TO 0 TEN ZERO. BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM NUMBER 36 AB
2224. CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED
UMBERG. UMBERG. AYE. CABALLERO
CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD. STERN A
STERN. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 10
TO 0 TEN ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE
ITEM 37 AB 2499. WE NEED A
MOTION. SENATOR STERN, SENATOR
STERN MOVES THE BILL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE LABOR,
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT AND RETIREMENT
COMMITTEE. UMBERG A UMBERG AYE
WILK. AYE. WILK AYE. ALLEN.
ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY ASHBY. AYE.
CABALLERO. KOPY. EURO. AYE TO.
RUSSELL. TO. RUSSELL. AYE.
LAIRD. NILO WHICH ITEM IS THIS?
FILE ITEM 37 AB 2499. ROTH.
ROTH. AYE. STERN A STERN. AYE.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 9 TO 0 NINE
ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 38 AB
1979. CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED
UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD.
NILO STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE 9 TO 0 NINE ZERO.
BILLS. OUT FILE ITEM 39 AB 3024.
CHAIR NOT YET HAVING VOTED
UMBERG. AYE. UMBERG AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 8 TO 2. EIGHT
TWO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 40 AB
1791. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
CABALLERO LAIRD. STERN STERN.
AYE. 7 TO 2 SEVEN TWO. BILLS
OUT. FILE ITEM 41 AB 3139. CHAIR
VOTING AYE. CABALLERO.
CABALLERO. AYE. LAIRD 10 TO 0
ZERO. BILLS OUT. FILE ITEM 42 AB
2693. CHAIR VOTING AYE.
CABALLERO CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. LAIRD. STERN STERN. AYE. 10
TO 0 TEN ZERO. BILLS. OUT FILE
ITEM 43 AB 3211. CHAIR VOTING
AYE. CABALLERO CABALLERO. AYE.
LAIRD. STERN A STERN. AYE 8 TO
2. EIGHT. TWO. BILLS. OUT AND
FINALLY. FILE ITEM 44 AB 2257.
WE NEED A MOTION. SO MOVED.
SENATOR STERN MOVES THE BILL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO THE SENATE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE. UMBERG.
AYE. UMBERG. AYE. WILK NØ. WILK.
NO. ALLEN ALLEN. AYE. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE CABALLERO. CABALLERO.
AYE. GRASSO DURAZO. AYE. LAIRD.
NILO NILO. NO. ROTH. ROTH AYE.
STERN. STERN. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE 8 TO 2. EIGHT. TWO. BILLS
OUT. WE'RE FINISHED. BUT NOTE
FOR NEXT WEEK, WE START AT 930.
NOT 130, BUT 930, IN THE STATE
CAPITAL ROOM AND IN THE STATE
CAPITAL. I DON'T KNOW WHICH
ROOM. WHICH ROOM DID SHE ADD ON
A CONSENT? YEAH YES. CONSENSUS.
I THINK EVERYBODY'S ON. OH, MAN.
IT COULD BE 112 OR 113. I DON'T
KNOW. OKAY, WELL WE'RE STARTING
NEXT WEEK IN THE STATE, YOU KNOW
, THE OLD WHITE BUILDING AT 9:30
A.M. AND THEN WE WILL HAVE A
SPECIAL ORDER OF BUSINESS AT
1:30 A.M. THAT'S THE NEWSPAPER
PRESENT. I'M SORRY. YEAH 1:30
P.M. THAT'S. THAT WAS FREUDIAN.
130 IN THE AFTERNOON ON, ON THE
NEWSPAPER PRESERVATION ACT BY
SENATOR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
WE'RE ADJOURNED.